techie maybe yeah that's it'd be interesting like you know for example one of my favorite bots uh
shameless plug is dr egg bot and i would imagine dr egg bot has a cool skill like i don't know
unslop or one of the skills i made like you know and kind of like adds a bit of flavor but under
the hood maybe it has like it uses one of those one of those stats to do something yeah that could
be interesting yeah yeah i like that and so maybe it's like you you start a bot and you kind of
draft your team around it so you upload a template we can help you generate a character
maybe we add some randomness to it so every every character looks a little bit different
um kind of gives you like a little avatar in the game i think it could be fun so you get some like
visuals there uh and then maybe you know just to start off and keep this simple we have your main
bot and then a few uh additional bots that are drafted into your team so you get this team of
like three bots that you're starting out with does that seem like it could work yeah so like i guess
let's let's let's imagine like what it would look like so i i i sign up uh you know i add dr egg bot to
my team and then i have like i don't know chad bot and what's another bot that you know oh we have
our uh outbound prospecting bot yeah outbound prospecting bot yeah kind of a long term long name
outbound bot and uh so i okay i have this team of bots and i guess so how do we determine the stats
that they get yeah i think we should think through that i mean we could probably do some
we probably want it to be deterministic right so when you upload a bot into you know and generate
generate a character from the bot you basically get sort of the same stats every time and so you can
sort of mint a bot into a character and that kind of oh that's interesting yeah yeah so maybe we like
come up with some ways that we you know give a range for these stats um one thing that i've seen
work really well in games like this is where you have like a full a total stat pool so maybe we start
with a total stat pool of like uh 100 max and then we basically split this into those three stats and
you know we could maybe actually put an llm against the description of the bot so if you describe a
bot as being really charismatic or being really like you know social and maybe its job is to coordinate
people that maybe gets a higher charisma bonus or something like that uh or maybe a bot that's like
really good at connecting to a bunch of different services gets a high dexterity stat because it's
kind of like moving all around moving all around but it's still it's still fixed right so like yeah
it would be a total it would all the three stats would still total up total up to 100 yeah i like
that so maybe for an example we have something like this um 70 30 is 100 okay i guess we'll need a
minimum right yeah that's a good point so maybe because i it'd be weird to have a zero stat maybe we do 10
is the minimum uh sure or one or why not one yeah let's just go all the way to the bottom one and then
max is 98 yeah because then 98 2 2 1 1 good point yep yep and it could be just random i guess
one more thought i have that could be really interesting because like it'd be really fun if
there was a way for like when you create a bot for there to be like a almost like because you know if you
play games like diablo or um like those action rpg games the the items that you pick up have like
i think rarity that could be really interesting here like because i'm imagining like it wouldn't
be so cool if dr eggbot was a legendary legendary body come on it has to be like it has to be a
legend it has to be i kind of like that i kind of like that yeah so maybe we could have like some
randomizer where we have a rarity modifier that changes how like what this total stat pool could be
so the base version is 100 but then we could have rarity that boosts the total stat count so for
total stat points uh maybe we could come up with like a base rare ultra legendary or something like
that and kind of having that be the way we split this up and maybe we do something like 100 points
for base we can come up with the exact numbers yeah something like that i like that and i guess like
another question i have is like um well you know we're pivoting to doing doing a game studio um and i
guess if we're keeping it somewhat realistic yeah the game needs to maybe make some money yeah so i'm
kind of curious like uh you know like for games i think a lot of people a lot of gamers do not like
you know like pay to win yeah type mechanics so i'm kind of curious if you know if you have any ideas on
like how do we how do we monetize yeah in a way that doesn't make this just a pay to win yeah i
definitely agree with not doing sort of pay to win i feel like that's like as a person who loves to play
games that's like the worst thing in the world where it feels like you like a lot of those mechanics
where you have to come back and like try for the next day or get your like limited number of turns and
so i think we should make this a little less um like power in maybe like you're not paying for power but
maybe you are paying for a lot of like fun upgrades because i think a lot of the virality of this could be
where you know you build your team and then you share sort of your team on social or kind of like
draft your team and maybe over time like we'll start out with a basic version of this but you could
imagine you could upgrade your box and maybe find upgrades over time and so maybe you could pay for
cosmetics that could be kind of fun um or maybe being able to pay for you know uh like potentially
access to different battlefields or arenas or something like that that could be interesting that
could be interesting yeah i'd pay a dollar for a cool hat yeah i would totally pay for something
i don't know or like my cool hat i would be the only one who had it right that could be a fun way to use
some other apis too like maybe using the rock imagine apis yeah you know to like build some really
cool visuals and making them almost like unique items that are unique to you so i wonder if we should
try to play with that those ideas cosmetics and unique items should write some of these down so we have it for
our whiteboard i guess i'm also imagining like the the bots are like facing off each other and they're in
some kind of uh what do you call it like arena or something yeah i like that uh or like some
battleground i don't know you know something like uh like a stadium exactly yeah stadium and i guess you
could talk like kind of like what you have with sports you can have like what do you call advertising okay
oh yeah i mean that's like the classic model i guess i like where it doesn't really affect the
gameplay but you know it there's a lot of like eyeballs on that space yeah because um well one
thing i think could be interesting is like um for the ability for someone to watch somebody else's game
um so like let's say you you know you like you and i get matched up and like maybe there's a link or
something that we can share and someone can watch the replay later so maybe there's something like
that where uh it helps with the monetization as well or something i don't know yeah like we can figure
that part out i think this part actually creates a really nice flywheel where you have sort of uh folks
who are willing to you know put put ads into the game but it doesn't it doesn't change the dynamics of the game but
really because hopefully we can grow this really big and get a bunch of eyeballs on it and that would
be a great way to create a flywheel for you know the different sort of stadiums or whatever we decide
to call them and then have those be fed back in so i like it a lot um okay i feel like we have a few
ideas here and like any good you know uh company we should prototype some of them and you know maybe one of
the things that i've noticed too about especially starting zero to one is you really just care about growth and
getting getting users as soon as possible and then you know we can layer in the monetization as we go
and as we kind of get a feel for how the product comes together and so i think the last thing we
should figure out is sort of what's the core mechanic of the game um so we've talked a little bit about
these bots and they have stats and so they have these abilities that maybe they can use we'll give
them cool names as we talked about um but you know one of the ideas that we were kicking around is
maybe we could have these bots sort of face off in some way as you can kind of assemble your team and like
pit it against another team and kind of pit some of these abilities against each other what do you
guys think about that let's do it that sounds fun yeah so i just started drawing this out here as an
example of that and like obviously we have some sample stats here but you know maybe we could mix
some of these around where you had a bot who had a charisma ability and it faces off a bot that has an
intelligence ability and these stats come to bear for how those things like go head to head against
each other and like i think a pretty simple version of the game but basically we would start out with
sort of like facing off stats once against each other and we can add some cool dynamics
for you know how we modify the stats or you know uh give you maybe like how those these abilities we
could you know use an lm to help generate what they are so maybe you get like a special boost that you
like roll when you first create your bot uh and then kind of like every every one of these sort of
head-to-head things feels like it's a bit of a different a different one and um you know then you can
go watch the replay and i feel like there's something here so maybe we start out with something really
simple where you have your team of bots and you set your lineup and then we create some lightweight
matchmaking where you get paired against another team of bots they set their lineup ahead of time
or maybe you know as part of the part of the matchmaking flow and um they just kind of face
off against each other with some of these stats so it sounds like right what we're talking about is
the you know if you have a business you're selling a product or a service or maybe a good right and
the product here is a game that you can interact with and so the business is a game studio that
creates the product a game and then all of the other aspects of building a business right are pretty
much the same right so it's like okay distribution how do we get people to discover this game oh yeah
well i guess we're on a live stream so that's pretty good but then also also we could have seo and aeo
so maybe that's something i could start working on we need a nice landing page we need a way for people
to find us we might think about running some ads we might have a special guest joining us uh after
the next break they could help us out with some of that stuff exciting i wonder who that could be
um there might be we like you know maybe we hire a fourth team mate i don't know anything's on the
table right we might run some ads do we get do we get seed funding can we get an intern i mean the
question is how do you get somebody without seed funding and maybe that's the we'll answer that
question later um so uh um yeah i think that's a good start of like distribution and then right we have
maybe the other aspects which are like customer service how do people reach out and like learn
more maybe there's like an email maybe there's a phone number even that you could call um or we
source uh the chat comments like maybe maybe our uh our way of interacting with the community is just
directly through x like we pull in the chat api or something um super cool yeah and we can just like
hear what people are saying in chat yeah i like that there's probably also going to be some things
here on just like customer support and like handle questions like all the things the classical
business would need to your point of like how do we put together the operations of the business and
that can be a really fun way to bring a bunch of grok bots to bear right just like what are our
our grok bots helping us run the whole business too so we get a little bit of that angle i think
that'd be really cool sweet okay so i was i think we have a bunch of um you know buckets here we have
some monetization stuff we have some thoughts on features we have some thoughts on product needs
and then i wanted to just redraw down here um how we're thinking about the core flow so i think for
the mvp our core flow could just be you take your grok bot template you get to draft your team you set
your lineup and then you get to compete against another lineup and we'll have to do some algorithm
work i think which will be really fun to figure out how we actually handle the core game loop and kind
of ensure that these are you know balanced matches and that folks are able to you know feel like they're
winning uh kind of like creating some incentives to come back but i think if we start with this we
could really layer on a bunch of complexity to it like you could imagine we you know have stat
upgrades we change the abilities um you know we could potentially even like create different sort
of uh arenas that folks are competing in and then kind of change the properties of those over time and
i feel like we have a lot of room we could play with on this and you know one thing that i've always
felt with ideas like this is that it's really great to have a tight version that we can start with and sort of have
that be what we build with up front and then kind of you know evolve that and give us plenty of room
to evolve and so this feels like one where we just have so much potential room for creativity
it's kind of what i'm what i'm getting and maybe i'm just getting really excited about the idea but
i feel like we have a lot we could work with here i think so i think there'll be a lot of chances to
uh do some cool engineering yeah things too yeah and uh you know like dr eggbot for example brings in
one of my plugins psac yeah gotta shamelessly plug it again uh and i think it'd be kind of cool to show
off some of the like engineering workflows that i use all the time yeah to work on projects uh and apply
it here but i do think like there's a lot of this idea has a lot of room for us to show off all the
aspects of creating a product and the business and operations that go around it right because you
could easily substitute this for an app right it doesn't yeah it's like a similar process or if you
had a physical business like all of the digital operations that go on around that physical business
right so yeah exactly yeah cool um lauren do you want to take us through some of the thoughts on how we
could mvp this because i feel like maybe uh yes actually i was uh typing while you were you were
talking prompting while we were talking and i have a rough plan if we look at my screen cool
um yeah so we'll get lauren's screen up this is yeah while we wait i guess i'll just talk to it but
yeah so we did some discussion earlier so i had some idea of what the plan would be
and i used um pstack again to do my so pstack if you're not aware is my plugin that has a bunch of
my skills that i've developed for doing engineering work and um one of the things that pstack includes
is a planning playbook so it's a bit long i'm not going to go through the whole thing but you can see
that it's pretty detailed it has uh you know checklists on things like how to verify the the application
and it's got some pseudocode in there for the types because i think you know a part of how i like to work
is thinking a lot about data structures and and the type the types uh and function signatures so all that
is you know i don't want to hear i don't want to cut you off lauren but i think we actually have our
first talk going live on sales engineering right now uh so we're gonna cut over the main stage and we'll
jump back into this yeah we'll be right back
hello everybody is my mic on cool awesome welcome to day two of grokbot galaxy i'm super excited to be
here my name is amrita i am a field engineer here at cursor and we have a really great great suite of
workshops for today um we're starting off with grokbot for sales engineers and then we'll have
grokbot for sales later today grokbot for sdrs um we have uh one specific for customer support um
and then throughout all of this we'll be following along with matt lauren and roshan on how their
company is going so super exciting day thank you all for tuning in um and yeah let's get started
all right so today's session is grokbot for sales engineers um what i'm planning on doing
with today's session is kind of similar to the other ones i'm showing three bots um these are three
bots that i actually use on a day-to-day um two of them will be in a demo project so you'll see kind
of how it works in sort of a sandbox scenario and then one of them i'll show i actually use every day
for curating particular customer kind of case study slides when i need to do external facing calls
um i'll do a quick overview of grokbot for folks who maybe this is the first time turning in um or
tuning into the grokbot galaxy event um so we'll do a quick overview about grokbot i'll talk a little
bit about why we created it what makes it different from some of the other products out there and then
we'll get into the use cases that i'll talk about and then a demo and we'll have some time for questions
at the end so if you do have questions please save them for the last 15 minutes or so and we'll have
some build time for folks in person so i'm happy to come around and see how you all are using
grokbot there are little uh coasters i think at your table that show you different use cases of
how we use grokbot so if you want to scan the back there's a qr code that kind of shows you a
template of a grokbot you might be interested in okay um we showed this slide yesterday but i want to
kind of hone in on exactly what this means where we're moving towards a world that's less kind of
task-based and one-off kind of request to an ai tool and more so a team of bots kind of at your
service working together on a task um so we're really going from a you know a chatbot type world
to more like a team of colleagues and what's nice about this is when i think about grokbot i think
about a tool that actually gives me finished work um and that's the beauty of it is it's not meant to be
something that you have to constantly babysit or something that is always you know just at your
computer that you always have to keep your laptop open for it's literally meant to be like a teammate
where you know it can work maybe while you're on vacation you're away it can work while you're asleep
it can work because you can you know talk to it on your phone like you would a normal colleague
and so we're going towards a world um where that's going to be happening all the time for all different
types of domains so whether you're in sales you're in product you're in engineering you're going to have
a staff or a team of bots at your service that can help you basically accomplish work that maybe you
didn't have time for before maybe you're not looking forward to but you're also kind of having them
ready to go with the context and memory that you're kind of providing them okay so for folks who haven't
seen grokbot before um first i recommend downloading it uh it's on android ios and the mac so if you
haven't downloaded it yet please do um and it's kind of the best way to to see it and try it out for
yourself um there's a couple main things to highlight here the first is kind of the interface itself so if
you've used iMessage or maybe any form of like a chat or texting interface you'll see that it looks pretty
similar um on the left is where all your bots live um and as you can see you can message them like
teammates so you can say good morning to your bots you can thank them you can basically go back and
forward with them because they have this long-lived memory that it's able to learn from you know what
you've said before if maybe you've told it that you didn't like how it did something a particular way
it keeps that in its memory and it's able to do better the next time around and we'll see an example of that
actually in this demo um you will also see that bots have their own computers and so this is kind
of what i mean where bots are like colleagues is no longer do you have to maybe connect each bot to
every single service or provider that you want to have access to your bot can do a lot of that for
you um an example that we did yesterday was a bot making its own google form an example that i've heard
from the crowd is a bot logging into mongo db and kind of analyzing your database and making sure that
everything is you know up to snuff and then i think another cool thing about computer use is you
can monitor what it's doing in the computer itself so if for example i want to take over its computer i
totally can i can also control from an enterprise level what it has access to in that computer so if for
some reason i don't want it to access a particular website or i don't want it to download a particular
thing i can always keep that in my admin controls so that you know you don't want the bot making
decisions that you wouldn't take yourself and then automations and routines that's a huge one um i
think it's something that people constantly look for with ai tools is hey how can i automate or have a
repetitive task be done without me having to think about it um a common one that i have actually is i
subscribed to a bunch of different you know ai newsletters and podcasts and i started not to keep
track of all of them and so every morning i'll have bot actually look through my email find the
newsletters that are relevant to me and then just create them in a daily digest and summarize them
in slack and then it just messages me every morning saying hey here's what you missed from you know these
podcasts these newsletters and it helps me keep up to date but it's also something that i no longer have
to think about um similarly there's a very common like morning brief morning digest for your work if
there's slack messages that you've missed overnight um i do like to highlight that for distributed teams
grokbot is really a game changer because you can go from you know having to wait on work being done
from other teammates or other tools to just having something that's really always on and always at your
service and so that's kind of the beauty of grokbot is that it's really great for distributed teams
but also it's for it's a multiplier it's a fourth multiplier for you wherever you are um and then
the last thing is sharing your bots with others so you see here on these kind of little coasters that
we have qr codes uh that's for you know public bots that are available on the marketplace if you want
to share bots with your team at work you can do that as well uh for example we have bots that are specific
to the sales team that we all you know share there's bots on the engineering team that they share with us as
well and so bots are meant to be multiplayer they're meant to be used and shared um and also creates a
sense of consistency across the company is you know you want to make sure that let's say the the sales
bot is not using different resources that maybe someone else's sales bot is so having that consistency
of bots is also very important okay um i touched a little bit on some of this like why grokbot and what
makes it different um i think the main things to highlight here is it's very easy to use um i think a lot of tools
when you first spin it up you don't know where to start you don't know how to kind of connect things
grokbot kind of learns all of that for you um you'll see it actually when we work with a bot from
scratch today uh it will basically ask me like hey what am i being used for and how can i best help
you and we'll also do something cool we'll actually ask one of the grokbots today to spin up its own
team of bots i'm basically going to ask it hey what bots do you think would be helpful for you if i had to
ask you to hire your own team what would be useful for you and a bot can actually make that decision
and so bots spitting up other bots or bots working with their other you know teammates is what really
makes grokbot this like multiplayer fourth multiplier tool um and then as i mentioned computer use and the
fact that it can do an entire task end to end um one thing that i really like about grokbot is if i
give it a task and again it's in the cloud so it's always on i can come back and trust that the task will be done
it's not going to sit waiting for my approval it's not going to go back and forth and like should i do
this decision should i not it will finish the task and then i can tweak it or steer it however i want
but the goal is that you're not just sitting and waiting for it to get do something you're actually
coming back to finished work which really really saves a lot of time cool um so as i mentioned these
these are some sales engineer use cases that i have seen um at spacex and also three of them actually
i'll be showing today um and so the engineer technical resource david gan will probably go more
into detail about this in his customer support support session so if you're interested in that
definitely take a look um but what's nice about this is we get a lot of customer questions about
security we get questions about how grokbot was built how is memory being stored um how is it you know
what type of computer is it using is it a linux vm all these technical questions some of them are in
our docs but some of them also are just in the implementation of grokbot right it's in the
repository and so what i do as a sales engineer is i actually have a expert i call him sherlock and what
he does is he basically has access to a repository so he has access to you know the grokbot repository
and so if a customer asks me a question i can go ask sherlock hey a customer is curious like do we
support x y and z sherlock comes back but what's nice about this is i've actually steered sherlock to
make sure that he doesn't ever you know release any ip that he phrases thing in an easy to understand way
if i need to communicate this to maybe someone more high level someone that's not down in the weeds and so
that's kind of the beauty of this particular grokbot is that it's meant to understand things
technically but then phrase them back to me as to how i would you know tell a customer
and then competitive intel this is a really fun one um competitive intel is basically a bot that i
created i named it serena williams because i'm a big tennis fan and she's also very famous for studying
her competitors and watching how they play but what serena does is she actually uses competitor products
in her own computer and then tells me hey by the way this competitor is using or is doing something
different than how your product is um is that something that you want to put on your roadmap or
something that you'd want to change and we'll see an example of that today actually of serena actually
going in trying out a competitor product giving me feedback on you know what's different between my
product and theirs um and then maybe suggesting like what i can what actions i can take later um echo is
something that i think krista and mark will show in a later session it's basically live curating
a deck during a customer call really neat tool um i i don't use it often but what i usually do is before
a customer call i'll give it context i'll give it notes and then what i'll do is i have this giant
master deck of slides of anything from you know uh case studies that we've done with customers to benchmarks
everything in one kind of master deck and based on the notes that i've given it of what the customer is
interested in it'll curate those slides and basically highlight what's important in you know what the
customer wants and then now i have like a specific deck catered to that customer that i can show later
so i'll show an example of this today um but in the build session if you all are curious about this type
of bot i'm happy to build it out with you okay cool awesome so let's get started with the demo then um
we have three bots today we have mimi um she's going to be kind of the slide customer proof point
researcher sherlock as i mentioned is my technical expert um and then serena williams is my competitive
intel one um and that will be fun to see so let's see how they do all right
so the first thing i'm going to do is i'm going to show you my bots they are right here um i'm going
to start with mimi so what's nice about mimi you'll see that i had a conversation with her over
the past i think couple days and the goal of mimi if i actually click on her here is let me actually
click into sorry into her um into her description um basically what mimi does is she has access to a
slide deck so you can see it here she has access to the slide deck once the computer connects and what
she's able to do is she's able to curate the deck and create customer case studies for me so i have a
bunch of slides about you know spacex and this is what i would present to a customer but what's nice
about kind of my case studies is they all look the same right so i have one for example for starlink and
how they use spacex and this is based on a public blog post about how starlink uses you know the api
and they all look the same they all have the same template which is problem solution impact and then
a quote from the from the blog post and often what i do right is let's say i'm meeting with a hardware
customer um and i need to present to them an example of how one of our existing hardware customers has
used cursor or has used spacex i basically give mimi a blog post or maybe even notes from a previous
conversation with a customer and all i do is i basically tell her to create a slide like this
so we're going to do a live example of that um you'll see that she did one for jellyfish recently
jellyfish just did a blog post about how they use cursor for code review and so all i did was i say
hey we actually go up here i said i just want you to do your job for jellyfish and here is the blog post
and boom you know she went through she said okay here's what i'm gonna do for jellyfish based on
reading this blog post this is the problem this is the solution impact quote and then the nice thing
about mimi is again because she has access to her home her own computer she can create these slides for
me and then take screenshots so she's like okay this is you know the jellyfish logo she was able to
actually go to the jellyfish brand page get the right logo and put that on the slide and then this is the problem solution impact and quote
and so let's do an example of this live and see how how mimi does so what i'm going to do actually
so i'm going to go back to the browser here um and i'm going to take this blog post i thought it was
very apt because it's a salesforce blog post about how they use cursor to cut legacy code coverage time
by 85 i'm just going to take this guy and i'm going to go to mimi and i'm going to say
can you create another one of these slides for salesforce for me
and i'll just link the blog post here and actually i'll specifically just say blog post here so she
knows and so what she'll do and you know we'll come back to this at the end of the session to see
how she does is she'll be able to take this um create a slide from it and then you know actually
insert that slide into the slide deck here so again what i'm opening here is mimi's computer as i
mentioned i can take control of it you know i can click around in it but what you'll actually see
which is very cool is mimi will have her own cursor in here so mimi will start editing the slide
she'll give me an update on you know when it's ready and how it's doing and then once she's done
she'll go ahead and present it back to me just like she did with jellyfish so i'll let mimi go here i
just want to make sure um that she can access this um but while she's working i'm actually going to go
to the other two bots so sherlock and um and serena williams so i'm just going to switch my account
here so you all can see the other two bots um here we go so grokplot versus engineers these are the two
bots um i have something very similar to serena in my in my other account that specifically looks for
grokplot competitors and you know what they do differently um but for today i'm actually going to work
in a booking app that we at spacex just created as a demo project so the app that we actually have
is something called flylo uh think about it as a very simple booking flight booking app so basically
what we did is we've created this entire company called flylo um they're meant to book flights for
anybody you can upgrade your seat you can change your flight you know whenever you want very similar
to expedia or google flights any other flight booking app that you see um what's nice about this is you
know we have created a whole like suite of engineering products that power flylo so there's a front end
there's a back end there's a web app there's an internal app for the crew to use um and what's nice
is my grok bot sherlock bot has access to all of these things so if i actually go back to sherlock here
you can see i gave him kind of a description i said you're a technical expert on flylo and you support the
website flyloair.com um i gave him access to the particular repos so the booking back end the booking
front end um and then i also say if there's a customer issue i want you to be able to kind of
investigate and then communicate what could be wrong to a customer um so i worked with sherlock a little
bit yesterday i was just curious i was wondering hey how do we support a race condition for maybe someone
trying to book two flights at the same time or they're trying to book the same seat at the same time
and so what you'll see is that sherlock actually uses cursor cloud agents under the hood which is
what makes it um really easy and what makes it able for me to close my laptop is that sherlock is
basically able to say okay i'm going to dig into how booking handles two people grabbing the same flight at
once um you'll notice that it says here all right flylo doesn't let two different customers confirm the
same last cabin um the protection is in postgres which is good to know um and then it kind of covers two
different use cases right a last remaining ticket or if someone is booking the same actual seat what
do you do in those scenarios and then what's nice about this and this is what i would recommend for
anyone working in like a customer facing or just support role where you have to respond back about
how things work is this is what you should tell a customer is that we hold the last remaining cabin
space when you start checkout for 10 minutes and if someone else started first you know you'll get a
compliment trying to book um and so this is kind of what maybe i would even tell i can say all right draft
this is draft it in an email and send it to this customer or i can even say um okay this looks
great can you actually send it for me myself and then i can give it a particular you know approval to
send an email or a slack for me um so this is the great thing about sherlock is that it's able to be
a technical expert and answer questions for me if i'm ever you know confused about how something was
implemented inside of my product now let's go to serena um so serena as i mentioned um is a competitive
intel bot and so what she's going to do is she's going to use her own computer to test out competitor
products see how they compare it to fly low so i'm assuming she'll probably text out products like
xpedia maybe sky scanner google flights um and then also check and talk to sherlock and see you know hey
do we implement for example this whole race condition thing like does xpedia implement that or is this
something specific to just how we do it um does xpedia do it better do they talk about it in their technical blogs
um something that i do whenever i'm kind of researching competitors and want to try out what
other products are doing is i always read their change log their feature releases their blogs because
it's kind of a way for me to see like okay what are they doing differently or how are they implementing
things differently and serena can kind of do all of that for you in fact you can even set up a routine
here and say hey serena like every week maybe can you summarize uh what has happened recently with the
expedia technical blog or with the sky scanner technical blog and let me know um if they've
shipped anything recently that i should be aware of um a very common i think tool in travel apps and
websites right now it's like an ai travel agent um so what we'll do actually is we'll talk to serena and
see like hey are you able to see that in some of these other products are there products that are
doing that right now and i'm actually going to have her talk to sherlock and see what would be the
technical lift actually of being able to build like an ai agent inside of flylo um so let's go ahead
and get started here i'm actually just gonna say um what are some competitor products
that you think are worth testing against flylo
and you'll see that what's nice about grokbot is it thinks and it's able to kind of communicate what
it's saying if you ask it to but for the most part it'll actually do a lot of its work behind the
scenes um so i can always ask it sometimes which is like what are you thinking or what's going on
but sometimes what it does and because it kind of operates pretty fast is it'll tell you exactly
how it's going to go about for example testing something like this um once it's done kind of
percolating on this um so as you can see it's going to say okay i'm you know connecting i'm going to be
able to find you some competitor products um as you can see it message sherlock already um so it said hey
sherlock i'm doing some competitor product testing against flylo um quick baseline
and asked what can the current flylo booking code base support today do they search you know do they
support searching fair selection seats bags um any known gaps versus a typical booking flow that i
should weigh when i compare so again i didn't really give serena any context all i did was um if we
go back to serena all i did was give her a description and then she immediately was able to
kind of understand what she had to do um but now she's going to give me some options here so i said
let's go with let's go with southwest and spirit let's see how those booking experiences compare to
flylo and then as you can see again she will work with sherlock to kind of go back and forth so
sherlock is actually now going to say all right serena asked me for a flylo booking flow baseline i'm
going to pull what the code actually supports and then i'll reply back to her and let her know like
hey we support these things but maybe southwest and spirit airlines don't um what i'll also do while
serena is working and this is a very cool part of rockbot is i can steer her in a particular direction
so for example if i want to say um you know i want her maybe not to test just the booking flow i want
her to test like what are the agenda capabilities that are there in these flight booking apps right now
i'm going to go ahead and just say can you see if there are any
ai travel agent capabilities in any of the competitor tools that we should be aware of
and what you can also see here at the top right is that serena is actually doing the southwest
booking flow on her own and so as i mentioned a lot of times i don't get the time um or you know i
don't have the time to be able to test out booking or any sort of competitor products what like step by
step i don't get that developer experience and so what is nice is that i'm kind of outsourcing that to
serena so she can tell me hey like the the southwest booking experience it's actually great um and it's
actually a lot better than fly low and these are the ways that fly low can be better um and i don't
have to do this just for southwest i can have serena do this for a million different you know booking
flow websites and so if you're ever wondering like hey i don't have time to see what the competitors
are doing in my space or how they how they fare compared to my own product you should really spin up
a competitive intel product it's very powerful and also just really interesting to see like how these
products do in comparison to your own product here um so we can see here she's actually like
picking on dates and actually trying to see how booking works in southwest versus fly low um what's
nice about this as well is you know you can also ask it to open up another tab and do the same thing
in spirit you can ask it to do the same thing in xpedia so if there's any particular things that
you wanted to test you can actually explicitly say that inside of serena williams um uh the bot
okay cool so as i said i kind of steered her in a particular way let's say i want to you know test
something more than just booking let's say i also want to test like the ai travel travel agent
capabilities this basically allowed her to not abandon this per se but also just incorporate this
as a part of what she's doing so as i mentioned bots have memories and bots can learn but what's nice
about that is that they're also able to remember if you've asked it multiple things at once i think
sometimes what can be frustrating with other tools is you ask it a question and then you're like
actually i want to do something else but the minute you ask it the second question it forgets exactly
what the first question was and you know you can't really give it proper instructions on how you want
to incorporate both of those things grokbot is actually able to really understand that um so as you
can see here it did some few it did some like initial discussions into like what the travel agent plays
in for fly low it tells me exactly what we offer um and then it's also seeing kind of like where uh
or what i'd change for fly low here so she's able to understand my question immediately and kind of come
back to me but at the same time she's also still doing the booking flow testing that i asked her to
do earlier so it's kind of a mix of both which is really great and what makes it a fourth multiplier
is that this bot is able to multitask and do many things at once okay i'm going to check in on sherlock
here and see how he's doing looks like he's looking again at like our booking flow baseline and what
we're offering as our product you can see here that the cloud agents are being launched in cursor um so
one is being launched in i believe the back end one in the front end and i can always open them and see
exactly how they're being launched what they're doing this is kind of the integration between rock
bot and cursor is once you know we're able to get any technical information from the repo itself we
immediately can talk back to serena and give her information as to how we've implemented something
and this is great again when you want to talk to customers because a very common question i get is
you know competitive differentiation what makes one product better than the other how do you guys
implement something differently and this is where i actually work with these bots together so that they
can talk to each other understand what the competitive threats are and then see what we do in our repo to
kind of make that or assuage those worries all right so i'll let these two guys run as you can see still
doing the southwest booking here which is good i want it to be able to get that full experience let's check
back in with mimi and see how she's doing so if we go back to this account here and i open up mimi oh
let's go ahead and just resend that um and that way she'll be able to get the information from that blog post again
hopefully she'll be able to see that
what's nice about
having bots that talk to each other um i'm actually going to switch back to sherlock and serena there we go
um is once they have a conversation you can use that conversation as a template for how you want
them to interact in the future um so i showed this yesterday but if folks are curious instead
of kind of going in between both of these bots and kind of seeing what they're messaging each other
sometimes what i like to do is i put two bots in a group chat and then get that visibility of how
they message each other in one place so i'll actually put sherlock and serena williams in a chat oh
sorry looks like it put two different people one second we'll do another good chat here let's do
sherlock and ah sherlock and serena williams there we go it looks like it's automatically putting
me in another person in the chat so if i add sherlock and serena williams here basically what you can do
now if we go back to that where do we go sherlock and serena go back here there we go
now both of them are in this chat here and now i can say something like
um what have you found is the key differentiator in our competitors that would be significantly
you know low effort to build in the product and what they can do is they can basically have a
conversation with each other both based on what they've learned already so sherlock now knows kind
of that serena cares about the booking flow serena now knows that i care about you know agenda
capabilities and they're able to use the context of what i've given it already and be able to talk to
each other about all of these things in one place um and so you'll see here that sherlock and serena
williams are going to work together now to come back to me with an updated kind of response or solution
on what they think would make sense um and what's nice about this is you can basically take the context
of both these agents together and then create a pr or a product doc that you can then send off to your
technical team um and so you'll see here in the marketplace that we have a lot of different bots
that are published by you know our team members but also publicly but then we also have plugins or
tools that you can connect to that make it really easy to kind of plug in whatever you found out from
your bots into some sort of like paper trail um and so maybe what i would do here is once sherlock and
serena have come up with a plan of let's say they want to build you know a travel agent an ai travel
agent because southwest doesn't have one and xpedia doesn't have one and that would be our biggest kind
of moat what i can do is i can connect it immediately to google docs i can connect it to atlassian or
confluence if you guys use a tool maybe you guys use microsoft one note or a tool that doesn't actually
have a plugin or an mcp you can just ask uh sherlock or serena to log into that tool on their computer
and so we covered this a little bit yesterday but i want to hone in on how important it is
that a tool not having an mcp or an api is not a blocker um because that the bots have access to
their own computers they can log into whatever tools that they want or that you want on the computer
and that makes it a lot easier to integrate with tools that are historically very hard to integrate
with for example we get a lot of users that use power bi and have had trouble using ai agentically
with power bi bot can log into power bi on its computer similarly i think the mongodb example is
also great where i don't believe we have a mongodb plugin but that doesn't mean that you can't use
mongodb and rockbot anymore so again remember that if your bot or plugin doesn't exist inside of this
marketplace your bot can still use it because it has access to it on its computer i want to cover
one last thing while i'm here which is you can see that i have some private skills set up
this is one that i created yesterday which is actually showing a bot how to do a slide deck
animation what's cool about this is you can teach it multiple different skills and it can apply those
skills at the right time depending on what it should be used so we can actually teach sherlock a
task or teach serena a task for example you can see here that you know she's doing something with her
computer with booking southwest so i'll let her keep doing that but let's say i want to teach sherlock
something let's say i want to teach it um how to let me think maybe how to go and see for itself if
there is a technical post released in like the github changelog for a competitor so what i can do is i can just
take over sherlock screen um and i would recommend everyone actually doing something like this during
the build session with me it's one of the biggest lever ways to use brockbot is actually by teaching
it something via video recording and i'm just going to say teach a task and i'm going to go open up google
you can see it's pretty fast and i'm going to say something like expedia technical blog post
and then i'm just going to go ahead and click this guy i know ironic um and then we're going to scroll
in here and you can see okay they have like a medium cool and they have a bunch of stuff this is about
graphql maybe i want to search and see is there anything ai related here and then look into that
looks like nothing really oh maybe this one reimagining platform engineering for the
authentic future scroll here see exactly what they're doing and are building
and then that's it i pause it and i'm done and now what's nice about this is sherlock will now have
all the details about that skill or that video and what i can do is i can say okay you know now use that
skill and apply it to other other competitors so do the same thing for uh for southwest or for spirit
or for a sky scanner for google flights um and now it's going to be able to know how to scan technical
blogs look for ai related things you can see here it says okay the recording is finished learning the
tasks from it and then i can even highlight particular things from that skill or that video
and tell grokbot to particularly pay attention to those so i can say something like i'll use voice mode
actually for this i'll say notice that i specifically looked for ai related blog posts
in my competitor products and i wanted to make sure that we are staying on top of our ai tooling
inside of our own product so i'm going to try and apply this to as many competitors as possible
um as you can see i did this skill inside of sherlock i could have done it inside of
uh serena as well it's kind of up to you on where you think the skill will be leveraged most
but as you can see here in the marketplace the skills are basically being used by all the bots
at all times so um it doesn't matter where you create the skill the skill will still be learned
and used by by the different bots here cool okay so we're going to go back and see how serena is doing
um actually let's check on our group chat where i basically asked them to come together as a team
and figure out okay where can we actually make a change or a difference with this product
so you can see sherlock was saying okay from the code base side of things looks like uh every
competitor treats this as basic table stakes which is for managing booking on the back end uh for trips
and so that's one easy way that we can fix things also the second is a flexible date calendar looks like
this is live the front end fine already has it wired but it never calls it this would be a classic
differentiator for us and very easy to wire up and then serena says okay round trip and bags look big
but they're not low effort here the bags aren't askew i'm curious which of managed booking versus calendar
felt most people when you were on those tools so they're working together here they're kind of figuring out
um what exactly is you know the biggest lift here or what would be the easiest thing to implement
i want to notice or i want to point out something here which is that sherlock tags serena williams
in this and this is a cool way for bots again to communicate with each other is if uh sherlock exact
wanted exactly you know something specific from a bot you can either do that yourself so for example i can tag
serena myself and say hey serena i'm specifically talking to you but the bot can also do that on its
own as well and that's a really cool way for bots to communicate and specifically get information that
they need from you know a bot with memory and context on that information okay so we have these two
bots i think i mentioned earlier that i wanted to do something different which is i wanted to ask the bots
what bots would be helpful to them and i do this sometimes when you know i'm working and i have a
team but i want to see like okay what can actually what can i do to help this team and to make it you
know operate faster or more efficiently or with better memory and context so what i'll do here um is i'll
actually go let's go to sherlock sure and i can say i can say based on the work that you and serena i'll
tag serena here are doing what bots would be helpful for you to continue doing great work specifically
around competitive differentiation and sales engineering
and i'll say go ahead and spin up those bots for me so this is a little known fact which is bots can
spin up other bots you can ask a bot to say for example if you have a chief of staff bot which is
i think one of our most common bots um you could say hey i want you to spin up three bots that you think
would be the most helpful for my day to day and usually what the chief of staff bot will do is they'll
spin up like an inbox manager maybe a scheduler and maybe like a calendar manager or something like that
but i'm actually very curious here to see what the bot thinks it would be helpful in this scenario and
how exactly it chooses those bots to spin up and this is also great if you're starting out with grok
bot for the first time let's say you're a sales engineer you work at a particular company you got
the very particular workflows and you know you do demos you do particular things that are very specific
and are not you know one-to-one with what i showed go ahead and ask grok bot to spin up some bots for
you and say hey i want to be able to create a demo for uh you know a poc that i have with my ae in a
couple weeks it's for this particular customer spin up three bots for me that you think would be useful
in order for me to accomplish this task grok bot is here to help you it's not here to add extra work
or to you know give you extra managerial responsibilities it's here to tackle problems
together on the same page and so that's kind of why i like having it spin up its own bots is because
it's able to do that without me kind of having to think exactly what i want those bots to be doing
so good kind of trick if you want to to work uh on multiple things or you know whether that be
competitive differentiation creating demos uh working inside of salesforce you can do all those things
with these bots kind of here okay we have about eight or so minutes left i want to check back
in with mamie and see how she's doing um i know there's a bit of an outage earlier today okay cool
looks like she's working she says already on salesforce from your last message i'm checking
whether the pair is in yet i'm still building the salesforce pair i'll send both screenshots when it's
in the deck um looks like she's having trouble logging in again let's see if we can go back in and log in for
her so again this is an example of how you can take control of logging into uh oh look that looks
great um you can take control of logging into a uh slide or doc or anything in google drive for you
um looks like it actually created those two slides perfectly for me so if the logo was a little small
but at least it got the right logo and then what it also did is it took that exact uh same blog post
that i gave it and created a slide for me so it said here's the problem legacy repos were far below the
coverage mandate this is the solution this is the impact and this is a quote from the blog easy done
within you know the last 10 15 minutes or so and now i have a nice kind of template of a slide that i
can give let's say if i'm speaking to service now or any other salesforce competitor to be like hey by
the way we've done cursor with salesforce and they had a great you know uh use case with us so we can do
this one more time if you guys want to see it again we can just keep mimi in the loop um we have a good
use case with grab grab uses cursor grab cursor case study let's see here we go another blog post
published by grab i'm gonna go ahead and do this one last one go back to mimi here and say great work
can you do one for grab
and again as i mentioned with the steering i could have sent all of these to mimi at once i could say
hey do salesforce do grab do this other customer story that we have and then she can create all of
these and then what what i could do which is kind of what i showed earlier with the echo uh grok bot is
when i have my customer you know call or i have to present these i can tell mimi hey hide the slides
or hide the case studies that wouldn't be relevant for this customer let's say the customer is uber
they don't maybe they care more about the grab case study than they do about the salesforce case
study something similar to that um and so i can kind of send all these off again i can do these from
my phone i don't even have to have my laptop open mimi
can work on all of these case studies and all of these slides for me she knows exactly how to do
them now given that i gave her the exact template which is logo and then problem solution impact and
quote um and then i can just you know feel free to use these slides whenever i want um and that's
actually how i make a lot of my slides with uh with rockbot is i ask it to follow a template because
i don't want it to you know come up with anything too sloppy or too wordy i know exactly how i want my slide to be
organized but then once i have the content for it for example this blog post
mimi the rockbot was able to be smart enough to take the most important parts of this blog post
organize them into the right places put them into a google slide for me and then now i'm able to go to
my customer ready and prepped so it's a really beautiful end-to-end flow kind of bringing it back
to what i said earlier which is finished work is the best part of rockbot is you are no longer
spending time reading through this blog figuring out what the main points are putting that into a
slide designing the slide making sure everything looks nice getting the logo rockbot did all of
that within the last 10 to 15 minutes and it can do that for as many different customers as you want
so as you can see it says all right grab next i'm going to check that the salesforce status works and
pull that engineering post i'm actually going to say salesforce looks great you can go ahead and
start working on grab and hopefully by the time q a is over today we can see the grab slide as well
in addition to the salesforce slide but this is what i want to highlight when it comes to you know what
makes my job easier is a lot of times i have to create slides for you know sometimes 15 20 different
customers in a week and having mimi as like my slide guru but also my customer proof point reader
actually sometimes what i'll do is i'll ask her to to crawl the web and just see all of these blog
posts like the salesforce one the grab one these are not published by cursor these are published by these
companies and sometimes we don't really get updates as to when these companies publish these posts so
sometimes i'll ask me i'll be like hey have there been any customer posts recently about cursor or
spacex recently that would be good to highlight in my deck and then if so go ahead and create a slide
for it and that can that's something that can easily become a routine um and so really really great and
easy um and i just love slides that look nice you know everyone i think has seen a lot of slides that
they all look the same they all use that same purple color because they're all ai generated but
not anymore not when you give brockbot the template the memory the context of how you want things to get
done and then it's able to work off of that okay um i'll let mimi work on grab i'll come back to her
during the q a i do want to quickly go back to sherlock and serena and see how both of them are doing
as i mentioned i taught sherlock how to use that ai kind of blog skills that it's able to find out what
our competitors are doing um but you can also see here that these are the three bots that um that
my uh sherlock bot spun up so if you remember earlier i said hey based on the work that you and serena are
doing what bots would be helpful for you to continue doing great work and you can see it spun up those
three bots for me so let's see what these bots do battle card blair competitive differentiation and sales
engineering battle cards so this is useful so in addition to maybe just having customer case study slides
maybe what i can do with battle card blair is she can work with mimi and create slides against my
competitors so not only do i have case studies on what customers like cursor i can do have case studies
on you know what customers are different from cursor and what makes them different so this looks great
it says it combines serena's hands-on competitor product findings with sherlock's fly low code base
produce short se ready battle cards competitor claims fly low reality etc etc looks good i'll probably keep
her around demo drake let's see what you're up to seals engineering demo and talk track specialist build
confident no hallucination demo scripts and call talk tracks that map customer pain to the fly low live
flow ground every claim in sherlock i love this i think this is important is that it knows that sherlock
is the technical expert and so it refers to that going forward and then when competitive contrast is
needed you can pull from serena or from battle card blair so this is what i'm saying is that you have
this team now that it's all working together on the same outcome and the same projects and that makes
things so much easier when you have for example so many different things to manage or to keep track of
you get all of that here and then the last one is ai radar let's see what this one is doing okay track
competitor ai tooling from public tech blogs so this honestly is maybe a little too similar to serena
maybe i need him maybe i don't um maybe i don't want him because he doesn't have a cute alliterative name
like the other ones um but you can see here that this one prefers to you know specifically go through
engineering posts it opens each blog finds the air related posts so it's actually using that skill that
i taught um i taught sherlock earlier um and then again uses sherlock as a source of truth always and
then hands any you know testing or user user flows to serena to do on her own computer so as i mentioned you
can always spin up your own bots just by asking them to do it um a very i think common uh joke at cursor is
or at spacex is if someone asks us like can we do this i'm like ask rockbot um and a lot of times
that's how we work is there are times where rockbot will say no in fact i think that's actually a big
advantage of the rock model is it's one of the few models i feel that actually pushes back um and will
say i cannot do something it won't always kind of just be sycophantic and tell me yes or or yeah of
course you're absolutely right um and so sometimes what i'll do is i'll use you know these these bots as
my as my like as my helpers basically to figure out what else i can do next um and that's that's the
beauty of grokbot um i'll bring mimi back up but i think um we are about to wrap up pretty soon um yeah
we'll do some q a uh for folks in person but thank you so much for joining and i i hope this was useful
and thank you so much for uh thank you so much for this workshop just one question about when
the bot is navigating through another desktop yeah imagine you're locked in you're logged into your
facebook account for example yep can it be blocked because you see it's a it's a it's a just a bot or
and how can we avoid on getting banned from these um this website yeah it's a good question so i think
we all saw that i'm not a robot captcha check earlier that has come up a couple times um and you know
depending on the website and how strong their their services are for detecting bots sometimes i can't
get past those um and so it really it really depends on the website what i do recommend and obviously you
know grokbot can be used for personal use cases as well as work use cases is for enterprises we recommend
our admins kind of blocking sites like face obviously you don't really need to be using facebook and other
tools during work and so you have that option in grokbot is to block access to particular websites
on the grokbot's computer um but yeah my honest answer is that there are some sites that will be
able to tell some sites that won't um these kind of sessions that we're doing are mainly meant for the
enterprise so my general rule of thumb is if you shouldn't be accessing a website like facebook we
probably want to just block it on the robot's computer
hi hi hi um i wonder because the grokbot can use the computer use and you say it will eliminate the or
reduce the use of mcp or mcp required websites where should the next move go like creating more mcps for
bots to use or not creating any mcps that's a really good question um i do think so i i think personally
that computer use is going to become a very very big part of the ai space generally i mean we've seen it
with with other models outside of grok um and so i do think that going forward a big part of how your
work is going to get done is via computer use do i think that mcps are going to go away absolutely not
i mean the way i describe mcps usually is like their their apis for agents right and so a lot of times
when you know i use an mcp it's faster than a computer use um like if i want to for example just
immediately create a google doc sometimes i'll opt to use the google doc mcp as opposed to computer use
because right now it's faster but i don't know i i have a big feeling that computer use is going to get
a lot faster especially as models get a lot better so there could be a world where computer use becomes
the main way of of agents interacting with tools than in mcps um i will say that for now mcps are
probably a lot easier to um to monitor and to add guardrails to right like for now you know in cursor and
spacex you can whitelist and blacklist particular mcps um so that's probably an advantage for mcps for
now but i'm assuming we'll we'll start to see more guardrails being put for computer use in the future as
well it's a great question
if there are no questions i would love if anyone wanted to chime in and tell or share how they're
using grokbot it could be for sales engineering it could be for not sales engineering um i think some
of the best ways i learn about grokbot is just hearing from how other people use it so if anyone
wants to share anything or if anyone wants to chime in on things they think this demo could could help
with that'd be great yeah a question from x if grok has its own server and access to internal systems how
do you guarantee that it won't make changes to production systems won't make changes to production
systems yeah i think so i there's a very equivalent question that i've gotten which is how do we know
that bots don't you know download malicious software and do anything dangerous i think the guardrails that
we offer within grokbot enterprise are are kind of the solution for it right now um we're still in the
process of hardening those and make the making them as uh you know just i i want to say as tough as
possible so that people can still use computer use without feeling that anything dangerous might happen
um i will say that you know with ai there's there's so many different ways that something potentially
harmful could happen and we've had ways to mitigate that like skills has been a very common one which is
you know you add add rules or guardrails again making sure that no one deploys to production when they
shouldn't um something that i didn't show earlier that i'll actually show right now is if you go into your
settings um auto review is basically a tool that we use at uh at grokbot to make sure that you know things
uh are reviewed ahead of time before grokbot makes changes if i actually turn this on um you'll see
that i can make particular changes to grokbot as to how and when it can do things and so what i'll
actually say is when grokbot wants to deploy to production when grokbot wants to use an internal system
instead of doing allow automatically i should always do ask first and those are some ways that you can
actually mitigate those harmful uh you know situations from grokbot
cool i think we're going to take some more questions from from remote folks um so i'm happy to stay up
here but if anyone else from spacex wants to come and join me up here that'd be great too yeah one more
question from x what do you do if there's no mcp server and the tool you want to use doesn't run on linux
oh my honest answer is there's there's no there's no way right now unfortunately um i wish i had a
better answer for that um but the truth is our vms are linux and so you can only run tools that are
linux on these vms and if they don't have mcp servers then you're you know you won't be able to
connect them via plugins i would be curious maybe to figure out what that tool is and we can we can
figure out from there but that is that is the honest answer there check two i'm seeing a lot of
questions about token usage can you elaborate yes um so tokens and grokbot are similar to tokens and
any other ai tool um you use tokens by talking to grokbot grokbot uses tokens by talking to you
and then tokens are obviously being used when it uses its own computer um the goal i think um working
at spacex is that we are training models that will be specifically good for tools like this
to make it so that you get the most out of your tokens with grokbot and so grok46 which came out
i think a couple weeks ago um was meant to be a model that and it is a model that is inexpensive but
also highly performant so it's able to power all of these things in fact i believe the underlying model
for grokbot is grok46 and so you will see how powerful it is and also how inexpensive it is i think
i was actually looking at my usage recently of like how much money it took for me to create some of these
slides some days i think it took me to create all of this this entire slide deck i think it took me
between 20 to 30 for something that maybe would have taken me four or five hours to create from
scratch and now i can use it forever um and so i do think that you know as the models get better we're
trying to optimize for getting the most out of the product via your tokens uh but yeah everything in
grokbot is just consumption based so it's just based on how you talk to grokbot how grokbot uses the
the computer um and you can customize that for example if you prefer a particular style of
grokbot talking if you think maybe it's too verbose tell it that and then that can also help your token usage as well
so you can actually adjust um how much compute it does or how much it spins
i don't think you can adjust it's computer use that i i think is out of your control what i think you can
adjust is how it talks to you um so i i think i lauren is currently offline which is kind of sick so
we're gonna we're gonna try something new out basically what lauren's gonna do is explain to me
how to build this and i'm gonna walk through what i was doing during the break um and how i'm using kind
of cloud agents and this will be good because lauren can then tell me how to do how to do it better
basically uh a little bit of a backseat driver so um if you want to we can cut over to my screen and
i'll walk through kind of my setup and what we've been doing so far um yeah screen imminent i'm sure
um but yeah i think i think if you you have dr egg bot installed you have an engineer bot um and we
have the plan that we wrote earlier already committed to the repo so i'm thinking maybe to start i think it'd
be interesting to use like potato mode out of pstack to do some prototyping uh just like really quick and
loose prototypes that you know we don't need a login screen we don't need a even a database right now we can
just hard code a bunch of things just to visually see how the game plays and then we can kind of iterate
from there um once we get your screen up still working through some some av issues so what i've
been working on kind of during the break okay so we have my screen up uh is i've been using kind
of the way uh this is kind of lauren's setup right so i have dr egg bot that creates new bots for me
and i have my sort of founding engineer bot that's working on a landing page so basically what i did was i
i said um you know i think before we we cut out uh lauren had uh walked us through um kind of her uh
plan which so we had our repo and we had uh docs and plans and lauren was talking about our mvp right
so lauren built this document with her agent's context and one way to share information is just to
point my agent at that context as well so i said hey take a look at that document that's going to be our
game our first goal is to make a landing page and so given that it's a monorepo reader plan and propose
like a nice lander stack with my project planning skill so i typically look at my project planning
skill i basically say this is what i want for every new project i create and if i'm owning the landing page
i want um basically uh an official i like to use scaffolds because like we got to move fast here we're
not writing our own stack so usually something like t3 tan stack um if it's like a react native app maybe
expo next really like or if it's just simple it could be v right um and then i have a bunch of
other like opinionated uh ui guidelines and styling guidelines that i like to spin up in my new
projects um and then i also really like this make interfaces feel better skill i find it's pretty good
for like ui polish and some of the smaller details so i said hey just like start read these things
reading these things and also lauren shared context and then make a plan with our end skills for
um what a lander would look like are those skills published anywhere by the way these these are um
project planning is my personal skill and then make interfaces feel better is a design skill
oh man it's gonna be tough i wish they i wish they had like the the author gave me credit but someone
on twitter made this and it's really good so okay um i'll just see if we can find it i don't want to
say the wrong person yeah off the top of my head but make interfaces feel better if you look that one
up you should find it pretty easy um so my sort of mvp here um is just like a bun based lander with
create next app um and i kicked this off kind of without anybody else knowing so lauren can critique
my my sort of like architecture here but it's like basically pretty pretty like uh pretty lightweight
and one of the things that i always like to include in my new projects is like og meta tags and
just like basic site meta information if you're unfamiliar meta information is like um the the if
you google search a site like the title and the description and then also the image if you like
post something on twitter that you see so it adds a really nice kind of level of polish so what it did
was i like approved this uh and it was actually nice because grokbot made it the right correction
which was that it actually started to applying like salt subtract before you add principles like
simplify things like removing off removing a waitlist we really just want like a a v1 um and then i i
kicked it out to a cursor cloud agent with a pstack prompt uh to start working so like my agent will
start using potato mode if i'm is that the correct terminology like should i say use pstack do i say use
potato mode yeah i would say use so in in graph bot you can type slash potato mode so you can also do that
you like use slash potato mode okay i see um but yeah you can actually even if you're just saying use
potato mode your agent or bot should be smart enough to know what that means um since it has
access to the pstack plugin and can see like oh that's what you meant um so yeah and i have cursor
configured obviously we're using grokbot for most of the building but grokbot is essentially a
lightweight harness and cursor is a coding harness and so it can be useful for grokbot to do um some of the
the conversation the back and forth and then use cursor to do the actual engineering and the coding
um and all these agents are running in the cloud so similar to grokbot actually none of this is
happening on my desktop which is kind of nice um you can see my workspace is still getting set up here
and some of the environment setup is still being done uh but in the meantime basically we have our
lander uh getting spun up and then the other thing i was working on in grokbot was with my sort of
creative director bot here i was thinking about visuals right like what is our game going to look
like so um there's a really awesome tool out there called dial kit which allows you to customize uis
and it's open source it's really great for designers and i was like oh well like what if
we started prototyping assets and then we use these sliders to be able to play around with like flat
um svg tokens and like i've never built a video game before you've probably heard roshan and lauren
talking about video games i'm like i don't i don't even really like i don't even know about game design
i'm like a total you know a total noob to video games so i'm like hey do research on how these things
work i've used phaser before for some like cool visualization stuff so i'm like okay like start
there like i know what that thing is and from there grokbot's like backing into the these these
technologies so every research project i do like every time i'm trying to build something i'm like
okay if i don't know about it help me understand it um and super auto pets which might be misspelled
here like miscapitalized or whatever is something that lauren recommended that we like we look at for
inspiration for like light and kind of fun graphics um and so from that i backed into through the same
like engineering process an asset playground and that's also um working cursor uh so we have our asset
playground um and then we also have um the lander that should be running here as well so that's kind
of where i'm at maybe lauren you can direct me on uh uh how to start with dr eggbot here to spin up
another engineering bot that builds the infrastructure yeah i would i would ask dr eggbot or even your
chief of staff to talk to dr eggbot if you want it depends like who your main bot is and where all the
context okay is so for example from my setup i have my chief of staff steve who has all the context about
the project like you know all our credentials like what the game we're building is and then steve works
with our other bots but you could tell basically i would say something like you know tell dr eggbot to
create a engineering bot for me this engineer will um we say if i use pstack and potato mode to spawn cloud
agents to work on our game and you can say that the job of the engineer bot is to the job of the engineer
bot is to orchestrate these cloud agents and supervise them and check their work um for the first
phase of what we're doing today we're going to do some prototyping that's not all the engineer bot will
do but we'll focus on you know quick lightweight prototypes just so we can um just so we can get a
visual feel of how the game plays before we start building out the real you know like we don't need
login yet when we don't even know if it's fun so i want to iterate really fast on the mvp of the game
and have like the sliders you were talking about where we can tweak things like the visuals or even
the game constants could be interesting but yeah that's the start of a bot that does that and dr eggbot
try not to make this engineer too prototype focused uh make it durable enough that it can do prototyping
but also the serious engineering work we'll do later cool transcribing um you gotta love it ah so we're
ripping yeah my my favorite pattern as well is like add to the end like restate this in your own words
before you start working just so you can confirm right because it's that's a big blob of text i feel
like that's what you know if you were talking to somebody and you wanted to make sure that they
understand what you said you could say like hey you know restate this in your own words i was like i mean
come that would be kind of awkward to tell someone you know it's awkward but that's like that's what
active listening is yeah that's true while you guys were doing that i actually got the visual
playground running locally if we want to take a look at that yeah sounds good maybe yeah see if we
want to play with some of these sliders i'll juggle some of this stuff and we can maybe cut over to
roshan's laptop and see what uh what he's working with yeah can we switch to my screen please if we get this
chance um i know this was something you just kind of put together pretty quickly matt and i haven't
used this before but i uh look like we could maybe play with some of the the properties here and i love
i love these sliders this is really fun um so you can maybe tweak some of the icons obviously this is
a really lightweight and we probably want to think about how we evolve these icons a little bit but
we have some good sort of uh like initial cut of of the of the structure um i guess these are the bots
it looks like and so maybe we have bots like this it's kind of hard oh yeah let me zoom in yeah
totally um how's that um you probably want them to look more like bots right yeah i think currently
they look too abstract yeah but um i kind of like it yeah we should we should make them look that's
interesting actually i didn't think about the color having a meaning yeah um but that could be kind of
cool yeah do we think we should maybe we should prompt do you have a bot that was helping with the
visual system and i wonder if we should prompt that one too maybe i would say my suggestion is let's
just get the bait the most basic prototype up first so that we can actually all contribute to the
code base um i think it'd be kind of complicated to build this part and the prototype at the same time
um but i think it's a good start and another thing we might want to have this system do as well is uh
tweak some of the in-game constants that we said like you know we mentioned earlier that
um there's this like rock paper scissor thing that goes between charisma int and dex and i wonder that
if the bonus being 22 percent if something if we can tweak that on the fly and just replay again and
see how oh yeah that lets us get into this really nice iteration loop right where we don't have to
like you know wait for the agent to go off and do something we can actually just tweak the values in real
time right and see the result live yeah and i guess this is really nice quick loop to make like we need
to shorten the time to fun yeah yeah yeah something like that would yeah i like that that'll also give
us like some ability to test different mechanics maybe as well so we can like if we had a playground
where we could tweak some things and see the impact on the game something like tuning the game state and
game behavior will be really important here too so yeah yeah yeah cool how's your how's your bot doing
my bots are working just in progress do you want to open them up and we can just take a look and we
can kind of uh introspect cool um so yeah i don't know are we what are we doing here we're sticking on
russian screen we're going over to my screen i'll switch over to mass screen oh yeah yeah
should we cut over to mass screen show some show spots awesome
there we go perfect okay cool so i'm working on like some preview deploys here um so i think uh we're
just gonna do a quick um like preview uh which is what cursor is working on in the background um this
we look at the prototype the prototype uh so dr eggbot's still kind of working on restating this in its
own words here yeah we're having some uh so hopefully we'll have an update there uh it's running a little
still waking up this morning um the founding engineer is working on the this this preview deploy and uh we
should have that up shortly and we also have our growth engineer uh who's working on a few other
things maybe something a little fun that i worked on this morning completely irrelevant and not related
to building things is i got all the bufo uh meme uh slack emojis in our inner slack so what i did was i
actually had um a grokbot rip those off the the website and uh download a directory of pngs and then
rather than uploading you know setting custom slack emojis myself um i just asked uh i asked grokbot to
find a way to use computer use uh to go and add all the bufo emojis so now we have a complete pack of like
12 1200 uh bufo emojis in slack so while the rest of the team was doing work i was kind of goofing off
and uh you know this is uh this is life of a of a dev roll basically um so yeah that's a few other
things we also have our knowledge-based uh bot that started working on updating our notion um with our
company doc so now we're working on our game design studio we still have some objectives but we're
documenting the pivot uh and eventually like what our go-to-market strategy might be um it pulled the
product plan with the core loop into notion um and so with our kind of like knowledge worker bot here
we're managing some of those things as well awesome yeah so now we're just uh we're waiting on the
box to to get to work here seems like uh we might be uh chugging along
so some of the things i'm thinking here to do
basically um i'm working on the landing page and then up next is probably like aeo seo stuff
and maybe a b testing stuff so these are the next things i'll direct my bot to work on and then like
whatever marketing looks like which i think we can kind of figure out based on our uh like lean in
uh to existing distribution um we'll need to think about like our ads infra as well these are some old
notes i think um and yeah maybe we could cut off my screen momentarily
yeah computer computer trouble is not fun
so sweet yeah and i think we're just gonna be cranking on building out that stuff for a little
bit so um yeah if you're if you're just joining in we're working on our game studio and our first game
uh we're just cranking along this uh this this morning live build day two i just had a bot do some
updates to notion as well so i think we'll check that that knowledge base going uh put in the diagram that we
drew earlier today so we have that as a reference for any future bots that need to
learn about the business that'll hopefully help a little bit cool
um i guess while we're waiting for our bots to
to work i wonder if i can go on a bit of a tangent and talk about some engineering things
um should i do my talk um yeah i mean we can just we can just work or you can do the talk it's up to
you we don't have to be talking all the time we gotta get some stuff done too
all right guys i think we're having some technical difficulties we're gonna be right back with you in a bit
Thank you.
Welcome back, everyone.
And again, if you're not familiar with GraphBot and Cursor, so Cursor is like more of the coding tool and GraphBots for general bots, I guess, for doing knowledge work and things like that.
So, they work really work really work, but they work really work, so I'm going to work, but I'm going to work really well together, but now I want to kind of iterate really like on the engineering work, so I'm going to switch to Cursor for a minute, and I've kicked off a local agent.
So, so I'm going to work and I'm going to work, so I'm going to work, and I'm going to work, so I'm going to work, so I'm going to work, so I'm going to work, so I'm going to work, and I've got it to restate in its own words what the game is, so I can just double-check that it understands the game, so I'm going to just read through and see if it makes sense.
So, we've got a short competitive loop, not another.
Okay, so the player logs in, imports a bot, we get a three-player roster, the lineup is hidden for your opponent, match another account, okay.
Good, it caught the elo part, which is really important.
Yeah, the elo part is interesting, because I have never designed a matchmaking system, but I've played games like Marvel Rivals that have some papers out there, so I'll just like maybe just use that as a reference.
I'm sure we will iterate over that, but we're just going to keep it simple for now.
But the elo rating is essentially kind of like a score, like almost like a chess rating, where you kind of, the more games you win, your score goes up, but there's like a factor as well, like depending who you get matched against.
So, the score might rise by a smaller amount or a bigger amount, and so on and so forth, just to keep it interesting for the matchmaking.
And then there's a bunch of sign-in stuff that I want to skip for the prototype.
So I'm going to say, I'm going to tell it like some notes here.
Let's just say, for the prototype, let me make this bigger, let's skip sign-in for now, just focus on the green loop, so we can iterate on it quickly, and then use potato mode prototyping.
I want to have a few different prototypes to choose from, and then let's keep everything local for now, no DB required, and I also want to say, include some debug panels,
where I have sliders and input boxes, where I have sliders and input boxes to tweak game variables and constants for the quick iteration loop.
And you have a prototyping section of potato mode, right?
That's when you say use potato mode prototyping, that's like how the agent knows what to do there.
Okay.
Yeah.
Cool, cool, cool.
So the idea of prototyping for me is that the thing that's important for me right now is like, or at least when I think about games, right, the point of the game is that it's fun, and all of the other stuff is not even important if the game isn't fun.
Okay.
So I want to just really cut it down to just the core loop.
And actually that reminds me that we're going to need some bots from seed, some bots from xai, botch marketplace, as our default set of bots.
And I think, yeah, let's just go with that.
But while that's working, yeah, the point of prototyping for me is to quickly get to the fun part.
And I asked it to build those sliders because I want to be able to tweak things in real time and just like replay the game so we can just quickly see if like, is this actually fun?
And if it's not, we can think about how to make it fun.
Yeah.
I like that strategy.
I feel like it sort of gives us the ability to not just build a prototype, but like, let us tweak the prototype without having to like prompt a bunch back and forth all at once and sort of like give us the, give us the little playground that we can use to actually tweak our MVP live.
I feel like that'll let us iterate a lot quicker, which is great.
Yeah.
Something cool, I guess I can talk about as well.
It's just like how potato mode works if you've never used it before.
So potato mode is, how do I explain it?
It's kind of like a router skill.
So the skill itself has not really many very specific instructions, except that for different scenarios, use these skills and these principles.
So in Pstack, we have these things called principles, which describe some principle for it.
So for example, experience first is like this really short skill that talks about, you know, choosing the light when you're implementing things like instead of implementation convenience, choose user delight.
Every feature needs to be justified, you know, ship less, but ship better and prototyping, right?
So design decisions are cheaper and throw away HTML than production code.
So I feel like that's really important.
Again, so we can kind of iterate quickly.
And it looks like our agent is going to iterate on just a simple in-memory object with some seeded bots, three-slot lineup.
And okay, now it's going to, oh yeah, here, this is something that potato mode also does is that it, it has a architecture skill that's called architect.
And this skill will use different models to come up with different plans.
So as you can see, we have four different models here, Fable, Sol, Grok, and Composer.
And we're essentially going to like erase them and see who can come up with the better architecture.
And we'll pick the best one and merge in any other interesting ideas from the other one.
And hopefully these are quick enough, but we're going to wait for the other candidates to finish before judging.
But I don't know if we really need this for the prototype, but I'll let it run anyway.
But this is pretty helpful in general because different models excel at different types of tasks.
And when it comes to things like architecture, sometimes you want to think about, like you may have different constraints or different criteria that you may not have thought about.
So having different models kind of swarm on them and think about them, that'd be pretty helpful.
But I'm going to actually say, let's skip the architect.
And while you're typing there, for those who are joining or are just hopping into the stream, we are in the middle of our three day sprint here to ship and launch a real product.
We're working on a game studio with our first game being built live.
And you're watching Lauren demonstrate how to use potato mode, which is a plugin that's available for Crock-Bot and Cursor to help drive your own software development projects.
And so it's all stuff you can go and use on your own.
And yeah, we're just cooking and building a really quick prototype as soon as we can.
We get a feel for how that works and feels and hopefully be able to iterate from there.
Yeah.
And I'm just telling my agent to skip the architect skills since that's going to be a little bit slower.
And we're just prototyping anyway, so I don't actually care about the architecture at this point.
I'm telling it to use Grok for the first prototype and then we're going to run it locally so we can actually play it.
And if you're not familiar with Cursor, Cursor has an inbuilt browser, which is really nice.
Oh, I have a favorite in here, Subway Surfers.
I won't play that.
Speaking of games.
Yeah.
Sometimes when you're just waiting for agent, like what do you do, right?
Like you go scroll X or you play a little game and I just so happen to have Subway Surfers in there.
But let's see how fast it can go.
We can also just, oh, there you go, Grok's completed.
It came up with, oh, it came back with a design.
You can take a look at the design and see what it came up with.
So the throwaway prototype is going to be just vanilla, HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
Makes sense to me.
Keep it simple.
Everything's going to be kept in memory.
We'll have three different UI variants that we can try out and toggle between them, which is nice as well.
It's going to fetch the list of bots from the marketplace as our mock seed data.
And then we have some-- this code is not very interesting because it's just vanilla.
But it makes sense to me.
It's kind of data-driven.
So let's see.
Oh, it's come up with some data shapes as well.
So that's something that we talk about in the potato mode skills is thinking a lot about data structures because that determines pretty much everything.
So it's got a bunch of types set up here.
All makes sense to me.
Oh, it's even come up with state transitions as well.
That's cool.
Almost like a-- what do you call it?
A state machine.
And my brain farted for a moment.
But yeah, I can't wait to see what it builds.
Oh, this design is pretty comprehensive, actually.
It's very long.
It's also got alternatives considered.
Let's see.
Three independent page prototypes.
Each with a copied student combat.
Live computing result with no snapshot.
Well, these are just implementation details.
I don't care about this right now.
Maybe I'm curious, Lauren, like when you're typically working with these bots, when are you sort of actually inspecting the output versus sort of letting the bots cook?
Like how do you think about sort of, you know, interacting versus delegating?
That's actually a really interesting question.
Because for more mature code bases, I feel like-- so like when I work on GraphBot itself, for example, a lot of my time is now spent on sort of GraphBot architecture.
And I'm not really observing or micromanaging the agents as much because a lot of development has already gone into creating an agent-friendly architecture for those bots.
But for a new project like this, I actually want to be kind of in the loop so I can observe, right?
Like what are the mistakes that my agents keep making?
And it looks like it already has that here.
It sounds like because we're in the more zero to one early life cycle of the project, it's a little more important for us to be in the weeds.
Kind of like reading the output, making sure the agent doesn't go off in the wrong direction.
Exactly.
And kind of come back later.
Yeah.
Okay, so how does this work?
Got a pool of bots, some lanes.
Okay.
Oh, I see.
I guess it's just like-- it's come up with some random-- oh yeah, okay, that makes sense.
So yeah, this UI is extremely bad right now, but it's good enough for me to actually just think about how the game's actually going to work.
We have some seed bots here.
And actually, let me take this figure so you can all see it.
So I'm going to, of course, pick Dr. Eggbot.
And we talked about how the other two bots are randomly chosen.
It looks like we have three common bots, so we didn't get very lucky.
Yeah.
And then we'll obviously come up with proper visuals for this, but right now you can reorder.
Do you guys have opinions on who should go first?
How should we order our team?
I like Outbound Prospecting first, the salesperson in me.
Well, Albound Prospecting has 72 charisma.
Okay.
But--
Look at the Riz on Albound Prospecting.
But it only has--
A deck skill.
The ability is hustle and it's dexterity-based.
Yeah.
Dr. Eggbot has Riz.
Unreal.
I'm actually noticing a bug here where the numbers are more-- don't add up to 100.
Oh yeah, that's a good point.
That's a good point.
So let's actually fix that.
So the stat, the total stat should add to 100 for common bots.
I think what's cool about this process too is like we're building a lot of scaffolding
and then eventually this is sort of scaffolding the agent can drive.
So if we kind of give the agent like, you know, some sort of playground,
it can also verify its own output.
And it probably won't look just like this, I think.
But I think we're sort of like starting to build a lot of foundation here.
It's really cool.
And actually, let me open this in the--
Oh, great.
Yeah.
Oh, it already did.
I'm going to hide that.
I'm going to close this.
I'm going to get more real estate here.
While we're waiting for the bot to make the changes, it looks like it gave us a pretty good debug panel as well.
We can just like tune the advantage.
The slider is so wonky.
Look at that.
Oh, wait.
It reminds you of that website where people show examples of the worst possible UI.
Yeah.
We'll need to pick that.
That's a very weird slider.
But I mean, it's got the numbers right.
So common cap.
Yep.
It's got it all set.
The bug right now is that--
Okay.
Just reloaded.
Now it adds up to 100.
Nice.
Okay.
So that looks correct.
Should we get the--
Oh, actually, let's show the design mode.
Let me--
So in cursor, very, very, very cool feature is if you open your app in the cursor browser and you click on design mode, you can actually click on the elements directly and tell your bot.
So the bot knows exactly what you're talking about, and I can tell it here, there's this input is weird and doesn't slide correctly.
Please fix.
And it lets you stay in the flow, right?
Because you can just quickly like, okay, that is a bug.
We'll need like quickly add, you know, get that in there.
I don't know, like maybe--
I think that's good for now.
I actually want to play the game.
So we have--
Okay, let's go with Dr. Eggbot.
Let's just go with the default and just fight and see what happens.
So in this first prototype, so I guess the way how games work, I've never really built any games, but the way I imagine that they're coded,
is that you have obviously the graphics, right?
And then you have your main game logic, and they don't necessarily have to be, I'd say like blocking each other, if that makes sense.
In this case, what I'm imagining for a game is the game could actually resolve instantly once the matchmaking is done, but we just show an animation.
Right.
And we play--like when you replay a session, it shows like--
Yeah.
Well, later on we can add graphics like, you know, Dr. Eggbot used Riz, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And has a cool animation.
I like that because I like the sort of the point of the initial game is that sort of once you set the lineup, the action resolves automatically, right?
And so we don't sort of need to like wait for resolution.
So we'll like know the results as soon as the matchmaking step is done.
And so I think if that's the case, then really just a matter of like figuring out how we want to add some, you know, some fun to that, whether it's animations or other things.
Yeah.
It's actually kind of nice.
It'll give us the option to sort of build that over time and evolve it over time if we want, so.
Right.
How do I make a new game?
Let me do.
There we go.
Cool.
It looks like every time you're hitting that, it's randomizing our team a little bit, which is nice.
Yeah, but does it randomize the opponent?
I guess not.
Oh, there's different--oh, okay, never mind.
Some boards.
I forgot it gave us different UIs to choose from, too.
My sister.
Okay.
What do you think so far?
Like, did the mechanics make sense, I guess?
Yeah.
Do we think it's getting it right?
So I guess for the first, like, let's look at that first one with critique and research.
Is it charisma?
Is it bonus?
That looks like the bonus logic is there.
It looks like we have the base that's there.
Yeah, we can simulate a bunch of games, which is nice.
That's actually really helpful to be able to simulate that advantage slider.
Why is it changing?
Yeah, it's actually interesting because if we go back to the site, we can actually see the bonus taking--
Mm-hmm.
This actually turned the game around.
Where round one, Dr. Eggbot actually lost with the 22% advantage.
Right.
Since it was, like, dex versus int.
And so project managers int went up to 18.3 because of the advantage.
And so it won.
So I feel like the base logic kind of makes sense to me.
Yeah, I think so too.
I think we have the, like, core logic loop here.
It'd be cool to figure out, like, how do we start to translate this into, like, something that is a bit more, like, of an actual prototype that we could play.
So maybe that would be the next thing.
Or what do you think was there?
Yeah, I'm really wondering if we can do a workflow, like, you know, use image generation to come up with mock game screens for a game.
I guess, like, I keep going back to super auto pads because I think it's, like, a really good reference.
Yeah.
But look.
Oops.
Up.
Back up.
On the web.
For images.
For, I guess, a visual reference on how bots look like.
And I want to essentially have a few images we can use for just starting to brainstorm, okay, how is this game actually going to look?
Because the core logic makes sense.
But obviously, we don't want to just play a game with, like, that looks like this Kanban lord.
So let's get it to create some images for us so we can start thinking about how it'll actually look.
Cool.
Yeah, I'm curious if both of you have thought about how, like, a visual style.
Yeah, I was actually working on that a little bit in the background and have something—it's very vibe-coded and it's just, like, little dots on a screen.
But I started to like the way it was evolving a little bit.
I know, Matt, you've also been thinking about visual styles a bit.
But yeah, I don't know if we wanted—I think it's worth trying to generate something now that we have the scaffolding and then maybe we can apply some visual layers on top and kind of, like, apply the polish to it.
Yeah.
Cool.
Maybe—
What are the mock-ups that you use to do?
I'd be curious to look at them.
Yeah.
Well, I have a really lightweight one.
Can we share my screen for a second?
Can we share my screen for a minute?
This is very vibe-coded, but I sort of was working with the bot in the background as well, trying to see if I could prototype something just to get a feel for how the core game loop might feel and just think about the product experience.
And so, in this case, the bot sort of made a binder of possible bots.
Can you use them in?
Oh, yeah.
And you can kind of see, like, in this case, it rolled a few that are, you know, like, legendary, common, etc.
Ooh.
And it just gave us some screens for how this could look.
And I don't know.
Sometimes I find it helpful.
Maybe just, like, we can get some inspiration from a few other ideas.
But, you know, we can unlock our bot order and kind of slide them around, which I think is kind of cool.
And we could probably make this drag-and-drop.
You know, right now it's not really a drag-and-drop.
And so you should probably think about how we do that.
But, you know, we can choose different.
Like, if we have a team, maybe we could have a team more than three.
But I think we said we're going to start with three first.
We kind of start with that.
And we can, like, lock in our order.
And then I kind of like this visual as well.
Kind of like seeing how the different bots would line up against each other.
It's a little like, you know, we could show some information about the rules and maybe the conditions.
Again, this is sort of a really just a vibe-coded prototype.
But, you know, this could be a cool way to kind of show the lineup and kind of what happened in the lineup.
I like this.
I think this looks good.
Yeah.
And what's cool about these is, you know, each one of these can have its own replay IDs and these kind of static assets that could be then shared later on.
And you kind of see the result as the next slide.
Here's sort of who versus who.
And then how the ELO score is calculated and then kind of getting a replay ID or something.
This is all obviously fake.
Yeah.
And then being able to maybe, like, go into your binder of cards and kind of see who you've drafted so far.
So, yeah.
I don't know.
I feel like there's something here.
This might be maybe some useful inspiration.
Nice.
So, actually, I think while we're building this, we have an interesting story to cut out to.
One of my favorite local coffee shops actually is a big GrockBot user.
Oh.
So, yeah.
Good friend of mine, Marcel, I bumped into him in the coffee shop one day and he was using GrockBot.
We ran a little story on him.
So, I think when we get a chance, we're going to cut over to the story of Icon Coffee in San Francisco in Potrero Hill and how they're using GrockBot to get more done.
Love it.
I'm going to cut over to the story of Icon Coffee.
I run the coffee program.
This is kind of serendipitous, right?
I live in the neighborhood.
I've been coming here for a few years.
And I bumped into you in the coffee shop the other week.
And I saw you were using GrockBot.
Yeah.
I think it was that same week my son started school.
All these emails come from the school.
And here's GrockBot, right?
And I'm like, you do it.
I gave it access to the parent portal.
And all the messages come through.
And the bot just kind of organizes for me.
I like to say like removing the noise
and just kind of focusing on the signal, right?
So after testing it out using my personal life,
I was like, okay, let's see what you can do at work.
You know, Icon is more than just a coffee shop.
We also have a roastery.
We source, we roast.
And, you know, there's just a lot of moving parts.
So his name's always been Rex.
I'm always like, hey, Rex.
Or, you know, we're always just hanging out
and just talking in the car.
And so Rex has always been kind of like my chief of staff,
per se, for here at the company.
We gave it API access to our POS system.
We're able to get reports, metrics.
I can be on my phone.
I can be on my computer and be like,
how did we do two years ago?
Like, what kind of growth are we seeing?
Or when we were optimizing our menu for the cafe,
I took a picture of the menu, uploaded to GrokBot.
These things right here, we've only sold X amount
in the last X amount of months, right?
I'm like, okay, that doesn't make sense.
Let's get it out.
My son's about to be 10.
That time is so precious.
An extra hour, two hours in my day
where I could just like, oh, I don't have to do that anymore.
Right?
This repetitive task is now, you know,
HomeBot's got it.
My GrokBot's got it, right?
So it's just, it's lovely.
Definitely feels like living in the future, you know?
I think we're getting there one step at a time.
For sure, brother.
So yeah, I mean, I think it's super cool to see how Marcel's using Bot
not only in his personal life, but also in his business.
What is your favorite thing to get from Icon Coffee?
Favorite thing?
I'm a huge cappuccino guy.
Okay, okay.
Very good.
Very good espresso.
Very good milk-based beverages.
Okay.
Consider the recommendation.
Yeah, yeah.
Awesome.
Cool.
Well, I think when we left off,
we are making progress on our game studio and game
as our business that we're building over 72 hours here.
We have done some prototyping, which is really great.
We kind of built a little bit of a debug tool
so we can kind of see the impact of some of the various game mechanics
on the actual game we're building.
And then I think when we left off right before showing Icon Coffee,
we were generating some images for how we might think about some of the art style
and maybe being able to tweak that later on.
So maybe, Lauren, what do we have?
Yeah, let's get our screen back on.
I have some...
I don't know if I like these mocks yet, but it's something.
I feel like right now it's very text heavy.
Yeah.
But we can kind of tweak it.
I love how colorful it is.
Yeah, the colors are nice.
Although...
Yeah, I think it's like a bit overwhelming at the moment.
Yeah, yeah.
But we can tweak it.
This is cool.
I actually really like this one.
Maybe the font size needs to be adjusted, but like...
You know how...
I don't know if you've ever played, like, gacha games.
Probably not, Matt.
The gacha game is like this concept where you...
It's usually a mobile game.
And the game is about, like, getting characters.
And then they have, like, different...
When you pull a character, it has, like, a different variety.
And they have, like, a cool animation that shows up.
Maybe we could do something like that.
That looks kind of interesting.
I kind of like...
I feel like I like this design.
It's, like, really cute.
You see, like, our little gacha has a little ribbon.
And again, very text heavy, but...
Yeah.
I feel like we could work with that.
We can tweak it.
I like the idea of actually almost, like, having your team all be one color as well.
That might be a cool way to, like, make that look interesting.
So...
There's also this really cool...
This is, like, one of my favorite things.
There's this...
Someone made this CSS library that...
Oh, that's cool.
...applies this cool visual effect to them.
And I was wondering, like, maybe that could be cool to add to our bots as well.
Especially for the rares.
So I've got it going up and building the...
Let's build that visual prototype now.
Now that we have this...
Seems to work.
Yeah.
We can always skin...
We can always, like, change the...
You know, the design later on too, right?
But I feel like if we can get sort of the container sorted, then we can go in and tweak that.
Yeah.
Cool.
So yeah, I guess our next step is we're gonna start actually building out the prototype.
Looks like we're also just making a quick...
A couple of quick tweaks here as well to the prototype.
Yeah.
I'm telling it to...
Oh, I told it to apply the Pokémon CSS.
So we'll wait for that to happen.
Cool.
And then I'm also asking it to start implementing, like, start working on the visual changes to that you generated from the images.
Oh, I can start to see...
I started to see some shinies over there.
I think we're getting...
We're getting set up.
Oh, wow.
That is...
That is very shiny.
We might...
We might need to...
We might need to do this.
Oh my gosh.
It's crazy.
It's kind of way too shiny, but we can play with that.
Also, it's like...
It's...
Yeah.
Like, why are they all rainbows?
I don't know if the agent fully understood the assignment on that one, but we can...
Well, I mean, I did tell it to do the...
I kind of steered it badly, I think, because I told it...
I got kind of nerd sniped, like, ooh, it'd be kind of cool to add this CSS.
So what I wanted to do was, like, apply that to the visual prototype we built.
Yeah.
So now I'm telling it, okay, actually go off and, you know, do the visual changes.
Cool.
So I actually like reading the thinking block.
I don't know if you ever do this, but it's collapsed.
I think there's a setting you can do in cursor to show them.
I like to have them hidden by default, but sometimes I'll just click on them because I'm very...
I'm always curious to see, like, how the agents are thinking about things.
And fun fact is, like, a lot of the skills I made were inspired by just, like, looking through these thinking blocks.
Yeah.
Like, just listening, like, wait, why are you...
How did you determine that when you never actually looked at the code?
Yeah.
You know, so...
Well, I think I've also seen you share this advice, which I've used a ton, which is, like, anytime you see the agent think incorrectly,
that's probably a good opportunity or chance for you to, like, build a skill to fix it, right?
Versus just, like, you know, I have this tendency when I'm prompting to, you know, just say, like, actually, no, do the next thing.
Do the next thing.
And kind of get to a result instead of taking the chance to take a step back and say, well, wait a minute.
Like, consider what you did wrong.
Turn this into a skill or update an existing skill that, like, helps me avoid the whole thing to begin with, right?
And I think I found that balance a really, like, interesting one to strike.
Yeah.
Oh, you see, it even applied to...
I don't know if you can see this, but it applied the shimmer to the uncommon cards.
Wow.
Maybe a bit too much.
Well, we'll tune it down.
Yeah.
Let's see if we can run an example.
Let me just try it again.
So I'm wondering about balancing because, like...
Like, if the bots have priorities and the bots are...
So one thing we did talk about is that once a bot has been...
generated into our game, it's like...
Yeah.
The stats are permanent.
Right.
the stats are permanent.
And so even if somebody else shares that...
uses that...
You get the same bot.
Yeah.
Right.
And I'm just wondering, like, how we balance that.
Because obviously you would always want the strongest bot in your team.
Mm-hmm.
And so you would try to try to...
Like, if the bots have priorities and the bots are...
So one thing we did talk about is that once a bot has been generated into our game, the
stats are permanent.
Right.
And so even if somebody else shares that...
You get the same bot.
Yeah.
Right.
And I'm just wondering, like, how we balance that.
Because obviously you would always want the strongest bot in your team.
Mm-hmm.
And so you would try to, like...
Maybe someone shares it in chat.
Like, here's my legendary bot.
Yeah.
Egg bot.
Right.
And now everybody puts that in their main roster.
That could be not so great, right?
Because, like, everybody would have a legendary bot now.
Yeah.
That's true.
I wonder if we should separate the rarity from the actual bot.
You know?
Like, you still get the same base stats, but then whether or not...
The rarity part of it is just a randomness thing.
So, for example, you could have a Dr. Egg bot.
Then I could have a Dr. Egg bot that I happen to roll legendary on.
And that can be kind of interesting, right?
Because then you have, like, multiple versions of the bot where the core stats...
Well, I guess the core stats would then be different, right?
Because...
Yeah.
Hmm.
I think we'll just, like, a little bit of that for now.
Yeah, maybe.
Yeah, right.
Oh, there might be...
Might create an interesting game meta where people try to find the best bots and then...
Yeah.
You know, like, try and get the legendaries and that could be kind of cool.
Then there's, like, this, like, almost meta game of...
Yeah.
How do you find...
Right.
How do you find the best bots?
Yeah, yeah.
That could be interesting.
I mean, it'd be really cool if people were, like, creating new bot templates.
Right.
And...
Well, that's the hope, right?
Is that people, like, create a bunch of bot templates in the hopes of finding some of the best characters.
Yeah.
Yeah, but we could always tweak that later on, too, right?
I feel like that's something that would work for a v1, no problem.
Yeah.
No problem, so...
Yeah, I guess that's...
Yeah, that's the thing I would imagine.
It's, like, I would always want a legendary bot.
Yeah.
Okay, so here we go.
We have some more visual games.
Oh, that's a real big visual.
Okay.
All right, now we got something.
Look at that full screen so you can see the browser window full screen.
Yeah, good call.
Okay, that looks...
Definitely more interesting than before.
Obviously, this part I don't really like.
I think we need to put that on a separate screen, right?
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
You have your team and then we can get that implemented.
I feel like this is fine for a v1.
Right.
Also, I need to tell it to...
So the shimmers are too severe.
It looks like a rainbow.
And I wonder if that's because...
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, this is, like, way too severe.
I mean, I kind of like wacky, though, you know?
I wonder if it just looks like that because the card is very small, maybe?
And so the gradient is not scaled to the size of the thing.
Yeah, I think that sounds right, yeah.
Like you need to scale up.
Maybe the gradient on the rainbow needs to scale up.
Maybe the gradient needs to scale to the size of the card.
And then, actually, I want to use design mode as well to, like, just tell that what I'm talking about.
And cut and paste right there.
Let's do that.
For those who aren't familiar, Lauren was talking about this a minute ago,
but design mode is a really cool feature in Cursor where you can, as you're seeing on the screen here,
interact with the actual elements on the page.
You don't have to pick a pre-existing div.
You can actually draw a box or draw a circle with the cursor around whatever you'd like like that.
How do I do this?
Yeah, there you go.
And what's really cool about this is you can actually, like--
Oh, I can do this.
Yeah, there you go.
That's what I was trying to do.
Draw an area, a screen area, and actually prompt the agent to do something with that space, which is really cool.
And then I want to say, can we move these lanes into their own?
And so what else do we want to tweak?
I kind of think we only need three-- well, we can do this later, but I feel like we really want to nail the start with your bot
and only get three bots on your team versus having this whole pool.
But that might--
I mean, I think right now this UI is very, like, debug.
Yeah.
Right.
So yeah, for the debug purposes, I think this works.
We just want to make sure that the lanes and the lane result is really good.
Let's actually try to play it now.
Who should go first?
Can you zoom in a bit?
Awesome.
Oh.
Cool.
Well, this is actually really strong because it's got 77 charisma and the skill units charisma.
Yeah.
I look at that stats aren't-- oh, this stats should not add up to 100 because it's legendary.
Oh, you know what?
Now that I'm thinking, it'd be-- I wonder if there's, like, a tweak we could make where--
I don't know if this would extend the game too long.
So right now there's only a max of three rounds.
Mm-hmm.
But maybe the ordering would matter more if your bot had, like, health points or something.
And so it could actually survive a round and go on to the next round.
I think--
Do you think that would be--
I think it could work.
But should we try just doing a one-round battle first and maybe starting with that?
Like, just this is it and you replay this and that's it?
Hmm.
What do you mean?
So when you said three rounds, what were you thinking about there?
Okay, now I put it into the new screen.
Okay, so let's just try this again.
We've got Dr. Eggbot, Common, Nile Engineer Common.
Okay, so we'll just go with the default and hit, right?
Yeah.
And we can see that-- where's the result?
Oh, here we go.
Yeah.
Well, I won.
Mm-hmm.
But--
Yeah, so this is cool.
So the ability bonuses are in, which is causing that 22% bonus.
Yeah.
Dr. Eggbot did not win the first round.
I'm sorry, Lauren.
RIP, Dr. Eggbot.
But yeah, so in my mind, this is actually the MVP and that's the result and you're done.
Were you thinking that we add a few more rounds to it?
Yeah, you know what?
I'm actually-- well, I'm-- so what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to tweet the gameplay, but it's fun.
Yeah.
I think right now, I'm actually not sure why I care about the order.
Mm-hmm.
It just seems random.
Like there's no strategy, really, outside of just the order of the skill, you know what I mean?
And so if you just happen to have a crappy card, a crappy bot, or a bot that's not very-- you know, didn't roll very good stats, then it's like you almost never want to play that bot.
Yeah.
So there's no strategy of thinking about like, oh, maybe that actually this bot could be fodder or something, you know what I mean?
Mm-hmm.
So I wonder if there's something we could develop there.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, the other way to do this, which I think we had also brainstormed a little bit this morning, is like, you know, each of these lineups, we could actually change the conditions that the bots are fighting in, right?
We could have like-- let's say you have what appears to be a really crappy card or a bot, we could actually make that bot like be really good in a certain circumstance.
And you can imagine a circumstance where like the stats are all swapped or something.
We can create all these different like arenas or something like that, where the arenas are then like where like one bot might be really great, another bot might not be as much.
That could be another way we play with this.
Yeah.
This is quite cool, actually, the-- what do you call-- I don't know what you call this, like this rotation.
This rotation effect.
That's kind of nice.
I like that a lot.
It just makes it look cool.
Mm-hmm.
Cool.
Well, I think we've made some really good progress in the last few minutes.
I like-- I think adding some visuals to it really helps the design start to feel more real.
I think we're going to bring on a guest actually to chat a little bit with us.
Nice.
And just kind of spend some time jamming on GrokBot and how they're using GrokBot.
So what we'll probably do is take a quick two to three minute break and kind of go off stream.
And then we'll come back with a guest and keep building in parallel.
Nice.
Yeah.
We'll try to make--
Nice.
Welcome back, everyone. Thanks for having spent the day with us so far. For those who are just
joining, you're joining our 72-hour live stream where we are using GrockBot to build a business
from scratch. We've made some really fun decisions. We've made some pivots. Catch back up on the replay
if you haven't had a chance to see this morning's content. I'm Roshan. I work on product at SpaceXAI.
Lauren and Matt, who are also on the team, are off building, but we really wanted to make sure we
could spend some time with folks who are using GrockBot in really fun and interesting ways. And so
we have with us now Karen Chang. Karen, welcome. Hi. Thanks for having me. Yeah. Thanks so much
for being here. We know you are a cursor and GrockBot power user. I actually have a slide on the
screen here if we can show that with some of the incredibly cool stuff you've built. And so we have
a bunch of folks watching. You are a creative technologist and filmmaker. You have over 3 million
followers. You're creating a bunch of just like really fun use cases with all of these tools. And
yeah, I'm excited to just spend some time digging into all this with you, kind of learning from how
you use all the tools and maybe sharing some tips, hopefully, for some of our viewers. Anything you'd
want to add about kind of what you work on and what you do? Yeah, let's dive in. I can definitely chat
through some of the stuff I've built. I've been using GrockBot since early days and got obsessed
with it pretty early on. And I thought maybe I would test the capabilities GrockBot. Yeah.
GrockBot, can I get a water?
Oh, wow. GrockBot in the real world. It's moved to the physical world. This is like part of your whole
thing though, right? Like this middle custom newspaper, which maybe we'll talk about in a little
bit. But yeah, yeah. Very cool. Very cool. Well, yeah. Thanks so much for being here. Obviously,
thanks so much for using GrockBot. The first thing that I'd like to ask anyone when I kind of,
you know, talk to them about GrockBot is like, what does your team look like? Do you have a chief
of staff bot? Do you have a bunch of bots working on different projects? Tell us a little bit about
how you set up GrockBot for you and how you're using it and maybe any fun bot names you've come up
with? Yeah. I have very uncreative bot names. So I just have a bot for each task. And so I do have
the chief of staff, but I have a package tracker. I have a like show, like a reality TV shows tracker.
Oh, I love that. Okay. I have like 30 morning newspaper bots because I was testing, creating a
template, which we can, we can get into. Yeah. Yeah. Um, and, uh, I was, I use cursor a lot for
projects. And then now I find myself switching over to GrockBot because actually I'm not super
technical and, um, whenever I vibe put it, I would actually oftentimes feel a little dumb because I
see all this code and be like, yeah, do what you do, do what you want to do, but I don't actually
know what's going on. And I love how the GrockBot UI kind of just makes decisions for me and almost
hides what I don't need to see. And so I can just focus on, this is what I want to do. That's awesome.
And so it sounds like you're doing a lot of coding work, but also maybe some operational stuff for,
for your, like your life and maybe your business as well. Is that the right way to break out?
I would say it's stuff I'm doing personally. And then also like weird things I'm inventing
slash making ideas that I've been building. And what I love is that GrockBot connects the cursor
on the backend so it can actually code and make things. That's awesome. And so you're,
you're spinning up cursor agents then within GrockBot and kind of pairing those things together
to build all your stuff. Okay. Well, obviously you've built some incredibly cool things.
I'd love to hear a little bit about some of them. Uh, we'll leave it to you to pick which one
you'd love to like to talk about first, but I knew you've done a really cool project with
best of boards that we showed a second ago. You have to have a really cool custom newspaper.
Right. Um, any one of those that you'd want to kind of share a little bit more about?
I'll start with a newspaper. Um, I just posted about it on, on Twitter last week actually. And so
the idea is, I don't know if you want to pull up the slide.
Yeah. Let's see if we can get the slide back on. So the idea is if you look at that
middle video there, um, it's a newspaper that's personalized to you that prints overnight while
you sleep. Why, why do this is because, um, you can now start your day without touching your phone.
So you can grab this in the morning. It pulls from your calendar and your email,
and then it creates this newspaper meetings, packages arriving, whether to do it,
it turns your subscriptions and sub stacks into a reading section. And then it creates a comic
based on your day and a crossword with hints from your life. I really liked that. And I actually
brought the one that it printed for me this morning. Yeah. So I can, I can, I can show you a camera close
up on this so we can show everyone on the stream. Yeah. So this is actually a bot template that I made
that you can try. Um, if you go to newspaper.karenx.com, uh, I'll say it again, newspaper.karenx.com.
It's a bot that you can just add to your rock bot and then it will say your name. It won't say,
it won't say my name when it prints. What if I want to copy the Karen times?
Well, you can't have one. You can have only your time. Um, but it will basically pull a summary of
your day. It'll draw an image and then, um, summarize your day with your meetings. And also I
have a section for packages arriving, which is, which is pretty useful. Um, and then it has today's
weather. And then, uh, the bot will actually ask you which of your emails. It'll actually go through
your email and look at your email subscriptions and ask you to pick which of your email subscriptions
do you want to include so you can pick your favorites. And then it will actually show your
subscriptions. Wow. And then I did actually a bunch of testing with laying out this newspaper.
So what it does is it, it says like verbatim what your, the person you subscribe to is, and then it
has an editor's summary towards the end. Oh wow. Very cool. Because you, because that way your paper
isn't like 20 pages long. Um, so this is the reading section. And then my favorite part is that it
draws a little comic about you and about your day. And you probably can't see this, but this is actually,
it turned out to be about the event, which I didn't, I didn't plan it. I just saw it this morning.
And so this is me like, um, getting the Uber code to get here, which thanks for the voucher.
And then this is me at the cursor at the growth bot event. And then this is me leaving. And then
it also creates a crossword with hints based on your life. Um, and so I actually, if you go through
and try the newspaper bot, so it's at newspaper.karenx.com or you can find me on socials and the link is
there. Um, it will actually draw an avatar of you. So it will look like you. So it, it has you
like pick your avatar and then you can just type in an ad like, do I want glasses? Do I want to wear
a certain type of outfit? And it'll make it look like you. That's awesome. So the bot prompts you
when you set it up to do all these things, it sounds like it connects to a bunch of services. Is that
right? Yes. So the bot basically, um, uh, it's, it introduces itself. Um, and then I actually
programmed a, so basically the way I set up this template was I wrote like a 30 page long prompt
about how this thing should be set up. And the first is the set of instructions, which is the
questions that it's going to ask you. And then the second part is all of these rules about like how to
design and lay out this paper and the setup flow. It will ask you your name, where you live. And so
that way it'll pull the weather and the like events around you, like things around town to help you get,
get you out of the house, hopefully. Um, and then it pulls me a calendar email to get all this stuff
about your day. And then it asks you to pick an avatar and then it asks you what time you wake up in
the morning. Okay. So that way it starts working on it like, um, a, an hour beforehand.
Sort of like a newspaper alarm clock. Like I sleep next to my printer now and it kind of wakes me up in
the morning. I saw that. I saw that. Yeah. Yeah. Um, uh, so, and then I, uh, I was testing with
friends and, uh, before I released it and my friend was testing it and then he was like, oh my God,
it just started printing. Cause what it will do actually, once you've reached the end, it sets up
your, it makes your newspaper is it will just automatically scan your like network for printers.
Oh wow. Okay. And then it will just print very agentic. Also there's privacy settings in it. So
by default, it will keep financial figures and like doc medical details and stuff off the page.
That's good. But just to warn you, it will find a printer and print it. So if you're at work,
like just be careful, maybe there's like a printer setting. Yeah. But I love how it will just find the
printer and just print it. That is, that is so cool. That's great. Printer setup is like the
most notoriously hard problem. You guys figured it out. That was honestly the part I was most excited
about. Was that just GrokBot figuring it out by itself? You just told GrokBot, hey, find a printer
and print things and it just does it. Yes. Wow. Well, I set up the template. I just said like print,
can you print it? And it didn't ask me like settings. It didn't ask me to connect anything. It didn't ask me
anything. It just in the background saw that there was a printer on my wifi and then it just
started, started going. And I was like, this is, this is the true magic right here. A true agent in
the physical world. Maybe next we could build a water robot that brings you, that brings you water.
Yeah. So we can really tell that story too. Yeah. Wait, so this is incredible. So it sounds like you
also mentioned you prototyped a bunch of different bots as you kind of iterated towards what the final
version of this was. Could you walk through kind of what that prototyping experience was? Did you know,
how did that go? Like, what was great about it? Maybe like what wasn't so great about it?
Yeah. So my, so this newspaper is formatted really to look like a newspaper, but I will say the first
versions of my newspaper formatting was really ugly. I don't have like pictures of it, but just take my
word for it. It did not look good. It looked. And so I would just constantly give GrokBot feedback
and then it figured out that it needed to use some sort of like wheezy print skill and CSS. And then
it also picked out like all these fonts and stuff. It just made all these great design decisions.
Yeah. And then I iterated with it to get the design the way I wanted. And then I had it create like a
template PDF and a template CSS file. And then, um, basically I uploaded everything to Cloudflare. So when
your newspaper bot loads, it pulls all the files, all the fonts, everything from Cloudflare, and then
sets everything up for you. That's really cool. So your bot template, you've kind of iterated on it.
The template now comes with some connectors that it should have that you should set up with it. And
then kind of that, once you install those. Right. But you don't have to worry about any of that.
You just literally click import bot. And then in the background, it pulls all that stuff. You don't
even know that that's happening. Awesome. So you kind of set it up where you're hosting a bunch of that
stuff too. And so it's kind of helped. Yeah. Makes sense. Makes sense. Very cool. Um, I guess I'm
curious, kind of having gone through this process with GrokBot, obviously you've built a lot of other
really cool stuff too. Um, how do you think about what GrokBot does for, you know, creators, inventors
like yourself? And it sounds like a lot of this is just like, it lets you test a bunch of ideas. Maybe
it kind of brings the code a little bit closer to the creative process. And I personally really love
that too. It's like, you can go from idea to execution much faster, but curious, like, are those the
things that you're seeing the most? Like what has done for you? It's speeding up so many ideas and I
have, I'm just able to build things much faster now. And I'm able to build things that I couldn't
before just because it's crazy just how much of a difference, the UI being simple, accelerates my
ideas in just this sort of like subconscious way. And I can, I can share, um, I can share an example of,
uh, let's go back to the slide. And if you look, the first project that I did on the very left side
is a project that I did with cursor. And I did this before GrokBot existed. And so this is basically
what I call the world's dumbest smartphone, but basically you pick up a rotary phone, you ask a
question, you hang up, and then I have it connected to a split flap display that will answer the question.
And again, the idea is that you can spend less time on your phone. As you can see, I really have a
problem with my phone addiction, but what you'll be able to do is, um, you ask any question and it
can look up the weather. It can look up like my exercise classes. It's also pulling from that. And
this took me quite some time to code and cursor to figure out how to connect to the APIs. Um,
and there was just quite a lot of development involved. And I felt like a lot of imposter
syndrome actually, when I was building it, cause I'm not a coder, I'm not a developer and I can use
cursor and I can ask you to do things, but half the time it's asking me to commit to GitHub and repose.
And I'm like, I don't know, can you help me? And it will help me. It will do it. But I am in there
and I feel like an imposter. Um, I actually recently tried doing something, some like re reproducing
that thing on the left side, that video on the left side inside GrokBot. And I was like, Hey,
can you just, um, I set up a package alerts tracker. Yeah. So inside GrokBot, I recommend you do this
because I don't, I'm not always good at like knowing what packages are arriving. Cause I have
my packages separate on a, like a separate email account. So I don't know like what's arriving
and then I maybe miss it. And then I'm home, but the, but the UPS driver doesn't ring the doorbell
and then it's on my doorstep and it gets stolen. Yeah. Yeah. So, uh, so I wanted a package tracker
that tells me like, this is what's arriving today. This is what's arriving this week. And so it will
check my email, uh, like twice a day and for like what's out for delivery. And then it will scan.
And then if it's out for delivery, it starts checking more often. Oh, cool. Yeah. And then
it even logs into my Amazon account. Nice. And, um, once it's out for delivery, it will send me a
screenshot of the number of stops away my Amazon driver is. So you're truly getting like down to
the minute notifications. Yeah. Cause I want it flipping. And then I also, it checks like
for DoorDash. It'll tell me like when my DoorDash is on the way. So I've, I've made this package
tracker and I've had it connected to like all these different packages. Sounds like all kinds of
like food packages and also like mail packages and everything in between. Yeah. Yeah. And then
I connected it to my split flap display, which is the best floor, which is the thing that flips
and it's in my room. And so whenever a package comes, it's like, your package is here. Like,
I can't, I can't miss it. So you never have to look at your phone. Like everything just gets
notified to you on for packages. But, um, for, but that was so easy to set up because, uh, for
in, in cursor, I had to build a whole like, like web interface, connect to APIs, like, uh, upload,
upload, like create a web. It was just many steps and a lot of troubleshooting. And then inside
Grapha, I was just like, wait, can you just connect to my Vesta board? I was like, sure. Here you go.
Give the API key. And I'm like, okay. So I pull up the app, which comes with the split flap display,
grab the API key, paste it in. And then, uh, like two minutes later, my, my display starts flapping.
And I was like, and it didn't ask me to build anything, commit anything, upload anything. And so
just the, the frictionless nature, I'm coming up with so many more ideas now because of that,
because it's just so easy to build things. And I feel like I don't have to code anymore. Like
the coding is invisible. Like it's no longer vibe coding. It's just vibing. It's, it's vibe
creating, maybe. Yeah. I'm not good at coining that. Please don't like, yeah, please don't feature
me. Um, you know, one of the things that I I'm finding that is really resonant about the work
that you've done is that it has really shortened the creative process. Um, but it feels like you also
like have dug pretty deep, like in your phone project, you're kind of like working with
microcontrollers and like doing a lot of work with hardware. And so I'm kind of curious,
like, you know, have you used GrokBot to help with sort of learning how to do those things?
Are you kind of like using GrokBot as an educational tool? And then also just like,
where do you get some of that inspiration from? Because there's a lot of people out there who
are like, I don't know where to get started or I don't know what to work on. I'm just curious
kind of how you, how you like think of those ideas. Right. Yeah. I'm starting to use GrokBot to
connect, especially with tools that have API. Yeah. Um, it's been really helpful. Actually,
the next step of my newspaper bot, uh, is I'm going to actually take this, this, this a step further.
And I actually got a robot pen that like actually plots and draws it so it can draw like a full
size newspaper and that can connect with an API. So I'm working on connecting GrokBot to like this
robot pen. And so that'll be my next video. Okay. I'm still figuring that one out. So, um, so, uh,
so that's been really fun. And, um, yeah, I just feel like it has just been able to,
I've been honestly been really manic the last week. Like I haven't been sleeping as well because I've
just been, I have had all these ideas, but in terms of where I get the ideas, actually this,
this came from solving problems that I had. So last year, um, I had a challenge for myself where I would
not look at screens on Saturdays. Yeah. I didn't do it every Saturday, but I would do it at least
like once or twice a month. It was very hard. Um, but basically the idea is from like from Friday
night until Sunday morning, no phones, no laptops. Like I would, I would watch a little bit TV,
but, but no, like no, no tiny devices, no devices that are connected to the internet that could send
me notifications. And I did it because I was so burnt out, um, on like my phone and phone addiction.
And I was feeling just really not good, like physically, not good, mentally, not good. I felt
like my brain was a sponge that held the maximum amount of water that it could possibly hold. And
there was just no room in my brain for anything else. So I did this thing where I would not look at
my phone for like, um, a day a month or two days a month. It was shockingly hard. Um, because
there's so much on your phone now, like everything that you need is now on your phone. So it's,
it's much harder now to not to forgo your phone. Right. It feels like you're like giving up an
appendage or like, you're just losing context in the world or something like that. I can't like order
food. Right. I can walk to a grocery store and cook, which is, you know, that's, that was a good
thing for me to do. Maybe that's also a good outcome. Yeah. Yeah. Um, and so, and then I also
can't just look up something. Like sometimes I'm just curious. I want to know like, well, what time
does the hardware store close? I can't look that up. You know, what extra, what time is the exercise
class today? I, I gave up so much in not using my phone. So I had all these like problems. And so I
think you identify a problem or a pain point that you have in your life and then just solve it. And
so I came up with these kinds of ridiculous solutions, which was creating, you know, this phone
that would answer questions for me on a giant split flat display and the thing that would print a
print my newspaper. But the problem with this solved actually was I know I'm not supposed to look at my
phone first thing in the morning. I know that that I noticed when I look at my phone on first thing
in the morning, I'm scrolling with like one eye open. Yeah. I like my, both of my eyes haven't even
opened yet. Yeah. And I'm like scrolling Instagram. I know this is not good for me. I'm scrolling TikTok.
This is not good for me. And then I wake up and I start my day and it kind of mess. It throws my
whole day. Yeah. And then I would have days where I was like, okay, I'm not gonna look at my phone.
I'm going to go out in the park first thing. And those days will always be much better, but that would
take so much discipline because in the morning I'm like, well, what's new? Who needs me? Was there
an urgent email overnight? Was there a calendar event that was moved? Was there something I need
to know? And so I would just could not resist checking my phone in order to get that information.
And then, but then I would see all my social media apps and I would see all the other stuff I don't
need. So I was like, okay, what if it could just print just the information I needed, which was how
this idea for this morning. This is amazing.
Well, I'm sort of taking away from this. And for those of you who are watching and maybe want some
ideas of what to do with GrokBot, I think so much of what you can do is like, you know, install
GrokBot, give it a problem that you are facing, whether it's wanting to curb your phone addiction or
maybe getting outside more often or, you know, anything like that, right? Like helping manage a
crazy schedule, helping track your packages. I think there's so many of these sort of like daily
problems that people face and, you know, daily things that, you know, if you haven't used an AI
agent tool in a little while, you don't, you don't even know it's possible that you could like ask an
agent to help with some of that work. And it sounds like you've really sort of like, you know,
productized that in some ways by saying like, Hey, I'm going to like go and figure out all these
little things where I can go and get GrokBot to help me out. I think that's just super awesome.
I can share a few other, I don't know how we are on time.
Yeah, I think we're going to be more minutes. Yeah. Why don't you give us a rapid fire?
I can share a few of my bots that have been really helpful. So one is like when my favorite
t-shirt, there was a shirt that I wanted that was out of stock in the color
that I wanted. And I just have like a back in stock tracker for items that are out of stock.
And so once a day, it'll go to the website and it'll check for like the size and the color that
I want and see if it's in stock. And then sure enough, like one day it had the alert and it was
like, it's in stock. There's only one. I think probably because someone returned it. And I went
and got it immediately. You could also set it up to buy it automatically. I was going on vacation.
So I was like, don't buy it automatically. I will do it.
Your package tracker. You need to track the package.
Yeah. And then my package arrives. Yeah. I have a shows tracker. So I just put in like, I just tell it
like, here are my favorite shows. And it'll tell me when something is renewed for season two, when
like it's going to come out that day. Because I'm sitting down at night and I'm like, what am I going
to watch? And then this thing will tell me like, hey, your favorite show premieres tonight or it just
got renewed. And that's, you know, that's something that I look forward to.
So you've also done a lot of proactivity, right? So like things that you'd otherwise have to go
seek out information for, you kind of now have GrokBot pushing that to you. So you kind of just have
one place where like, it's kind of like a feed, right? Of all the stuff you care about, all these
like things that are arriving on your doorstep, maybe some like notifications that would be over
there that you can centralize. So I really love that idea of kind of like putting everything in one place.
And then the thing that I really like viewing is I like, GrokBot can control your iMessage.
I don't know if you, okay, so this takes, I think a little bit of settings to set up. You have to
like change the settings in order for this to happen. But GrokBot controls your iMessage.
So then to be able to put if then logic on your iMessage has been so cool. So for example,
I was ordering an item to a friend's house that they needed. And so I Instacarted it to their house.
And so I needed to tell them like, this is when your items arriving. But I didn't want to,
I wanted to go take a shower. Like I didn't want to go sit and update this, my friend. So I was like,
okay, GrokBot, I want you to check where my Instacart driver is. And then once it gets close,
like within 10 minutes, I want you to take a screenshot and then send that screenshot via iMessage
to my friend every like two minutes. And then my friend actually could know where the driver was.
And then get it because Instacart doesn't have actually the ability to share where the driver
is to someone else. But with GrokBot, you can make it multiplayer, it sounds like. Yeah,
right. Yeah. Yeah. Very cool. Very cool. Yeah. So these are all really amazing. I know we're coming
a little bit up on time. One thing kind of just working on the GrokBot team that's really helpful
for us to hear and like kind of putting my product hat on is what feature requests do you have? Like,
what would you love to see in GrokBot next? Maybe where are some areas where you might want,
you know, things to be a bit better or some areas where, you know, we could add new stuff?
I would love for it to be able to, I would love for it to be able to manage logins better. So the login
stuff is super useful. I use it, for example, to check, I have a subscriptions canceler. And so it
checks how much money I'm spending on my various subscriptions. But the problem is things are always
getting logged out on the virtual machine. But sometimes I'm logged in on my local computer.
Just managing that whole life cycle better. Yeah. That would probably be one pain point that I would
love. And it sounds like you're logging into a bunch of services. So you're probably hitting
that pretty frequently. Yeah. Awesome. Well, thank you. It's like really helpful for us to hear,
especially from a power user such as yourself. And so maybe just to wrap this up, first of all,
thank you so much for being here. This is incredible. I just find it is incredible to see the
creativity of what you've built with GrokBot. You know, I'm excited to see all the future
projects you build. I'm not going to ask for too many spoilers, but the plotter sounds amazing.
I might need to buy a plotter and go make myself a full page newspaper. So like, you know, we'll chat.
We'll chat afterwards. Just to wrap things up, where can people find you? Where can people find your
bots and any parting thoughts you'd leave for the folks watching? Okay. You can find me on social media.
It's Karen X Cheng, C-H-E-N-G. And then if you want the newspaper bot, it's newspaper.karenx.com.
Wonderful. Or you can just search in Google like morning bot,
morning newspaper bot. Yeah. And we should get that in the marketplace too.
It is in the marketplace. You can go to the marketplace and in the personal category.
X.ai/bot/marketplace. And there we go. All right.
All right. Well, thank you so much for being here. We're going to cut to a short break,
and then we will come back to building our three-day business and keep the process going.
Thank you all for being here. Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
We're back on.
And so that was a conversation with Karen and Charen and Roshan.
Yes.
And honestly, one of my favorite demos for Rockbot is Karen's internet-connected printer.
So if you haven't seen that one on X yet, highly recommend.
I really want to build something that I want to build something to do, I want to do this, I want to build something similar to the game.
And so in the meantime, during our break, I was chatting with Lauren.
I did a bunch of whiteboarding, started to think through some ideas and directions for the game.
Yeah.
So we take a look at my screen real quick. So I have tldraw open and I was basically, this is more for me. You know, I could have prompted a bot to come up with this, but I just wanted to like visualize it in my head how it would work. But this is kind of a rough, like I guess a rough set of moths where you have like the game screen.
The name of the game is obviously a working title. And then you get like a new match screen. And then you have a captain.
Yeah, so I was thinking like so you would pick a bot as your captain and maybe that has some implication later.
Yeah, right. For now, I don't know if there's any implication. But you choose your captain and so that's the bot that you get to pick.
Right. And then random one and then a few other ones that are asking two. To assemble your team and kind of put the team together.
Yeah. Yeah. That makes a lot of sense. And then…
You can see the stats maybe. Yeah, so once you click on choose captain, then you get like…
So this is like your list of bots that you've already hired. And then you can pick which one.
And then I guess there could be like another… like an input here that says…
Create a new one.
Yeah, you can do it here. But then you can also go into this team page and then you can manage the bots you have.
And maybe for now we'll just… it's just a very simple list of bots you've imported before.
Yeah, I like that.
And they're kind of associated with your account, right? So when you've logged in, you kind of have a team that's…
It could be interesting to track like who minted the bot.
The original creator.
I don't know what that means.
Yeah.
It's just because it's just the person who uploaded it.
That could be a fun like Easter egg to add maybe as a bonus feature.
Do you like the whiteboard in the browser inside cursor? Like… and what does that unlock for you?
Like can you do anything special with those…
Yeah, so the really nice thing about drawing… so yeah, I have tldraw open in cursor's browser and my agent can just see it.
So you can see like I just told the agent like, "Hey, can you look at my browser? I drew some mocks."
And it took a screenshot and it now has context, very useful context, to actually go off and build it.
So I have it actually… because our original version of our prototype is kind of…
I still love this by the way. Like I think this looks pretty great.
I mean it doesn't look like a game. It looks like some kind of weird UI.
Trading cards. Maybe they look like trading cards, yeah.
But yes, I wanted to make it look more game-like.
So that was the inspiration for, "Okay, how do I actually want this to look?"
Because this is not very… this is not a game I want to play, personally.
So, you know, like very big and minimalist and fun.
Yeah, I like the big sort of like take over the screen, really focus on the bots.
We can maybe bring some of the card CSS that you were calling out to bear here and have this really be simple, right?
So you see your team and then… did you have a chance to prototype out how you'd actually go and then…
Yeah, so once you pick your captain, then like let's say I picked Dr. Eggbot as my captain.
Mm-hmm.
Then you get to decide the order of the… and you just drag and drop.
Cool, yeah.
Then you confirm and then you put… you get matched… you get a finding match screen.
Right.
It'd be ideal if the matchmaking was so fast that you'd never saw the screen, but maybe if it takes more than like a few seconds to show you the screen.
Yeah.
Cool loading animation maybe for you too.
And then, okay, so let's say I got matched with Maddie P.
Yep.
Who has Matbot and round one.
So unlike the prototype we saw before, which is very text-wordy, you just see like, you know, one bot at a time and it's like round one.
And I'm still kind of thinking about how this would look, but maybe I'll get the bot to kind of… now that I have some basic mocks…
Yeah.
…just get the agent to actually riff on these.
And so I was just thinking like, okay, random tool used Riz and Matbot used Implode.
And I was toying with this idea of like not making it too stat-focused, if that makes sense, because it's like… it's not very fun to me.
Yeah.
Like random tool used Riz and that was 37 cards, like who cares.
So I was thinking like maybe there's like a way to visually show like, well, this has two arrows of power, you know?
Yeah.
And so you can… it's more like conceptual.
And Implode only has like… maybe this is just based on the stats.
Yeah.
I think that could actually be fun.
It's like we just… maybe we chunk the stats into four categories, like 0 to 20, 20 to 40, 40.
Yeah, it could be like a week strong.
And the numbers are like behind the scenes.
The numbers are behind the scenes.
Yeah.
So for people who really want to dig into the numbers and like, you know, get into it, they
can.
But if you're…
I mean, I don't know.
I feel like the numbers…
Or maybe the numbers aren't visible.
I feel like the numbers could be hidden from readers.
Yeah.
And maybe we'll see how that feels.
That's a good point.
We can always add that later.
And maybe…
Yeah.
Because like…
I feel like the numbers are only interesting if you can somehow have an impact on the number.
Yeah.
So I think like maybe just show the relative strength for now.
Yeah, I like that.
We should just take…
Because I think we go up to what?
150 max?
150 total stats today?
Yeah.
So it's probably a way for us.
Like 4…
Yeah, you go 4…
It'd be like a cool animation.
Yeah, yeah.
And maybe you don't even know that your opponent bot is like legendary.
And it gets revealed that it was.
It just gets shown when they use a skill and like extremely powerful.
I really like that too because it sort of amps up the drama.
And I feel like that's something that keeps you really…
You know, would keep people engaged.
I would love that.
I'm like waiting with anticipation to see what happened in each one of these turns.
So…
This part definitely needs some design help, I think.
Like I'm not that good at coming up with designs here.
Just thinking through like how…
Like how do we do these?
Like how do we make the animation so good?
You know, how do we make the…
How do we just make it not like a tech suit game?
Where it's just a tech floating around everywhere?
So some like cool animation.
Okay.
Like a win and lose animation.
Interesting.
But yeah, that's what I just sketched out really quickly.
I love that.
Yeah.
And we have our…
Oh, there you go.
We have some mocks, I guess.
Nice.
I didn't ask it for mocks, but…
Oh, maybe I just need to refresh.
Oh, there you go.
Cool.
Okay, let's try.
Let's walk through our prototype.
Wait, wait, hold on.
Is this a real login?
Okay, no, it's just Facebook.
Thank goodness.
Okay.
New map.
That's a fun logo.
Okay, so I'm diamond.
Cool.
Yeah.
What is diamond?
Oh, so I had this idea.
Since we have ELO ranking…
Yeah.
I thought it'd be cool to show…
Oh, cool.
Instead of showing numbers, it's far more, I think, engaging and interesting when the player
doesn't see the actual…
I don't know.
You don't have to see the guts of how the game works.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You kind of…
It's more…
You know, instead of saying like, oh, my ELO is 1, 3, 7, 2…
Yeah.
I can say I'm diamond.
And that's like way cooler.
Yeah, like I'm in this cool category.
I'm diamond and you're like bronze.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm totally better than you.
Yeah, right.
At this game.
So…
I like that.
Okay, this one doesn't really look like my mock.
Is it still working?
I like the big loss.
Oh, that's kind of…
I like the summary screen here too that it came up with, where we'd show all the boss
on the summary screen if you scroll down.
Oh, interesting.
I can show you the summary.
I guess maybe that's interesting because then you can like tweak your strategy.
Yeah.
One benefit of actually showing the stats is that you could kind of then show why you
lost.
So like in the actual battle, maybe you don't know the stats, but afterwards you kind of
get the game summary.
And that would actually be really cool to share on social for people too, I think.
Yeah.
So I want to actually tell… give it some feedback here.
Like…
Can I draw?
Maybe I'll just do the shift click.
Oh.
That's not what I wanted.
So what you're doing now is using design mode and cursor, right, to kind of give direct
feedback on the actual…
Oh, there you go.
Prototype.
There you go.
Yeah.
Shift click here to select the whole screen.
I'll just say this doesn't match my box.
Just giving the agent some feedback on what to adjust.
Three big cards where the first card is the captain selector, I guess.
And the other two cards are…
Okay.
And then let's actually…
Okay, let's just… for the sake of seeing the fill… okay, I'm just going to go with
LingShades bot.
And okay, so now we can sort the order.
Help me out.
What do you… what do you guys think… who should go first?
So for this one, I think… let's do our… well, I can't see what Keto gets… Charisma.
I think we should put our, like, Krita Keto first.
That feels like it's a guaranteed win, right?
40A Charisma goes to Charisma.
Yeah, I think we didn't actually implement the drag.
Oh, okay.
So I think… what did we do?
Oh, that was not… this thing is blocking my screen.
I can't see.
Oh, I guess…
I think you might have lost… did we lose your screen?
Oh, yeah.
And we're back.
There you go.
I think… I'm going to give feedback again and say, like…
Keep pressing… make this draggable.
Make this draggable.
Yep.
Through the order.
And you can remove the reorder button at the bottom of the screen.
One thing that might be cool, too, is if we want to push some of this up to our repo.
I did push… I did push it up so you can start playing with it, too.
You can start playing with it, too.
Awesome.
Yeah.
I was working on some, like, landing page stuff based off the design Lauren has, so…
I'm going to zoom out a little bit so I can actually click the stuff.
Just kicked it off.
Okay.
Then I'm going to confirm.
Finding match.
Check it out.
Looking for another name player.
Okay.
So this is just, like, a demo.
I'm going to skip the leap.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, this is kind of cool.
Okay.
Yeah, but it happened too fast.
Like, I think…
We need to add the animations.
Yeah.
But you know what?
Maybe this is fine.
We'll ship it.
Yeah.
And then we can iterate.
Iterate.
Exactly.
So…
I don't want to show the details here, so I think we'll give it some feedback as well.
We'll say, "Don't show this card here.
Just the bot avatar."
And then…
Let's remove the…
Let's just say, let's remove the… what do you call this?
The stats.
The stats, maybe?
The stat line.
Mention.
Yeah.
That line.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
And then let's go next round.
So we're definitely going to need some animation, so this looks more interesting.
Yep.
I can take a pass of that once we have…
Yeah.
Once we have this pushed up.
And then…
Actually, do we even need to see the result at this point?
I think it would be…
Well, what are you thinking?
What…
And I just think…
I'm wondering, is this kind of a useless button?
Why not just…
After this round, we can just show…
Automatically.
After a few seconds, just show…
So we go like, round one, round two, round three, and then done.
Yeah.
And lost.
And then it'd be nice as well if like…
I wanted to do this where we should automatically find a new match.
In the background?
After…
Five seconds if the user doesn't click.
It'd also be kind of cool to see…
Do we want to show you like, any tier changes in this?
Like, you could show diamond, plus five.
Like, diamond, minus ten.
Yeah.
Maybe this could…
For each player, you might want to see like, how they…
How they're ranking changed.
Subtitle or captions that shows the change to your ELO.
Yeah, change to your ELO.
But we don't want to actually show the number.
We just want to show your tier…
Oh, no.
Right, we don't…
So we could show like, potato, minus five.
We could even do it where it's next to your handle.
And then like, if we just say like, diamond, minus five, like, what is that?
It's kind of hard to…
Yeah.
To understand.
Or we could come up with an icon for it.
Like, arrow down and like, have some more severe arrows for like, you're dropping a lot.
Okay, now that I'm thinking…
I guess, I mean, some of these competitive things do show the number.
Yeah.
But then it's like…
So you do know like, oh, okay, like…
I don't know, like, bronze is from 800 to 1000.
Yeah.
But you just talk about your score as…
Your tier is bronze.
Well, maybe one way we could do this is we could implement the tiers as a bit of a medal.
So you have like, bronze, silver, platinum, the medals that are next to your name.
But then we still show you the number.
It's like a tooltip on hover, basically.
Oh, I like that.
Yeah.
You hover over the diamond and you get the actual number.
So yeah, my bot's kind of like working through all these feedback.
All the feedback.
Cool.
And let's see…
Is it working?
Okay, I think I'll just refresh.
Let's see if I can get the latest version of this running on my own too.
I guess I haven't implemented it yet.
Are you just pushing to main?
Yeah.
Awesome.
Nice.
No time for full requests.
No time for PRs.
Cool, cool, cool.
Okay, I'll just say like when you're done, push commit and push to main.
Let's do it.
And I'll kick off an agent to like prototype maybe some of those animation frameworks.
Cool.
nice no time for full requests no time for prs uh cool cool cool
okay i'll just say like uh when you're done push commit and push to name let's do it
and i'll kick off an agent to like prototype maybe some of those animation
frameworks cool what are you what are you prompting um help me do some research on game
animation framework so i'd be like more curious if there's like a library and open source solution
where um like these things exist and then we can like build them somehow maybe even using sliders
it's like rather rather than like constructing them ourselves i'm wondering maybe you think
we could take a different approach to that though um so for like graphbot animations we actually use
like code to drive okay so we could just i wonder if we could actually uh i mean i don't think i don't
know if we should reuse it but maybe we can have code drive the animations as well if it's like
programmatic that's kind of what i was thinking like i was just wondering if there's like i don't
know if there's a framework that's what i'm saying if there's like a dev like a game dev way so i feel
like the agent or bot could just figure all right we can just also have the bot like write it just be
like yeah right it's uh it might be hard though it feels like we need a design child i'll just like
chat i'll chat with the agent for a little bit before i have it like build something well how do you do
like what is your recommendation for that with potato mode like do you use potato mode and then
chat with an agent before you like or i think this is like i think this yeah in this case if i'm not
sure of the approach i would kind of like keep doing prototypes okay to build some prototypes tell
it to do some research as well like look up how to do programmatic animations uh with you know javascript
and for the type of few examples small examples um it's kind of hard because i think for the grafod
avatar you actually spend a lot of time thinking about the uh like so even though they're like 2d yeah
but they're actually like like they're 3d in a 2d space in that sense because you can actually see
like when they do like a rotation right or like a cool flip or something like you actually see them
rotating and the eyes obviously moving around yeah yeah so i think i feel like you need to prompt that
somehow okay right or or show your agent well do we want to keep them two-dimensional or make them
three-dimensional i don't know maybe we start with 2d yeah i think two dimensions i feel like evolve this
and stretch it yeah because it maybe starts simple and then we'll try and try and expand there yeah i
feel like 2d would get us to something faster yeah and then we can revamp the graphics later because
the graphics are just a layer on top of the logic right exactly you can kind of i think we should ship
something yeah yeah that'll be an interesting moment as well like when we go from 2d to 3d yeah at that
point i connect the next milestone yeah right like having but i think yeah my hope is that we can get this
prototype launched uh as soon as possible yep and get our audience to actually play yeah chat with uh to play
and oh actually you know what i forgot we need a leaderboard uh that reminds me um but the idea is
that yeah the leaderboard will be like bragging rights like you know like who's the best uh cupcake
battler um and uh you can replay the game oh yeah like see the replays and see what happened in
that game yeah are you thinking for the leaderboard we just rank everyone by elo and that's the that's
the v1 uh yeah i think b1 would just be like who has the highest level yep yep yeah i like that and
we'll just keep it really stupid and simple sounds good yeah and then we can go back and and put it to
tiers and do medals and stuff later on so yeah okay just get it working first cool has your agent pushed
up the latest changes uh let me see no it still work it's still doing some changes but um
i'll probably start switching to pr since the three of us are yeah let's do it i'm excited to
start but i think for now i think you can keep working and then we'll just have your bots resolve
all the changes it should be fine okay uh but let's see i need to i need to know let me just wait for it
to to yeah i really want to get the base the base in there so i can build on top of some of these design
uh let's see it's taking screenshots oh yeah okay so it is working but i guess it hasn't let me see
oh there you go okay okay so now uh okay i can see my evo score now so diamond tilt
12 4d i can choose my captain and oh there you go i have uh who am i gonna pick i'm gonna pick
dr eggbot hell yeah uh and then let's let's actually go tinkerbot first okay it's like tinkerbox
has really good decks in fact maybe dr eggbot stats are pretty bad i'm sorry so we might need to change
out of the back end um actually why not i have a handy dandy b bug here let's make dr eggbot oh i can't
change the rarity unfortunately but um can i actually oh uh well since my ability oh you know what let me
just make my ability charisma there you go so now dr eggbot has 43 nice cheating what a stat we got we
got to cheat you know should we add cheats should we add like you could we'll say that we'll have to
hide the debug yeah yeah when we actually deploy make an admin interface um one thing that could be fun for
the two of you to help me with yes the uh right now the i feel like the the bots are kind of boring looking
um it'd be nice to have like i guess you're working on the animations yeah like a better a nicer design for
them and then for the skill the abilities i feel like it'd be really interesting if we used grok imagine yeah
grok imagine yeah come up with like a cool icon for it yeah um just to make it a little bit more
visual and more fun yeah and um instead of just text because i think i can start working on that yeah
i feel like the enemy of the game design here is is too much text and numbers yeah for sure i want to
make it a little bit more visual more fun cool so i actually have a bot that i might be able to use for
this actually uh we cut over to my screen i'll show you what i've been what i use okay we could reuse
this this is before the pivot and this is a pattern that i like to use for um imagine uh so what i'll do
is i'll chain together a couple different services and so here i use um uh imagine with foul and so there's
a really good foul model by refnet v2 which is for background removal and so then once i get a good
style so you can see i was kind of prompting and then like an airbnb like
uh little house kind of cute style for like some of our designs on the storefront and i can combine
imagine to get the design and then a background removal model to remove the background and so you
get really good transparent backgrounds um and this is something i've been using uh both for like icon
design and every project that i have so what we could do is like maybe we could get some of the bots um
in in like a png format here i guess i'm a little like torn because like how are we going to animate
the bots with a javascript-based animation framework if they're uh if they're pngs right so like uh i
i almost feel like yeah you want them to be expressed as code yeah so we should start your code
maybe there's something about like you know we get we get it to build can they build 3d models
and then we somehow render that as qd is that too complicated i don't think it's too complicated but
then we're not really using imagine right like imagine could be just like hero assets maybe um
or like stuff could imagine actually make like different states of these i guess like a series of
states yeah so like you know like i kind of like a like a sprite sheet almost yeah we could probably make
a sprite sheet that could be that would be a simple way to do like 2d animation so do like sprite sheet
and then use that to like move over to svgs or something like i'm because i think like the animation
could just be like swapping swapping the swapping between the states yeah yeah like a angry state
uh battle state yeah i don't feel happy you know yeah i guess like my inclination is that the more we
can keep it in code like the more flexibility we have with the states so i don't know i'm down i'm down to try
whatever um i think yeah my sense is like let's keep the bots as uh code for sure and then only use
grok imagine for the skills okay the ability icons okay so you could have like really cool icons for like
you know a riz skill ability or like that could be like a i don't know whatever the grok imagine comes
up with um and i think that could be pretty interesting okay so what i'll do is i'll have like my chief of
staff bot and i'll say like have uh cupcake eng talking and uh to the image gen bot and uh explain
the repo we're working in or like our um explain the game
mechanics and
then build some cool like i don't know skills uh skill icons using imagine and uh remove the background
these need to be on brand so use the existing design language
cool all right we'll see i'll see what imagine comes up with for that
uh by the way so you created cupcake eng with dr egg bot yeah uh i'm curious what what the how did
dr egg bot make your cupcake i think if you click on cupcake eng and the yeah and then click on the
the icon at the top yeah and you can actually see the description okay so the descriptions are actually
pretty interesting uh because uh i don't know if this is common knowledge but essentially the description's
almost like the well some people call it like a soul or like a system prompt i had no idea but yeah it
actually affects how the bot works um so um a lot of times when you're this is how dr egg bot designs
good bots it's like it equips the bot with really good description uh you know like how what what voice to
use when you're talking to user um it looks like it added a ton of content uh in here um and uh i think
it also has like oh yeah dr egg bot also specifies like one job so you know you don't have a bot that
tries to do everything it's a specialist um so that's pretty pretty cool how it it set that up i think
i feel like this one is too specific and this is almost like a meta point here where i sometimes notice
this happen with agents in general like when you create a skill or a rule or anything really whenever
that rule or skill change comes from a like a problem or like something that happened in that chat session
i find that agents tend to like to put all the details in that thing in that rule or skill and then
it makes the skill less feasible because like it's overfitted to that one scenario and does that kind
of make sense it was like a lot it's a lot of inspiration for peace back i see it came from that
like you know the principal skills yeah came about that where i saw the agent making a change and i was
like why why are you saying like this thing just was only for this pr yeah it's not a thing that's
going to be it's like locked into this like scale context yeah every time if you don't fix that then
you just get this your skill just becomes like the soup of examples that are no longer relevant yeah
distracting okay so a lot of how i like to think about these changes are like how do we keep it
durable okay high level yeah and how do you do that like when you're building these agents um just a lot
prompting okay yeah prompting and observing okay you like you have to like click into things and read
them um that's the hard part i guess yeah because ai produces so much text it's hard to read i mean
but this is helpful right because now i know where to look like where some of these these details are
coming from yeah one question i would even say like you could tell doctor but hey the description you
came up with for cupcake eng is way too specific can you read potato mode again and come up with like
principles that cupcake eng should follow instead of these overly specific issues
uh and actually while you do that let me get a qr code for people
to download dr egg bot if you don't have it already
cool dr egg bot is on it nice what is the uh does the lab how does the label affect
our bots i've always wondered this uh actually i believe it doesn't right now it's genetic
uh but uh someone else can correct me on that because yeah it's it's been changed a little bit
but i think we made it more cosmetic because the point of the label is like when you have a lot of
bots that are you know well some not everybody has like descriptive names like you do like for
example my bots are just all like food names tater mash and hash brown and if you forget like it's
helpful to have yeah a label just remember like oh right tater is the engineer um and steve is the
chief of staff okay yeah i was i was always wondering that so it's good to know dr eggbot is rewriting
writing that the cupcake and there you go potato principles love that cool
cool i have a prototype running which is great uh yes chat it's live
um so what's your bottom my bot or your agent my agent so these were like the lander design
prototypes um looks like we're having some issues these are running the cloud with the remote server
there so i might have to pull them down locally um and then i was doing some research on the uh
animation frameworks so it looks like um computer use is actually running the game so we can kind of see
cursor running the game and testing out it built a motion is that the older version it might be you
might yeah you might want to like hey rebate rebase on trump right rebase on main get the fresh changes
all right so we're gonna ask you to rebase on main uh good good deal yeah
comment sicko i love that one so uh for those of you curious what what the hell is this comment sicko
comment sicko is a agent in pstack whose job is to uh kill comments there's actually a story there's
actually a story behind this so like it's called the comment sicko because it's like inspired by sicko mode
yeah or sicko you know you know the the meme of the person like peering through the mirror like sickos
i see so my idea was like inspired by you know a fellow colleague paul who had created a sicko mode
skill i made a comment sicko who gets really excited about deleting comments and you might be running
like who cares about comments and i've actually noticed that bots will often or agents in general
will often use comments as like a crutch for explaining some kind of workaround um yeah instead
of actually fixing the root cause and i've noticed this on like our database where over time you just
get like a ton of comments and like a ton of workarounds and you know your app just becomes very
unmaintainable so uh that's the inspiration for the comment sicko i always love uh when i when when it gets
spawn because if you if you ever click on it you'll see it laugh like yes hahaha yes going to delete
comments nice okay so cupcake eng is now just this already looks a lot cleaner um number one right so
high level context on uh our game studio one job owned engineering outcomes by orchestrating work
through p-stack potato mode and cloud agents then supervising and verifying um this is a little
bit of ai slop so we could probably clean clean some of these up uh match your playbook and follow it
this looks more aligned with some of the cupcake stuff maybe a little bit more high level um what
do you think lauren uh i think it looks good i mean it's kind of receding a bit of the potato mode stuff
yeah so we could probably trim it it's it's fine i mean this is i mean this is better than what it was
before so we can we can iterate cool you got the lander running locally i do and i'm actually doing a
quick a few quick like layout tweaks here uh maybe we cut the the russian screen yeah let's see russian
uh what what are you thinking as you make the changes yeah so um basically what i was doing is i'm
trying to go through the prototype end-to-end here and get it sort of feeling really like we could take this
and like with a few clicks or a few config changes uh ship it and so um a couple of things that are
going through my head so i'm starting off with um just kind of like running the app locally kind of
using design mode as well by the way team can we get russian screen oh yeah we could get my screen
on that there we go that would be great um yeah we see it cool i might want to zoom in though yeah
like so tiny there we go um so yeah we have we have this working kind of like what you're seeing
on lauren's screen earlier a few things i'm noticing is you know kind of going through my like
how do we start to make this a little more polished right so i started out um i can just refresh this
here um so here we have like this sort of header looks like it should be actually pinned to the top of
the um of the menu so i have that getting pinned to the top uh with an agent working on it this debug
menu is obviously just for us right now but we'll probably put it behind a feature flag at some point
or something and so yeah i feel like we need to delete it yeah so i have it as a floating bill for
now so if it's a feature flag then it's like a it's like a runtime check which means the code has to
live in the the code still will get shipped even if it and so like a hacker in the console could be like
i'm gonna tweak the the the values that's fair and actually that's a good point as well for a competitive
game we actually want to make sure some a lot of the game matchmaking logic and the battling i guess are it's
maybe server-driven yeah we don't have to do that now but it's something to think about for competitive
games so that you know you don't have people just in the console let me make my stat 1 million right
yeah and and defeat your your character yeah i think that's a really good point i'm also adding a
feature here um where i want to be able to mint a new bot which is something we talked about yeah uh and
then this copy is a little bit uh come on design mode here uh oh yeah we could just should we just
delete that yeah actually let's just delete this i agree delete this cool um and then i think for
these guys i like the drag i like the highlight but there's some like interesting like see how the css
kind of just like clips like that so i'm gonna see if i can try and fix that a little bit that might be
hard to oh i guess you could draw on it i could try to draw on it and say something like when the
card rotates this number stays in front of it it should be maybe oh i see what you mean it should
be like attached well like attach to the card and rotate with the card right um attach to the card
rotating with it and then these are running as sort of multiple multiple agents all at once which
is great so i can kind of see all these changes hopefully as they get deployed and then i also
think we need to improve a little bit of how we're showing the uh the abilities down here like to me
it's not really clear from this screen like you see a bunch of stats and then you see this like
hustle dex and i'm not quite sure what that means so maybe actually you mentioned multi-task actually
yeah i want to like go back to that real quick totally um what is that yeah so in cursor we have this
multitask mode uh which is really cool it basically means that we can ask the agent to do multiple
things all at once and particularly when making design changes like i do this all the time when
i'm editing something you know within our product where um you can tag a bunch of things that you want
the agent to work on and then actually click start multitasking which i did a few seconds ago and um
we'll spin up a separate sub-agent that works on each one of these capabilities and so um what this
really does is just help me parallelize a bunch of work all at once and i love it for design polish things
because it's like i'm in my head being like fix this change this do that do that and i can just
kind of get the agent to start thinking about all that once so yeah i totally agree actually that's
something i completely forgot to do when i was doing my changes earlier so like i was just blocked by my
one bot oh man and doing you know uh so okay well this is this is now fixed but that this is now
needs to be fuller height i think why not let's just tell the bot to kind of delete this container
if that makes sense so that the everything else just overlaid on like this doesn't need a container
yeah i agree i agree
and then what's up with the cupcake logo and what is going on there yeah it almost looks like a bot that's
where's our where's our design do we have a do we have a design we need to i'll check in on my bot and
see what's going on we may need to start thinking of a name at some point maybe it's not that important
now it's just it's just our coding we're getting close to it we got some got some images are generating
according to according to my bot here yeah i do have a uh a little lander potentially if we want to
show that oh okay yeah can we go to matt there we go so this is so we got the cards with the shimmer
um and what i've been doing here is i've just been i went uh grok 4-6 low effort fast and that's like
my favorite uh combination for using design mode because then i can just like yeah kind of rip on some
of these things that i don't like so you know the header was like a little too bold and close together
we made it a little bit more sparse i still don't like some of this language right um
some of this is just kind of like i'm picking things that don't make sense to me like it used
prototyping language in the lander which obviously we don't want but then even things like um hey you
know like these were it gave me like fictional bots but i was like oh just actually look at the bot
marketplace and then find me some better bots that are actually on the marketplace so we got dr egg bot
trad bot from i believe clervo uh overheard and a few others um and then one thing i noticed ai
does a ton is it'll like take something super specific about like what you're building and be like oh i'm
gonna just like show this to everybody like bro what is this like i don't i i don't want to see that
on my landing page so i need to think through at a higher level like what is this game like what
it why is it fun why should you play it and i don't think that that's like some crazy like uh
i have a bit of a contrarian take which is like do we need a lander page um in that i mean it's cool
that you have one but we already have the sign in screen i think i think but what you're highlighting
though is like the how it works part and like maybe like you know i mean like there's a the screen
that i had in my mock-up uh was like you would just you just come to the page and the first thing you see
is sign in with x sure and now that i'm thinking about it like why why would you sign so maybe there's
something about like a guide or even a mini tutorial sure yeah maybe there's like an interactive tutorial
i kind of like the lander though i like that there's sort of a home like you know if we're if
we're building this as like an app there's sort of a you you land somewhere and then you kind of click
in and you get into the actual game experience but maybe there's like other fun stuff we could add to
this over time too like you'll have a pricing page one day in terms of reducing friction because like
i want you know the players you just drop into the game it also makes it simpler which is better so
yeah i just love how this looks it's like so i do like the cards take some inspiration from this
yeah i think we should definitely keep this like little card collection here um i mean if there's
nothing else that comes away from this honestly most of the rest of this isn't yeah it's just fluff
right now like all this but i think i think just the top part of like its own little image
could be cool we just show the cupcake all the way up to the yellow bar and we just keep that
that could be really cool just what is that how it works button or link to nice oh it does it just
scrolls down it says yo yeah no honestly this is my favorite part and i love like these little bot i
actually quite like the design language here like i don't know what where like these look kind of good
to me um honestly uh all things considered we could tweak the eyes a little bit but um yeah i like this
this card stack i guess cool okay so maybe i just like keep this part and we yeah i think we should
keep the hero part of the lander and then just like a big play button that's just like play and i
think that's where you get into the login effects flow and that way we at least have like a nice place
where they're not the first thing you're seeing is just to log in because that also feels like it could
create some friction um that might be a good in between so cool i'm curious to watch you prompt this
and kind of learn from higher prompting so if you want to just quickly jump to my screen for like a few
seconds while matt's getting that ready i mentioned a keyword code for dr eggbot so you can get your
phones out and put put this graphbot link in and if you have the graphbot app installed it should prompt you
to uh it'll open the app and let you install dr eggbot um but uh yeah you can you can download
dr eggbot and add them to your roster and get them to take a look at your bots and improve their prompts
uh and it also does like a health check so be nice to have awesome and yeah you can
there's a ton of bots out there too so dr eggbot is one of our fan favorites here that
we've been using this entire time but like a ton of really cool bots out there too
depending on your role you work on uh and yeah hopefully many more to come there so how's the
progress on the account uh i'm pushing my changes into main i'm just checkpointing as i go uh so that
way if you guys are also editing we can we can pull latest but i got some of the alignment issues
fixed which i'm pretty excited about um we still need a logo so i'm looking to my design partner over
here we're checking on and okay we got these are not good i feel like i'm asking matt to multitask
a multitask mode for matt should we like take a quick second to talk about our like how we want
to split up the work and also i think we have maybe under 10 minutes left so uh maybe we'll think
about like how we split the rest of the work and then during the break we can go off and work on this
a little bit more yeah i think that's a good idea um i what i really want to spend some time on is just
getting like the core prototype built end to end because what i'd really like to get to is a point
where we have a prototype in maine that we all feel kind of good about and then we have the scaffolding
where all of us could just go independently build features and then just get our bots to help
reconcile the differences on them yeah um and so what i'd like to get to i think we need to implement
the auth system too and so i'm happy to work on that or did you already yeah i think what i was
thinking like maybe i could work on the off okay and then because like i agree with you i think
it'd be really good to like maybe just the three of us for now yeah we'll sign in and actually just
fight each other we should yeah we should play and then we can actually play yeah because i think
like play testing is like an important part so i can work on the auth uh and matt what do you what
would you like to work on so we gotta get um i think assets we need some assets so we can generate
some of those uh there's some other fun stuff i think we would work on there but maybe some
design like what the actual you were talking about like a mini tutorial i think that sounds fun so yeah
mini tutorial and i think like the abilities should have some cooler icons so they're not just text
because right now we just have like riz ability yeah that's not the most exciting thing for his
ability yeah uh the ability yeah kind of cleaning up that core loop i think that will be really cool
um maybe we spend some time kind of like designing that out together so we're really really aligned
i also think the part where we have round one round two round three now like if you see on my
what i'm trying on my screen we have this sort of um we haven't fully implemented this like the main
game loop and so i think it'd be great if we also spend some time on that and i can i can take
that as well but basically right now we just show round one and then we kind of make you click through
the whole experience which is not not super great so um but it's funny every time i play this i lose and
my elo score goes down so we have that part working uh let's see let's see what it is after this one
okay i'm at 12:58 that's pretty good oh you won i won this one as soon as you started watching i won
but yeah i mean like the core this feels pretty good if i just click click click and you can see the
elo's persistence that's nice i like this um yeah i think the the part that we'll need to really
get right is the the player feel yeah so i think like nailing the animations are going to be really
important because you know at the end of the day like right now our mechanics are not very complicated
it's just like rock more or less rock paper scissors with some numbers i think we can add more systems
later once we get the core within uh but uh it would be nice for it to have even more like visually
engaging you know like some somehow just show like what's happening like right you mean in this part
right where we're saying right now we're just showing round one immediately see like who like what
happened i guess yeah yeah and so i think this is where we i really liked your mock-ups and i think if we can come up with
like that that animation of how they how they behave um cool okay so yeah i think we have a bunch of
things to work on right yeah yeah i'm thinking uh what about some so we've been talking a lot about the
game yeah what about all the other parts of running the business all the other parts should we also
kick off some bots before the break yeah we could cook to work on like you know like gtm things yes
business things like one thing we were talking about were ads yeah start thinking about running some ads
like maybe because right now like the the bots are just battling in like in outer space but it'd be
interesting if there was like a stadium oh yeah yeah selling ads right like yeah and then you can have
like little banners or something yeah so non-intrusive not not obnoxious we'll try to sort of like ad
marketplace maybe so like where people can bid perhaps and then we like figure out a way to mock like
have us moderate the companies that are like applying to have ads yeah something like that
um how are we gonna get the companies i mean we got a stream right yeah hopefully we have some we have
some friends afford to give us some ad ad money um okay cool yeah no i can take that we can start
thinking about like the stadium and how we're gonna get ads there i also want to start thinking about
the like the game server like what i was mentioning you know not allowing people to cheat i don't know if
we need to build it right now but i'm starting to think about it um and then doing handling off so
i can take big pieces nice cool sounds like we got a lot of stuff going on yeah i'm just doing a little
bit of cleanup of our nav bar a little bit um so we have this logout button which i think is good
okay it looks like my agent is um taking over this is really cool too where i can tell the agent to to
make some changes and then in cursor uh it sort of takes control you can see that it's it's asking me
if i want to take control here but the way the agent verifies its output is it just runs itself through
the entire loop and so you know if you're building or prototyping things this is really powerful like
agents do a lot better when um they can verify their output and then earlier we showed you or i talked
about multitasking now i can show it to you so you can see that i have a queued prompt here to add a
badge to our tier system so that platinum diamond etc come with a little bit of color
and so i can just hit this button to say start multitasking and then you know the cursor agents
will automatically jump in and we'll start kind of building multiple tasks in parallel i could also
just send the prompt now if i wanted to interrupt the agent and kind of steer it and so those are both options and kind of pick whichever one makes sense
cool cool cool so it looks like we're working there i still think this captain flow is not perfect
yeah well uh oh yeah that's i like that yeah oh we need to fix this one too
i'm also wondering about like i guess maybe we can start iterating a bit on the mechanics
do you think like the random bot thing makes sense yeah our initial idea was because like assemble a team
right no because it just occurred to me like we have a re-roll button yeah like why wouldn't i just
spam that button until i got three legendary i think i think we should get rid of that feature
like no re-rolls i think once you assemble your team it's your team and you kind of
right what if like in this screen we just didn't show which which bots you got oh so it's blind it's
almost like you pick your cap and then you get two blind bots okay that could work yeah yeah
and then you can re-roll i suppose yeah uh and uh yeah drag and drop
yeah i'm gonna just also do some visual tweaks there and what were we saying so for re-roll maybe we um
i think we should just get rid of the oh no maybe yeah i think we can keep the re-roll button but
make the make these bots the non-player selected bots hidden first
um and i think we only have about two minutes left so let's quickly uh wrap up and talk about
um what we'll do next cool let me fire off this last prompt i think um multitasking is happening we have
uh we're pushing directly to maine uh for those who are just joining we're a game studio building
a game along a three-day journey of which i think we're halfway through it's a bit scary to uh get
something into production we have a bunch of design and asset work going we have um a core game loop
that we're pretty excited about a fun way to bring in some rock bots and um we're hanging out in san
francisco for three days there you go rockbot galaxy right next to dreamforce as well and so
a lot of really fun uh conversations coming up including one just in a few minutes on grok bot
for sales um but i think a couple things we're going to work on off stream we're going to keep
cooking on some design work and a lander that we really liked we're going to improve the core game
loop we're going to add authentication to our service so we can put out into the wild and we'll
do a bunch of play testing and we'll be back in 45 minutes to an hour or so and hopefully show you
guys a bunch of progress yeah there you go yeah all right with that let's kick over to the main stage
for grok bot for sales
hi everyone thanks so much for joining today's workshop on grok bot for sales my name is crystal
let's i'm on the go to market team here at spacex ai and i'm mark wright on the same go
to market team at spacex ai and excited to share with you grok bot for sales uh something near and
dear to all of our hearts here uh getting into it we'll talk about the agenda we're going to be
introducing grok bot or reintroducing to some of you uh here today why grok bots uh specifically for
sales and in the marketplace uh some sales use cases and crystal will take us through how she's
using it and demo it and then what we learned we'll have time for q a and then hands-on session together
as well all right a little bit about uh the am maturity curve and where grok bot fits in today
i think as you all know uh it's evolving very rapidly just a couple years ago we were simply using
uh chat to ask and get feedback uh you know ask a question get a response uh and then quickly
evolve into a task base where i'd say maybe clean up my my files on my computer and then come back and
uh ask for the next direction but now we're really doing uh you know bots and agents delegating full
tasks or work streams and so now you can simply say things like build me pipeline get me a meeting with
x company and it'll simply go do that and we really believe the future of where crock bot and this is
going is having more of a staff function so having a team of bots that focus on a specific set of uh
opportunities and tasks and then having them work together to essentially you know solve what you're
looking for specifically in the sales function as well in comes grok box uh hopefully it's not the
first time you've seen this but excited to re-share it with you one thing you'll notice rather quickly
looks very simple looks like i message easy to message and chat with and and figure out what to do
um you can create bots for different jobs that's highly recommended uh whatever their specialty is
you should create them and uh you know the memory aspect of these bots are really incredible
so things you've told to it at the very beginning you know one recommendation is always to tell it a
lot about yourself your functionality um log in the same way you would into different applications
so that it can then start to take over a lot of the work the mundane work that you have been doing
repetitively for days on end um and get it to to go out and start to accomplish some of those
one thing we'll get into as well as setting up automations and routines and skills ensuring that they can
simply you know take this work when you're not there uh and effectively you know work work on your behalf
as well uh and then lastly you can easily share bots and templates across to each other it's actually
something that we saw internally at spacex ai krista has been a power user for some time
and she's actually shared out uh you know templates the rest of the team so we can effectively get
moving on grokbot much faster as well
why grokbot uh as we know there's a lot of different things in the marketplace but grokbot is
really you know taking the world by storm at the moment and uh here's a few things why uh that's the case
i mentioned uh we're meeting people where they are everyone knows how to type an imessage
and so we make grokbot feel much the same functionality uh as such as well so you can simply
just type away and go from there no longer do you need to close you know keep your laptop just a
little bit open and keep it on for the boss to work it has its own computer its own vm working 24 7
when you're not able to work it uses the tools just like you do so it has access to what you as a
user would have access to and be able to go do that work uh and and as mentioned at the beginning no
longer do you have to you know really handhold it uh the future is now you know sharing uh an
objective something that needs to be accomplished right whether it's generate the pipeline and or um
you know going through and and getting a meeting with a company it's going to go out and figure out
the best way to do that uh and then you can obviously share share the work to move more quickly
all right the exciting part you know what are some real life example use cases that we're seeing
today in turning at spacex ai as well as with our customers um around the globe uh pipeline pipeline
pipeline i'm sure that's near and dear to everyone here within sales how do we generate that we'll talk
through a little bit how we're using grokbot to do so rather than you know spending all your time um
you know looking through identifying the right contacts and sending out uh we as sales folks get a lot of
questions that are really engineering specific and uh sometimes we can't always answer those and and
you know the the key here is not to always have to bug your sales engineer or engineering partner
now grokbot can actually have that uh knowledge so that you can just simply bug your grokbot in this
instance um echo is one really exciting one i think chris will take us through and it's you know how to
really live uh understand the the call and be able to you know offer in some of those insights within it
uh chief of staff is one you guys probably all seen kind of you know having a starting point
and and working through your bots from there um and then lastly like forecasting we all have to do it
it's all uh used to be a manual process and now with grokbot in your systems you can simply
you know one click or have it automated as routine to move forward from there so with that uh crystal
alternative youtube introduces to your team yeah so before i demo i wanted to introduce you to my team
of bots so first i have olive uh i like that you can customize this agent so olive is my dog she kind
of handles my day to day uh pg is outbound prospecting as you mentioned pipeline is key uh echo is one i
created that was really popular where uh i you know want to ensure that i leave a discovery call with
something like around next steps you know discuss the actual use cases the customer discussed with me
so you can easily update a deck uh just by stopping a granola recording and bot will update those slides
based on what the customer said during the meeting uh and then just like a customer expert i work with
a few strategic customers so it helps me stay on top of usage before renewals any product signals if
they're you know trying a new product within spacex ai it can track slack threads um i'm sure everyone's
slacks are very noisy uh lately so it can track any key items related to the customer uh something i really
love is like i have a lot of feature requests that customers raise so when we ship our chain
log you can actually pull up a feature request that the customer asked for maybe a month ago that i
would have forgotten about and be like hey we just shipped this changelog reach out to this customer
who asked for this feature uh kind of feels like we built a feature request for them uh and then the
engineer as you mentioned i like to think my bots like how i would work with colleagues so if i would
slack an engineer or maybe slack a bdr for something now you can have bots that go and handle this work on
their own so i can share a quick demo um let me share my screen um so as i mentioned i have my team
of bots here all of my chief of staff so she can prep me for my meetings in the morning so if you're
on the bus to the office i feel like for me that's like my most anxiety prone time is like when i'm not
at my laptop but i still need to get work done and i have like slacks and emails flowing in so it can
prep me for my day prep me for my 9am meeting and then also uh like reply to emails for me so you can
see that just has this email card um you know maybe i got a note from a customer who's asking for a one
pager it will go ahead and draft that for me i can make any changes here and then just send the email or
discard or change it so that's my chief of staff um they also have routines so you can run like a morning
inbox scan you can run this like a couple times a day i think a tip for usage as well to ensure you're
using uh using your uh uh tokens in a responsible manner is uh i actually run less routines i usually
like run a routine once or twice a day otherwise i find it really noisy um but i'll set up routines for
my chief of staff to um let me know anything coming through my inbox um i had echo that we talked about
earlier so you can see i had a couple calls today um these are demo notes but uh it can it can actually
update these slides based on what calls i had i can even ask it like hey can you translate this slide
to japanese i work with a lot of international customers so it's nice to be able to translate
slides on the fly so it'll go off and work on this um next i have pg which i think is top of mind
for anyone in sales uh so you can have uh your pg agent what i have do is it will based on my pg skill
which is available in the marketplace you can uh run a agent to go and pick five accounts in your book
it'll pull that from sales force it might look at like intent data like what are the best fits or you
can actually give it those accounts to run so you can do five accounts they can do 100 accounts i do five
and then i have it pick five contacts and instead of just like basic company data like hey oh your
company raised funding like they're probably getting the same uh outreach from a thousand companies right
now i like that it will pull like uh like personal hooks so say the cto posted on x about
uh you know building a software factory with his team or the ceo posted about like a new product
they're launching uh you can have it actually pull those personal hooks and then shape messaging not
only the company but the person what i found with other ai tools is it would pull like out of date data
or just like things that uh weren't like personally appealing i think everyone has ai now everyone can see
like basic company events but pulling actual social data i think is really important so i would highly
recommend connecting the x api i always talk about this but i think um x is like where a lot of leaders
and companies post you probably saw the apple ceo just joined x so it's a great way to like stay on top of
recent company news and uh just connect with all of your executives at the account so it'll create this
sheet uh filled with uh personal hooks um intent data like company growth maybe job openings uh anything
that you would like it to pull essentially uh it can rank contacts by like who they recommend that you
reach out to it pulled like some podcasts and webinars and your agent can actually watch these podcasts and
webinars so i think before i had graphbot i would like try to listen to a few webinars or podcasts on my way to
the office but it just wasn't scalable to listen to a 45-minute webinar and then try to find
a you know hook or blurb where the cto or ceo whoever you're working with mentioned something that
would be relevant for what you're trying to partner with them on so it can watch these webinars and pull
out actual quotes uh or things that relate to how your business would help them and then put together
messaging and then you can uh draft it in your gmail you can have it like create like a card like this
and edit them and uh something i do before i send all this is i have graphbot scan your gmail uh your
slack or even your x like give it writing that you're proud of and it will know your writing style and know
your voice i'm very picky that things sound like me when i write uh i don't like the generic you know
lm uh type uh style writing so i think to like de-slop that a little bit is to make sure that it
understands your writing style uh so that's my pg bot i've booked a lot more meetings with executive
buyers just because i really understand uh new things that are important to them based on what they've posted
about uh i don't know does anyone enjoy uh updating salesforce uh next steps that are pipeline probably
not oh you do okay i have one person who enjoys updating salesforce oh no no no okay perfect uh so
this is like one of my favorite things because it'll actually listen to my granola and gong calls
and it'll pull out relevant context to be able to update next steps i even gave it like the format i
wanted uh like my initials the date uh customer outcomes what are next steps and you can give it the
format and then it'll pull those details from your emails from your slack uh from your granola from
your gong and update those for you and then you can like review it and then push to salesforce
uh which is really powerful powerful i talked about this a little bit earlier but i have a few strategic
customers so my job is to really know these customers in and out a lot of times i work across
different departments i have multiple slack channels maybe internal channels external channels
maybe they're emailing me or other members of my team uh so i work with notion as my database for
my customer expert so after every call it will update notion uh on the account plan any signals maybe
i have a renewal coming up who are the stakeholders i need to reach out to what were the calls we've
had what projects are we working on so it'll automatically update this account plan in notion
uh it will kind of detail the next steps i can pull any usage data here for this example i asked
like what the top 20 power users are so my team and i can reach out get their feedback prior to the
renewal or maybe we're shipping like a you know new feature that they'd like to try out uh you can see
uh that there was like that there was like a um you know a um a customer question in a slack channel so
it'll you know kind of pay me when things are top of mind or i need to action on things so i found that
really valuable just spending more time with customers not spending time like searching through notion
asking an engineer a question um and on that note uh i have an engineer it's connected to the code the code base
so when i'm live on a call instead of you know needing to get back to somebody i can just ask a
question live in a call like one example is uh we work with customers that set up cloud agents a lot so
i could ask like hey can you send me a customer facing answer on how to set up cloud agents
also send me a few outcomes that amplitude and fair achieved so like maybe for this question i would
have had to like talk to an engineer or bring an engineer on the call to help walk the customer
uh through setting up cloud agents and then maybe i would have had to like talk to the amplitude and
fair uh account managers and understand like how they're leveraging cloud agents or talk to those
customers myself but it'll pull that customer or that uh response uh from a code base uh a lot of times
i paste this in slack so it kind of already knows how i work and like shares with me like a pace ready
version i can share um but it gives me all the steps to set up cloud agents and then it also uh shows
customer outcomes like how have we worked with other customers to set up cloud agents and what are the
outcomes achieved so i use this a lot um and then just like pulling content i think like the most powerful
thing for me is just like actually watching content and doing things i like to think of graphbot like
not just like as like a thinking partner or like a research partner actually like a doing partner so i could have it you know watch a customer webinar with a
ceo and be like okay based on this webinar dropped me in outreach messaging or
put together messaging for my ceo to reach out to the ceo and set up a meeting to talk about their three
key objectives and how it relates to what we can do uh for their business so uh when i first started working
with graphbot i think i mistakenly started using it as i would like a chat interface so i was like hey
go and do this research and then it actually gave me the links to go and watch these webinars myself
uh but i kind of pushed back i was like hey no go watch those webinars for me and draft an email for
me so i think you have to change your mindset with how you work with these uh like think of them like
colleagues who have their own computers they can work overnight and they can do these things for you
so a lot of times when i'm prospecting i will just have my prospecting bot uh work overnight on like
a very long list and then just have all the emails ready to go for me in the morning and then i think
every day i like to add like you know 20 more like okay well uh you drafted these email responses that's
great we'll go in and draft like linkedin responses or go find 10 other people to reach out to you can
kind of build upon your bots as you continue to use them i also use graphbot a lot for travel and expense
i'm sure we all do uh also expenses are not fun so you can find like starlink flights which is helpful
um and then i use x spot a ton so this is connected to the x api um as i mentioned like i found just
like linkedin is a pretty out of date with company information and you can kind of dig and find like
who you can you can reach out to um and then i also just like learn it like use a graph bot for learning
um so if you're like researching like a new topic um like one i like to like think about is like um
spacex um or maybe it's like uh learning about um or like a topic like i want to research um new
restaurants or something uh but you can just like pull up a new chat and research restaurants to reach out
to um but uh yeah these are one of my favorite things you can ask it to be like hey can you
watch the most recent webinar with roman uh around grok bot on lenny's podcast yeah i think we have a
lot of grok bots actually watching this as well yes yeah there's probably grok bots live um so it'll go
off and watch uh any live rock bot webinars yeah and chris i want to hit on one thing on the engineer
piece um the engineer one uh this has been impactful for me as well in terms of like speeding up my deal
how many times we all been there where it's like oh yeah let me find the answer and get back to you
but now with the engineer bot we've been able to like quickly get those answers answer them on the call and
really speed up the next steps and an opportunity and that one i highly recommend is really impactful for
for us in the organization as well perfect um i think that's all i had planned for today happy to go
through any questions happy to go through any demo items um but would love to you know chat more uh
we'll kind of finish up with what we've learned today and then we'll open up for questions at the end
sure you want to get back there perfect great so um a few tips and tricks kind of what we learned
today looking at that as well as overall um the biggest thing we talk about our customers is really
connect your stack like look at uh what you use in your day-to-day operations and get those connected
directly in grokbot um that's really going to help you speed up uh the time to value here and uh it's
really impactful in terms of you know getting those aha moments early and starting to really uh you know
work within grokbot one thing we've talked about too whether you use like a chief of staff to delegate
down or grokbot by grokbot um you know have one bot with one job like this is your focus and christa
showed a great example like we have engineer we have pipeline generation travel and expense
have them be an expert in that field these are your team members that you're onboarding
have them be an expert and give them all the relevant information materials to be great at that
at that job um and then another one is uh work on the routine some people use them more regularly
and some people don't i frankly like the automations and routines kind of like ron papay like set it and
forget it have it do the work and uh you know come back to me with anything necessary and that's a good way
to make sure that it's always working and doing the the tasks uh needed so three tips to take you
forward on your grokbot journey after this but would be great to open up the floor to any questions you
you may have uh for krista and myself sure
i think it depends how you're using it like uh there's ways to reduce your amount of usage which is like running less routines a day
i think we had one example where someone acts like a routine for every 15 minutes so those are like ways to reduce your usage
i personally don't use routines a lot because i find them too noisy so i just run them once or twice a day
and i think another way to save on token consumption is i personally like work with my specialized bots and i feel like if i use my chief of staff we
i didn't show this today but your chief of staff can orchestrate other bots so if i'm working on like a deck it'll call
like the you know deck designer or maybe working with a customer it'll like call that like customer uh bot and like pull the account data
And I feel like if I use my chief of staff, I didn't show this today, but your chief of staff can orchestrate other bots.
So if I'm working on a deck, it'll call the deck designer or maybe working with a customer, it'll call that customer bot and pull the account data.
I personally like to work with my specialized bots, and I found that reduces tokens as well.
But it's highly personalized to what use cases you're leveraging.
Another tip is I use computer use if there's not a good MCP available.
I think most of us work in sales, and I've just found a lot of the sales tools we have don't have great MCPs.
But I would save the computer use for if there isn't an MCP available already.
Thankfully, we shipped a lot of MCPs out of the box.
I think we shipped Gong, Granola, Salesforce, and more.
So use the MCPs when you can and save computer use for when you need it.
Great point.
Just to add, I'm probably the opposite where I'm like, chief of staff, routines.
So perhaps my spend is certainly higher.
But one thing I make sure to do is ask Rockbott for optimization tips.
It's a great way to go there and say, look, figure out a way to be able to optimize some of our workflows here
and what's the best way to save money.
The fact that we leverage first-party models in a lot of these things really helps reduce that cost anyway.
What do you think is a good hack in order to maintain a really good knowledge space?
Like connected to Notion, Granola, ask to download Obsidian and manage an Obsidian account.
I mean, what would be a good hack if you get bigger and bigger knowledge space?
Yeah, I could start that.
I mean, I think if I understood correctly, we meet where you are, right?
Like what are you using internally within your company and where does that knowledge sit?
That's typically the best way to be able to quickly get access and start to work through these things quickly.
For us, I feel like everything lives in Notion and Slack.
And so connecting those two has been really the unlock for our company in order to like hack, if you will, a way to move quickly.
Yeah, obviously we use Salesforce.
So Salesforce has been like a source of truth.
But I think I see GroffBot as like an orchestration layer of all those tools.
So whenever I need data, like I can pull it from GroffBot.
So whether it needs to go to Databricks or Salesforce or Notion or Slack,
I don't think any company is good at maintaining data and having it in one place.
Usually, at least before I had GroffBot, it was like, oh, great, you want this data?
Like go to Databricks.
Oh, you want this data?
Go to Salesforce.
Or this is a Notion.
Or no, someone just posted some Slack the other day.
So it's like really impossible, I think, especially for very Slack-heavy companies to stay on top of where data lives or when something changed.
So I think GroffBot is like a really great outer layer of pulling that information wherever it lives,
whether it's Notion or Salesforce, Slack, or anything.
Delegate task to Cursor or do you have to tell it to, hey, this is what I want, and then go build with Cursor?
Yeah, you can tell GroffBot to spin off Cloud Agents.
So you would just have your Cursor account connected.
But if you're like, hey, go spin off Cloud Agents and Cursor, you would just tell the bot to do it in natural language.
Great, thank you.
We got one question from X.
There's some confusion on when to use a specialist bot.
So the question is, would you set up a bot for a major client or would you create an expert that handles all of your clients?
I think this is preference.
I think I even asked my GroffBot the other day.
I was about to spin up a new bot and I was like, hey, should I keep these bots separate or should I move it all to one space?
So I personally have bots for each of my strategic customers, but I only work across a couple where I know other AEs at other companies or even at SpaceX AI work across hundreds of customers.
So I think it's preference, but what would you recommend?
Yeah, absolutely preference there.
And the way I do it is somewhat similar but different where I've got bots that are delegated to these customers, which is looking at their intent,
you know, kind of taking the notes from our previous calls and able to kind of feed into there.
And then I've got my chief staff that kind of directs them on what to do.
And then I've got the intent one that's actually just looking at all things GrockBot and building demos for me on my behalf on the GrockBot so that any call I get into,
I can quickly spin up a demo and go from there.
One of those things where it's like once you get started with GrockBot, you can kind of figure out the best way to do so.
And I think X is the best way to find those quick wins as well.
Sure.
There seem to be some pre-packaged skills already, right?
So if we download these, can you customize them for your use case and edit those as well?
Yeah, one, we already have some sales use cases on our GrockBot like template marketplace, but you can also create your own.
So if you want to share your own templates with your team or even on X, like I think everyone in this room probably has a good template you can steal or share.
But there's some on the back of the cards if you're in the room with us.
And we also have a marketplace online.
I also have an X account, so I like to share mine.
But yeah, you can steal others' templates.
And I think that's what makes GrockBot like so fun and easy to get started is you can steal what somebody has already built and customize it for real in use cases.
And the product team from the sales organization, is it via Slack or there is a better way to do that from GrockBot?
Like how do I communicate with other departments?
Talking to other organizations, sales is talking to marketing all the time, products all the time, or like, you know, so what is the best way?
Right now we do it, of course, through Slack, but is there a better way to do that communication?
Yeah, right now I do that via Slack, but you can also use GrockBot to track channels.
So if you're in a marketing channel, maybe about this event, and you want to track what's going on, you can keep track of that event within GrockBot.
So we've been talking a lot about personalized setups, your preferences versus yours.
How would we set this up for, or do you work on setting it up for a team where you kind of had somebody else in sales, here's your kind of standardized setup, and then personalized from there?
Is there a good way to do that for a company?
Yeah, there's some best practice out there.
Certainly like today, we are working with customers on like how they want to set this up.
The starting point has really been everyone get GrockBot and start to build it for yourself.
So very, very good point there.
What we are seeing in terms of a change is like now when you get into GrockBot, it's going to ask you about your role and maybe pre-give you some of these templates that make the most sense for you.
Some of the more advanced companies, though, are like leveraging a power user that's done really well, like Chris in this instance that has templates, and then kind of sharing those out for as a sales rep at your company.
I'm going to get these five bots populated into my instance and then be able to run from there.
And if I'm in marketing, perhaps I get another five.
So possibly there's really endless there, and that's been a big shift we've seen more recently of like having this pre-enabled based on your role or personas in the company.
So is that set up through your cursor account where you start setting that up on the enterprise level?
Yeah, directly through GrockBot, you can kind of build these up and then share them to new users, right?
So a little bit like let's build them out, and then a new user will just share them over so they have them day one.
Are you able to demo the EchoBot on how during call, right, somehow you have some streaming capability to stream the transcribe to the bot itself so that you can understand context to update the slides or something?
It's not the EchoBot that you have.
Sorry, how do I stream?
The EchoBot.
Oh, EchoBot.
Oh, okay, yeah.
So I use Granola, so I'll do discovery usually like most of the call, and I just like stop the EchoBot or stop Granola, and I run Echo, and it'll just pull the Granola transcript automatically and just like start working on the slides.
So Granola is like very quick, so I also use Gong too, so if you use Gong, I would say use Gong because it takes a couple minutes for it to load after the call finishes, so that's probably more for like the next call or to send out after the call, but you can run Granola during the call, stop it, and then just run the EchoBot, and it'll live update during the call.
I think it takes me two minutes, so maybe give yourself two minutes, and then it'll update.
Got it.
Thank you.
Yep.
Perfect.
I think we're going to wrap up here, but lastly, thanks for all the questions.
Before we jump into building, I wanted to announce that we just launched an exclusive challenge on X, so you can share a GrokBot.
We talked about templates a lot.
You can share one of your GrokBots that you can't live without and how you use GrokBot for work, and you and a plus one could head to Starbase and actually get the chance to watch a Starship launch in person, which I'm very jealous.
I would love to watch a Starship launch.
So to enter, you can follow at Grok and at Bot on X, and then quote our challenge post on X with a description of your GrokBot and a link to your shared bot template, and you can scan the QR card here and save the X post.
You'll need the quote to enter the challenge, so best of luck.
Great.
Perfect.
Thank you all.
Thank you.
Thanks.
And we're back.
And while Lauren and Roshan are off getting some work done, I am joined by another Matt,
one of my favorite Matt's, Matthew Berman, who can maybe tell us a little bit about himself.
And we're going to go into how he uses Crockbot, some of what he's seeing in AI.
But first I'll let him introduce himself.
Sure.
Hey everybody.
I'm Matt Berman.
I make content for a living now, which is still wild to say out loud.
Yeah.
All about artificial intelligence.
I do everything.
I do everything from model reviews, breakdown news, sometimes geopolitics, research papers,
sometimes tutorials, but everything is generally artificial intelligence.
And I've been doing it for about three years.
Before that I've been in technology for about 20.
Nice.
Amazing.
And while you're number one, a friend of the Crockbot team, we've hosted pop-ups with you.
We've done a lot of collaborations.
Also just a really great content creator.
And I take some inspiration from your work.
We've been friends for a while.
I remember you're talking about moving up to the Bay Area.
Now you're in the Bay Area.
Yeah.
I see you around all the time.
It's great.
How are, I guess we could start with, how are some of the ways you're creating content changing
with AI?
And then we can tie that into some other things, but I think it's a good place to start.
Yeah.
This was like kind of an interesting learning over the past, especially year.
I tell a lot of people like don't use AI for the actual creative process.
When you're coming up with the ideas and deciding what to make and you really actually have to
invest the time and be creative.
But especially in the last few weeks, we have figured out how to increase our productivity
substantially simply by doing things like, I mean, my team has been incredible.
Ryan and Alex with editing videos using AI.
And prior to three weeks ago, it wasn't even possible, it seems.
Okay.
But then all of a sudden they're dictating and they can do multiple edits in parallel.
And it's really great.
Obviously we're doing a lot of behind the scenes automation with AI.
So everything from like sponsor management to taking notes for us during meetings, follow-ups,
proposals, everything kind of the back office stuff.
That is easy to automate.
You should automate it.
The new stuff that we're getting into with video editing is what's most exciting to me right now.
Cool.
And yeah, it sounds like you're kind of trying to automate back house stuff, trying to eliminate
some of the managerial, like more just like tedium from your day.
Yeah, absolutely.
And then using that to spend more time focusing on the creative side, right?
Yeah.
That's where humans are going to be more and more in value is going to go to that kind
of how creative can you be?
How well can you craft an interesting story, a compelling story for other people?
That skill set is going to increase in value over time.
So I'm super excited about that.
I mean, I'm excited about it too, because yeah, I just love creating things.
And so it's exciting to think, okay, well, I'm going to be able to spend more time doing
what I love.
And so seeing that in your creative team and your creative process, how are you using like
Brockbot in some of these things or maybe for your personal life?
I'd just love to hear how you use tools like Brockbot to get more done.
Yeah.
So Matt and I were talking right before this.
I actually want to pull up some of the Brockbots I'm using because I wanted to talk
to you about it.
Okay.
So the one I've been using probably the most is the family bot.
And so I set up this bot and it reads all of the emails.
And I have two kids.
They go to different schools right now.
They have multiple sports, multiple after school activities.
And I get like, I don't know why every single teacher, every single coach decides to send
a like three page email every other day.
So I'm getting these things so often.
And of course, I have a million other emails to get there.
So I have my growth bot reading every single email, making sure, hey, it's family related.
One of the kids.
It'll summarize it for me in like one to two sentences.
It'll actually recommend when I have to take action rather than just like, hey, here's something
you have to know.
It's like, hey, you need to tell the coach if you can show up to this event or not.
Yeah.
That's been incredibly, incredibly helpful.
Then I have it connected to my calendar with my wife.
We have a special family calendar.
It automatically puts the events on our calendar.
It will notify us if there are any conflicts.
It'll help us solve it.
I know like all it's like very specific to being a parent, but I can't tell you how much
time this single bot alone has saved me.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, if you take a step back, these are the problems like everybody faces,
which is like you have two calendars and you need to like manage multiple information sources.
And the glue that holds all of those things together traditionally has been like a human.
Like I would be trying to do that.
You make mistakes and it's like really painful because you have to read a three page email.
And I think before GrokBot, like what that looks like is, oh, I'll write like a script
and have AI parse the things.
And then you're creating service accounts and doing all this weird stuff.
So what it allowed for me and it sounds like for you as well is like, oh, I can just stick
all these things together really quickly and then drop an agent on top of it.
And it turns out that's like a really powerful, really powerful interface.
Yeah. I think there's actually also a meta aspect to it, which is like once you connect
one of these things, whether it's your calendar or your email, you don't, you don't necessarily
have to do it again.
It kind of already knows where to look.
Yeah.
Um, and, and I think that's really the power of it, where it would just make assumptions
about the way that I want things done just so like, you know, it saw an email and it knew
I had this other event at the same time.
And it knew I had a preference for not taking meetings in the morning.
And it, it just kind of learns these things over time.
And it just, I'm not having to re-explain myself over and over again, which is super helpful.
So it sounds like maybe some skills or memories or something that's like, you know,
remembering your preferences essentially.
Yeah.
I mean, you know, all, all of this stuff kind of was inspired by, I think originally OpenClaw.
When we first saw OpenClaw, it was incredible.
And, but like, I think what really stood out for GrokBot in particular is all of the difficulties
of having to manage and fix and maintain a lot of the kind of initial AI assistant software
that was out there.
It's all gone.
Yeah.
It just works, you know, and I think that's, that's been a really nice thing.
Um, I give my wife access.
We have a shared telegram.
So now she has access to certain bots of mine and she doesn't have to think about,
okay, what's a bot?
What memory does it have?
She just like interacts with it as if it were an AI assistant.
That's super cool to hear.
It's cool to hear that your family is using these tools as well, because, you know, I think
we're still a ways away from like mainstream adoption, right?
Yeah, I agree.
And many people watching this might not even know what CrockBot is, right?
And so, you know, to kind of ground it, you know, you referenced another AI agent tool
and it was like these personal assistants that got everybody really excited this year.
And I think it's because of the idea and like the promise of like, oh, hey, you can just
connect everything to this agent.
And then the agent like reads messages, drafts emails, like takes care of the things you don't
want to take care of.
Yeah.
So the core idea is like, oh, there's an agent and maybe you run it on your laptop, right?
But that's like not really secure.
So it needs to run in the cloud.
But then that host, that brings all these other problems together.
Like, okay, how do you run an AI system securely in the cloud?
And I think the original AI assistants, right?
That was the hard part.
Everybody's talking about buying Mac minis, getting VPSs, doing all this crazy stuff.
But now it's like, okay, GrokBot exists.
And it's just an agent that accesses all this stuff and just runs in the cloud.
There's no setup.
Most people don't want to think about it.
Exactly.
They don't want to.
I mean, you know, let alone like getting everything installed and then making sure it has access
to the right a computer, the internet, browser control.
People don't want to think about this.
The broad audience does not want to think about that stuff.
I generally don't want it.
Like if I'm on the run, like if I'm taking a walk or I'm doing something else and I need
to shoot off a quick email or a task, I don't want to have to think about how it's all working
behind the scenes.
I don't want, you know, that's not where I want to spend my time.
And I think the new generation of AI assistants like GrokBot are incredibly good at kind of abstracting
all of that complexity away.
Super interesting.
And so you talked about how you're using GrokBot with like your family ops.
Do you have any other cool use cases for us?
Yeah.
Okay.
So I think I mentioned this before we started streaming, but one of the coolest ones is I
went around my house, gathered everything that I wanted to sell.
Like stuff that I've not used in a while.
I had like a PlayStation I didn't use for a while, a mountain bike.
You're getting rid of the PlayStation dude?
Come on.
I got rid of it.
I know.
And especially with GTA six coming up soon.
I kind of regretted it in that moment, but like I haven't turned it on in a year and
a half.
So, okay.
Anyway.
So like I took pictures of everything.
I sent all the pictures to GrokBot and just said, list them.
Like I, and so it, the only things that I had to do after that were log in to Facebook.
So it listed it on Facebook marketplace and log into eBay.
Some of them it listed on eBay.
Right.
And so like the mountain bike, I want to meet somebody in person cause I don't want to ship
a mountain bike.
You can't really ship a, you know, 70 pound mountain bike.
Um, but for like everything else I shipped it and yeah, it just, okay.
So posted everything, did the research on what the items were like that.
Like that, that's a big part of shipping or sorry, selling, making sure the listing is
really complete.
Yeah.
Did all the research, put the listing together, hosted it and then watched it.
And then when we got questions from potential buyers, it would automatically try to answer
them.
And if it couldn't, it would ask me for like, Hey, how would you answer this?
Or Hey, do you want to, uh, entertain this kind of lower price?
Um, and it, it just followed up indefinitely.
And I've already sold.
Yeah.
I sold the PlayStation.
Um, I sold the Mac book and I'm, I'm still working on getting that mountain bike sold,
but like it is just mad.
I was just showing you, I just got a message.
Somebody offered me a price.
So I'm going to go negotiate or I'll let my grandpa negotiate it.
Yeah.
You could sell it live on this.
Uh, that's funny, you know, and I actually use mine for similar, actually buying things
sometimes on Facebook marketplace, definitely like negotiating a lot of like purchasing and
understanding these items.
Like you have to immerse yourself in the domain.
Software is very similar, right?
You have to understand, Oh, what is a mountain bike?
Like how much is it worth?
Well, how much is my mountain bike worth?
What are like the variables?
Nobody has time to do that.
Yeah.
To then list this thing.
And so you can just ask an agent that can do web search to understand relative prices.
It got comps.
Yeah.
It actually got the comparables for mountain bikes that had sold in the last six months.
And yeah, and it like listed it at a great price.
And yeah, and you know, it's impressive.
I think one of the things that, that might go, um, understated is that we talk about these
personal use cases and then people go, okay, but like you're trying to get us to use
GrokBot in our jobs or whatever.
And I think the important thing is like personal problems map almost directly to business problems.
You're trying to sell something.
Okay.
Well, like you could use GrokBot to haggle with a vendor the exact same way that we're describing
using it in Facebook marketplace.
Right.
Okay.
Go help me understand the wrong materials.
Help me understand the data.
Help me understand deals that like my teammates are doing and synthesize all of that.
And then in this communication that I'm having, I don't have to go ask somebody.
Right.
Yeah.
We do something very similar.
I mean, for, for my business forward future, uh, we work with sponsors.
I make videos.
They want to tell my audience about their, their products.
Okay.
So we take on sponsors.
Um, GrokBot now knows about all of our different ad units.
It knows about the pricing.
It knows about our inventory.
Yeah.
Uh, it knows about the context of the relationship.
Have we worked with this company before?
Have we not?
And it, and it helps me.
Um, it joins all the meetings via, uh, uh, fathom, which is like an, like an AI recording
for meetings, uh, gets the transcript, understands, basically puts it all together.
And at the very end, it's just like, okay, here's your proposal.
And I didn't have to do anything.
And, and, you know, sometimes I'll say, okay, actually that's like a little bit off.
Or, you know, we have a little bit of other context here.
Like it's right.
And it's saving me so much time.
Yeah.
It's, it's really nice.
And that's kind of the back office stuff I had mentioned earlier.
Okay.
Interesting.
Yeah.
And I mean, same for me, I joined cursor and then eventually SpaceX, like right around
the time of this acquisition.
And so there's like a lot of context going on.
Um, and luckily GrokBot was like in development at the time.
So I had access to it throughout my entire tenure here.
I just use it for onboarding.
Like Lee hired me, shout out Lee.
Amazing, amazing guy.
Lee Robinson.
Yeah.
Um, at Lee Rob on Twitter, just a little plug.
Uh, and you know, I, I feel bad like being somewhere and I have to like ask people things.
Like I feel useless, but even then normally at a company, you start your job and you're like,
okay, like, I guess I got to open the company wiki and like read all this stuff.
And then I don't know where the stuff is.
I got to ask somebody, I got to putz around and search, click in Slack, find messages.
It's like the information retrieval, very similar to how you're retrieving information across
your email and your calendar with your wife.
All this stuff is like, now you actually have the shared context that you could just say,
um, who owns this thing?
Look in Slack.
Look in notion.
How do I get X, Y, Z done?
Oh, actually I'm blocked on firms.
Like have other people been blocked on similar permissions in the past?
Who did they talk to and to get this stuff done?
Totally.
And you just like, what I've found is the number of messages I've had to send to like a manager
or like to my teammates to ask them random questions is like nearly zero.
And that compounds over an entire organization.
If you have everybody that has the agency to be able to just answer questions, it's outstanding.
Okay, Matt, let me extend on that point because you're right.
You kind of made me realize how valuable that is in the moment with AI.
Like if, okay, if I have, you know, 150 emails coming in every day and I'm trying to remember
in a moment, what did this person say about, you know, a sponsor?
What was the last context I had with them?
And I'm working with a bunch of sponsors.
I don't necessarily have to go search through my email, dig through it, look through the thread,
look through all of the replies.
I simply ask the bot and it just, it'll go and find it.
Yeah.
And so I think that reduces the amount of context switching, but also context searching,
which is what you just mentioned.
And that also is a huge, huge value.
Like just the, and okay, now multiply that across multiple email addresses, Notion and Slack
and, you know, Drive and all these other things.
Now you have documents and context in so many different places.
And you don't have to remember where each one is now.
Right.
And, and I'm realizing like I've been doing that, but maybe I didn't put it verbally how,
how important and how valuable that, that kind of piece of it is.
Yeah.
And I mean, to me, these are like universal problems and it's almost like, I can't really
remember what it was like when I was like, oh man, I need to like go like look through Slack.
I'm like, I'm never going to do that again because it's like really hard to find stuff.
Yeah.
Um, and searching across multiple calendars.
I remember, you know, just a couple of weeks ago I got invited to something.
I think it was like a company event.
And I was like, wait, did someone post that that was happening in Slack or post that or
send me an email or just put it on my calendar.
And if they did put it on my calendar, like when was it?
And you talk about like, Hey, we just want AI to be easy.
Right.
Like as humans, this is like Friday after like my brain was like cooked.
I'm like, I don't even know like where I am right now.
I, you know, this is, but this is like being an employee and doing a job.
It's like there are times when you're overloaded with all this information.
And to just ask AI, could you remind me like when this thing is and where it was?
It might seem like a simple thing, but that could be the difference between you missing
like an important meeting or being there.
Right.
Totally.
Do you remember Microsoft recall?
Do you remember?
It was like maybe a year and a half, two years ago where Microsoft was, they announced
this product recall, which would watch everything you do on the computer.
Okay.
And it was kind of this like super powered search.
So, and, and so it would effectively like take screenshots of everything you were doing
on the computer.
And then you would be able to ask AI like, Hey, I remember this email.
Like where would they like leading up to the launch got so much flack about like the privacy
and the security.
And, and it's just, it's like, it's, it's like very different from, from how GrokBot works.
But I think back to that and I, at the time was so excited.
Yeah.
Just not having to remember where all the things are.
In, in the 70, the, you know, the 17 different places that I store documents.
Um, and, and so now everybody's kind of opting in.
I'm like, no, I want to share all this stuff.
I would have been okay.
But yeah, at the time they got a lot of crap.
It is interesting.
It is interesting how everyone has like leaned into kind of like some of these agentic, you
just trust the model, you know, like it's going to work out.
You trust the guardrails.
Um, also security has evolved substantially since then.
Yeah.
It's not just taking screenshots anymore.
It's like, no, we actually have a secure connection to the system of record.
I mean, even like some of these personal assistants you're mentioning earlier this year.
I remember, uh, you know, cause I do technology demos.
Yeah.
Someone was like, Hey, I want you to like demo this thing on our service.
And I look at it and I'm like, I can't show people this.
Like it's just dumping passwords in plain text.
Now compared to that to Grokbot where it's like you have secure entry.
It goes into a vault.
Like the agent can't even see the password.
Right.
So that is much more, much more secure.
And you have a much smaller blast radius.
Um, if any of these systems get compromised, um, shifting gears a little bit.
One other use case you told me about, which I think is interesting.
You told me, Grokbot helped you with your electricity bill.
Is that correct?
Yeah.
I'd love to hear about this.
I pay a lot for electricity.
So, so, okay.
So I kept getting these emails from PG and E saying like, Hey, you could save on your electricity
bill.
You have an electric car.
So you should, you know, think about one of these other plans.
I looked at the email.
First of all, it's like three pages.
Okay.
Like a ton of texts and, and maybe, maybe I have no attention span.
Maybe that's it.
But I'm looking at this email and I'm like, okay, I would like to save money and I would like
to change plan.
And then I would just like, Oh, then I have to compare like what plan should I be on?
They don't tell you.
Yeah.
And so I, so I gave Grokbot, I took a screenshot of the email, gave it to Grokbot.
And I said, figure out if I should switch plans and which one, look at my previous 12
months of electric, uh, electricity usage, look at the bills and, and tell me.
And so all it asked me to do was log into PG and E and that was it.
And so it did all this review looked at all the previous 12 months of my bills and said
like, Oh yeah, you could save a thousand dollars by switching to this other plant that is, you
know, especially tailored for having an electric car and doing like off peak usage, charging
off peak usage power.
Um, and I was like, wow, that was like really easy.
I had to double check the math twice just in case.
Yeah.
I switched plans this morning.
There you go.
Yeah.
Thousand bucks.
Thousand bucks a year.
I mean that it's incredible.
Maybe all in all took about 60 seconds of my actual mental attention.
And I, right.
I love classifying problems like these, right?
Because it's like, again, you're talking about like a very specific personal problem.
And there might be people out there like, Oh, I don't actually pay that much for electricity.
Like this doesn't apply to me.
Right.
But it's like, there are all these things in our life that we have to pay attention to.
And part of being an adult is that like, you can't, it's just like so hard to give your attention to all these things.
Yeah.
Whether it's your like, your kids emails or like stuff at your job.
It's like, you're so, maybe you're so overloaded that you pick a more expensive supplier at your work just because it's easier for you to do that.
You just don't want to think about it.
Exactly.
Yeah, totally.
And now it's like, okay, well, if I can at least map the problem space and then put an agent on figuring that thing out, you don't have to worry about that.
Right.
And you can optimize these things.
Yeah.
It's so interesting you say that.
I've talked about this a lot on my channel.
The ROI on tasks that had kind of a lower value is now substantially greater.
The ROI on, let's say like you have two things to choose from.
One which would have been $10,000 of value and one which would have been $1,000 of value.
Obviously you're going to focus your human mental attention on the $10,000 one, maybe forgetting or just dismissing the $1,000 one because it just didn't make sense.
Now you can do both.
Right.
And both of them take substantially less attention and thus like the ROI on investing in that getting, you know, whatever the $1,000 value thing.
Like, hey, like simply getting changing plans on my electricity or whatever else it is, it makes a lot of sense now.
It just becomes much easier.
And I think an extension of it is just have it go through your email and look at all your subscriptions.
Like even if it's $9.99 a month and you haven't used it in six months, go ahead and cancel it.
Yeah.
And you can have GrokBot, you can have your AI assistant do that for you now.
And like previously you would have maybe said like, okay, that's $9.99 a month.
Maybe I'll use it next month.
And I don't really want to click through and have to answer 17 questions about why I'm canceling.
It's like, no, no, GrokBot, go ahead, cancel.
Yeah.
And that's it.
It's done.
Yeah.
Totally agree.
It just incentivizes like the agency.
Like if you're the type of person that you like to get stuff done or you just feel like you don't have enough time, right?
You're limited by time or resources to get things done, but you have like the energy and willingness to like dig into problems.
Yeah.
It's like, hey, look, I mean, anytime you've ever gone to the doctor's office.
This has happened to me.
I use GrokBot and Grok for these sorts of things.
Like you get a bill and the bill makes no sense.
And you're like, dude, where did this number come from?
Nobody can explain it to you.
You can just use AI and not have to spend your Saturday morning trying to understand a bill.
And that's like you said, one of those things where it's like, oh, maybe I just don't want to deal with this.
I'll give them a couple hundred bucks and it's just like, you know, now I can have something that helps me like figure that thing out.
Yeah.
I want to bring up something.
Okay.
Maybe you struggle with this now.
I am getting more work done than ever.
And I know you've probably heard this.
I'm also busier than ever.
I'm actually struggling on the attention or like not the attention, the context switching between all of these things.
I'm kicking off so many different agents and they're coming back.
And I still like there is still this cognitive load of switching between different threads, switching between different pieces of context.
How do you solve for that?
Like what does your workflow look like?
Oh, that's interesting.
So it's funny.
We actually talked about this in a session like on the stream, just like earlier today.
And Lauren, who's probably sitting over there somewhere hacking on our software, our game design CEO, shout out Potato.
Potato gets all the shout outs on Twitter.
Like you cannot, if you go on Twitter, just it's just potatoes.
Yeah, I've been seeing her name everywhere.
It's just people saying potato.
It's insane.
So one workflow she mentioned, which is like she uses a like chief of staff.
She just calls her Steve, which I like better than chief of staff.
Chief of staff is like overplayed in my book.
Like we're on the stream.
If the chat in the stream, no more chief of staff.
Can I show you?
I have chief of staff.
Of course you have chief of staff.
I'm switching it right after this now.
I have been shamed into switching it.
I just feel like, you know, we have to be more creative.
We have to be more human with our agents.
Yeah, that's fair.
That's fair.
So anyway, just basically like the same model as a coding agent, which is that you have like an orchestrator.
Yeah.
And then you can like fan that out into sub agents.
And rather than interacting with the sub agents, you interact with the orchestrator.
So you could be like chief of staff bot talk, you know.
So, okay.
So this doesn't work without one other piece, which I'll describe, which is Lauren has like a bot factory bot, which is she thinks about how she likes to create bots.
And then she put that into a bot.
So chief of staff bot talk to, she calls it Dr. Egg bot.
This is all very playful.
Steve talked to Dr. Egg bot, right?
And create a bot to do this thing.
So now you're really only at interacting with chief of staff bot.
So you say chief of staff bot, you know, I want to understand my power, my energy bill.
Talk, you know, create a new bot that is focused on auditing that and report back.
And so now at least you're looking in this one thread and you can kind of kick off these agents that then report back.
And you're maybe in one piece of context.
So that's one way to approach the problem.
I like that.
I've done some of that, but I find myself going into each individual thread.
I'm a huge fan of having things separated by topic.
And so I do find myself like the chief of staff is where I go in the morning.
That's where I go to like really think about things and kick kick off the day's task.
But as each of the individual bots are working, I do find myself going into each one.
Yeah.
And it's kind of interesting.
I do think eventually I'll kind of more and more try to push things to just being summarized really concisely in the...
I'm just going to call it chief of staff for now, Matt.
I'm sorry.
But like I'll probably try to push more and more things, my attention specifically into the chief of staff rather than trying to go into each and every single bot that I have.
Sure.
I mean, you know, the other thing that I'll say is because I feel like everybody in AI feels like they have to have some sort of like suave answer to questions like these.
It's just like overload sometimes.
Like as an engineer, if I'm writing code, I have 10 cloud agents running at the same time working on 10 things.
Like writing code used to be like, oh, I'm going to like put on low five beats or whatever and just like chill out and think about one thing.
Yeah.
And now you're just like an overloaded manager at all times.
So I think like as an industry, we just need to evolve to understand the way to handle some of these problems.
Yeah.
And I think at least the people I've talked to, like everybody's like a little stressed out and trying to do more, you know, and that's normal.
It's so nice to hear that.
No, it's nice.
It's nice because I'm not alone on this.
It's true.
Like myself, my entire team, we're getting more done than ever.
We're busier than ever.
Yeah.
But there is this like cognitive overheating at times where I'm just like, I need to step away.
And I think a lot of these are probably design problems that'll get polished over time.
But it's really nice to hear.
Yeah, no.
I suffer with it too.
And I think it actually, in some ways, like being busy all the time, it makes you think like, what are actually the right things to focus on?
Right.
So it's like, okay, do I need to do this all the time?
So, yeah, I think this was a great conversation.
We have a customer video that we're going to kick to in a second here, Nokia.
And they're analyzing 50 million lines of code in two weeks with cursor.
So we're going to kick it over to one of our customers to learn a little bit more about that.
Cool.
Dude.
That flew by.
I can just keep going with you.
You got back.
Oh.
Whoops.
Okay.
Oh, we're back.
Are we back?
The SVP of product and engineering for one of our product development divisions at Nokia.
We are trying to leverage cursor as an agentic platform to introduce specialized agents that are persona specific for every aspect of work that we do that can partner with the human in seat that does that work today.
Those things become much more possible if we are able to iterate in much, much faster loops that directly impacts customer economics, lowers unit cost, improves customer satisfaction.
And then finally, there's an entire class of things that I think we're now going to be able to do faster that are to do with increasing resilience, reliability and security in the network.
Cursor and curses agents that increasingly many of them are out of the box is a massive step up in accelerating analysis, getting insights that otherwise would not be possible.
So we're at the beginning of a very critical journey.
We've burnt the boats.
Our plans, our goals for this year, not next year, for this year, hinge on this working.
We have a product line, easily 50 plus million lines of code.
We are, I would say, in an intermediate stage of decomposing what is fundamentally a monolith oriented architecture.
It would be a very daunting task for us to attempt a manual inspection of that code base.
We have undertaken that with cursor.
Our early results of that analysis have been remarkable.
We have been able to do precisely what I just described, which would have required bespoke tooling, would have taken far longer, probably several months of effort across probably a dozen or more expert people.
We performed the initial analysis as one example within a matter of, I think, a couple of weeks by two people.
We've seen evidence of cursor being deployed very successfully in situations that involve a need to move very quickly,
where we have run into a customer impacting defect that might be having a subscriber impact.
And now we're able to do that against an extremely large corpus of service requests and radically accelerate something like a root cause analysis.
These examples have not been one or two.
They've been quite a few and growing in number.
That's where we're seeing, I'd say, the early success and where we would love to take it next is leveraging cursor as a platform for multi-agent deployment and orchestration,
where really the role of the engineer, the architect becomes the supervision of agents that are calling out the tools that are performing work at scale, collaborating with one another.
We are literally redesigning our entire software development lifecycle from inception through product delivery and everything that comes in between.
And we are back.
Matt has left the studio.
Now only one Matt remains.
And we have another guest.
Got it.
Got to keep the great guests coming.
Yeah, welcome back.
For those of you who are just tuning in, we are in the middle of a three-day live stream here at GrokBot Galaxy in San Francisco, part of Dreamforce, right next door to all the festivities happening right outside.
We are building together over the course of three days a business entirely implemented by GrokBot and coding agents.
And so we spent our first day kind of working through some ideas.
Today we're really deep in coding.
We were earlier today showing you how we're using bots to drive a lot of the core workflows that we use to power our software engineering stack.
Lauren is currently off stream working on reimplementing some of our prototypes into a scalable game system.
And so we're really excited to show you that when we come back on in just a few minutes here with the full team.
In the meantime, we're really excited to bring on our first intern.
I guess we actually just hired an intern.
I mean, I feel like any good team needs an intern, right?
Of course.
Like you've got someone who can help out.
Yeah.
But you're more than just an intern.
You're also currently a student at Stanford, right?
You wanted to introduce yourself and say a little bit about who you are.
Yeah.
So, hi everyone.
I am the first forward deployed intern.
So, on my full-time job, I am bringing them coffee on a day-to-day basis.
Currently, actually, before this live stream started, I was handling all the coffee logistics.
Really great.
But in my free time, I guess, whenever I get that, I'm a full-time student at Stanford University.
I'm a rising junior, and I need a job.
Hopefully, we can help with that.
And hopefully, this job is some good on-the-ground experience.
Of course.
And what are you majoring in at Stanford?
I'm majoring in computer science right now.
Cool.
And you are a huge GrokBot user.
Is that right?
Yes.
Okay.
I personally get through all of my usage in half the time limit.
Wow.
Okay.
We should really maybe take that feedback back to our usage team to figure out how we can
make that a little bit better on you.
Or just give me more usage.
That would also work.
Yeah.
Maybe there's an intern benefit that we can see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Some intern credits.
Okay.
Very cool.
Well, thanks so much for hanging out with us.
I think that's a great thing to do.
I would love for you to just talk us through how are you using GrokBot?
How has it been helpful for you in the job search?
For those of us watching maybe who aren't as familiar with how a job search goes these
days, how that process works nowadays.
I feel like it's a really competitive market, particularly for software engineering.
Maybe let's start off with that.
How does the job market work these days?
What are the things you're having to manage as you're going through the job search process?
Let's start with that.
Yeah, of course.
So keep in mind that I started my job search, my internship search around two to three months
ago.
Now there's usually like three to four pathways that I like to think of when it comes to the
job search.
First is obviously the normal method, which is cold applying.
You see that job for SpaceX AI, SWE internship, and then you see that and then you're like,
all right, I got to apply within three hours.
At the end of the day, any big company is going to get over 200, 500 applications.
So it becomes very competitive very fast.
The second approach is focusing on the startup community.
All startups need good engineers at the end of the day, and they need people who can ship
fast, deliver fast, and then also bring in new unique ideas that can improve either their
business or their workflow or anything else.
The third approach is a little bit unique in that sense, which is going outside of the cold
approach strategy and then just directly communicating with the recruiter.
Cool.
Right?
Seeing if you can email them or having a coffee chat with some employee within a particular
organization you want to work for and then have them connected with the recruiter and then get
you fast-tracked into the process.
And then the fourth strategy is just on-air begging.
For example, I'm here as a forward-deployed intern, so let's hope that stays.
Let's hope that converts.
That's hope that converts, yeah.
Well, it's funny because when you're mentioning that, there's so much that this ties to when
it comes to sales, right?
There's this sort of like you're doing some outbound prospecting where you're going out
and finding leads for your job, and then there's sort of the open contact forms where you're
filling in just like, contact us, but you kind of want to make sure that goes somewhere.
And so it feels like, and I can't help but draw that analogy, and it feels like you're
almost selling yourself, right?
Versus selling a product.
Does that sound right?
Wait, exactly.
That's a perfect analogy.
Like, you have to sell yourself when it comes to the job.
Yeah.
Whether it's cold applying, you need to be the perfect match for whatever scanner they
use.
When it comes to a startup, if you're DMing them, you have to be the perfect candidate at
the end of the day.
You have to craft the perfect DM that catches everyone's attention.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, I know you're using GrokBot to power a ton of these workflows, and so it'd be really
great if we can just get your screen up on the camera.
I think this laptop is plugged in here.
We can get that on the stream soon.
But yeah, take us through how you are using GrokBot.
And I'm curious just to maybe like walk us through your team, kind of who's in your team,
how you set up these bots.
There we go.
And if you don't mind, just like command plus a little bit.
We can zoom all in a little.
There we go.
Yeah, walk us through your team.
Actually, maybe even a little bit more if you don't mind.
Oh, yeah.
Of course.
Yeah.
So I guess I can start off with the most recent one I talked about other than begging, which
is the recruiter finder.
So right now I have a GrokBot that essentially controls my web on their VM.
It will find all different recruiters via search, searches them up on LinkedIn, uses the Apollo
extension, browser extension to see if their email address is like within their database,
copies that into a CSV, and then now I just have access to that.
And then it goes through all the different big tech companies or any tech companies that
are hiring for software engineering roles.
So for instance, you can see all the different rounds and all the different emails.
I really hope this doesn't go against any law about doxxing, but also who cares.
But as you can see, there's like a bunch of emails.
There's also this.
Let me see if I can pull up.
There's like a lot of validation scripts you've written.
Yes.
Some cool notes there.
Yep, yep, yep.
Cool.
And you have like cover letters that you're writing.
Okay.
We've got to talk a little bit about that.
That's going to be fun.
Ooh.
That is going to be very fun.
And that is actually something I was working on.
But really quick, these are all the recruiter emails that I have.
Love it.
Okay.
Let's go back to your GrokBots.
So you have a bot here who's helping you find recruiters to contact.
That's awesome.
Walk us through some of the other ones you have here.
Is it an alumni database email finder?
Yes.
Okay.
I really hope Stanford University is not watching this.
Really hope not.
They might be.
Also, if there's any sensitive data, we don't have to show that for me.
Oh, no, no, no.
It's not sensitive data.
At least not shown here.
What this does is we have...
Every university has like alumni database at the end of the day, or a majority of them do.
And they all have information about which alumni are working where.
And for example, I'm interested in like software engineering positions.
So I'm looking into the alumni database and see who's working at Google, Microsoft, SpaceX AI, et cetera, et cetera.
Then I search them up.
So this bot, what it does is it searches up a bunch of people, runs it through the alumni database.
That alumni database hands me back the email.
And then it copies that, puts it into a CSV as per usual.
And then eventually what I'm going to do with the combination of both the recruiter finder and also the alumni database email finder is use that and then connect it with the Outlook MCP to just start sending out emails to these recruiters and alumni asking for coffee chats or asking for a way to understand the recruiting process.
Right.
Getting any information or any tips.
All of those things are going to be really important during the job search.
And that is something I'm planning on doing.
Okay.
So this is...
I'm curious, like how...
So you mentioned that there's like a database backing this.
How did you connect GrokBot to that source of data?
Is this like a connector you built yourself?
Did you feed us some CSVs?
Like what does the process look like to kind of bring some of that context into the bot?
Yeah.
So I think the biggest thing is that there's actually no connectors.
It's actually really non-technical in that sense.
I can honestly show you the screen if that's okay.
Yeah.
Let's not show any sensitive information.
Oh, there's no sensitive information.
I'm blogging it.
Cool.
But this is the alumni directory.
It...
All it does is it just controls this web and it just searches up every different name, every different profession, whatever, whatever, companies.
And then it finds all that information.
There's no connectors.
Honestly, all you need to do with your GrokBot is just give it access to whatever directory you want.
And then also eventually give it access to your email that connects your GrokBot to your student email.
And then just start sending out emails.
It's actually very straightforward.
There's not many connectors involved with this.
Cool.
Yeah.
I really like that.
And it's a great example, I think, of how GrokBot can kind of give you its own...
Has its own computer, right?
Yeah.
To go get work done for you.
And it sounds like in this case, you're just driving GrokBot through computer use and having it just kind of navigate these various services for you.
Obviously, something that we've seen a ton of great use cases around over the last day or two.
Yeah.
I'm curious.
We earlier saw a little flash in your finder window of cover letters.
Yes.
And so maybe tell us a little bit about your cover letter writer.
Because we talked a lot about how this is a marketing and sales game.
Yeah.
So how are you marketing yourself and how you write these cover letters?
So that's actually a great question.
This is actually something I was working on five minutes ago, actually.
So...
Slacking off while entering for us, I guess.
That's okay.
I'm sorry.
It was my downtime.
It was my coffee break.
Your coffee break.
Yeah.
I have two bots that actually work with cover letters.
One thing I've noticed with all the jobs that I've been applying for is you need two things.
You need a resume.
Obviously, a tailored resume with the keywords or whatever stacks you need to implement based
on the job description or the JD.
I will say JD a lot, so that just means job description.
Yeah.
Second thing will be the cover letter, which I think is the harder way to actually autonomize
in that sense.
Because cover letters are really personal.
It describes not only the job and what you've done, but also needs to connect what you've done
to the job.
Include your personal experience.
Include your voice at the end of the day.
And I think that is something that you just need to work on a lot in order to make that possible.
So what I have here is a set of two bots.
First is the cover letter writer.
This is actually a new bot that I created less than like 10 minutes ago.
What this does is it takes my resume.
It takes in all of the different stories that I've written within this bot saying,
"Oh, I worked this internship at Stanford Medicine.
Here are all the stories that relate to what I actually worked on, right?
Here's what I worked on for my project.
This is what I worked on for my game, right?
And these are all the stories."
And then it has all of that information.
It also has my resume, obviously.
Then what it does is there's another bot that's like the Swede Job Applier, which focuses on finding all of the jobs out there.
GitHub repositories, Greenhouse.
I forgot what it's called.
Ashby.
Yeah, Ashby.
Exactly.
Goes through all of that.
Finds as many jobs as possible.
Scans through the JD.
Sends it to the cover letter writer.
Then it will take that information, do a little bit of deep research if it needs to about company values or whatnot.
Then it sends it through a pipeline, which is just a cover letter creator repo that I personally made.
Oh, cool.
As you mentioned before, off-air, you saw cloud agents running.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So this is all the different cloud agents that were running before.
Okay.
If I scroll up right over here.
What does that repo do?
We can get your screen back on there in a second.
Yeah, but what does that repo do?
So you said you wrote some code with the cloud agent.
Is this sort of generating a PDF with the cover letters?
Yeah.
That's exactly it.
That's cool.
So it generates the entire cover letter and it sends it back to the sweet job applier.
The other thing that I wanted to work on because at the end of the day cover letters, as I mentioned before, are really nuanced and they need to be perfectly crafted.
I created an actual guard rail in that sense, like a cover letter critic, which looks at the cover letters and is like, hmm, this doesn't sound like you.
Yeah.
I don't like how it's saying, and this is what I want to work on, which sounds so inspirationally useless.
So that is something that I have right now, which is essentially like a guard rail at the end of the day, whether it's in cover letter generation or in actual code bases, you need to have something that's writing the code, something that's actually thoroughly testing it and sanity checking it.
Yeah.
So those are the two bots I have for the cover letter generation.
This repo also creates the resume.
However, I don't worry too much about the resume just because, and this is also a tip that I would give to everyone who's applying to jobs.
Do not fake your resume.
You will have experiences.
You have stuff that you can work on or you've already worked on.
Don't fake experience because when you get that first interview, which I have multiple times, if you fake anything, you are not going to get through.
Yeah.
So not lying.
I think it's a good idea.
Yeah.
Honestly.
Honestly is good.
Yeah.
So it sounds like you have this cover letter.
I love the bot interaction you just described.
So you have a cover letter generator.
And then how did you train that cover letter critic?
So it knows stuff about you.
Clearly, there's also a resume that hangs out in the generator.
So did you prompt this critic in a way where it kind of learns more about the actual things you've worked on?
What does the review process look like when one of these bots talks to the other and it's like, hey, critique my work?
Yeah.
Well, that's awesome.
So the way that works and the way it was actually trained is I personally was just sitting there.
It generated a cover letter.
I would look at the different feedback and the different use cases that are the patterns that I just knew that were embedded within this repo that wasn't resonating with the way I actually write.
An example that I was actually fixing just now is that it would write very short, very useless sentences.
An example would be like AI slop, but like the most motivational AI slop.
Interesting.
Right.
It would be like, and I want to do this.
I want to work on agents.
And then I, myself, I was thinking, yeah, what agents?
Why?
What are you working on?
A harness model?
Specificity.
Yeah, specificity.
You want to be able to tune it to be a little more real.
Exactly.
So I noticed that my writing style and I also looked through all my different papers that I've written.
I also gave it all the papers that I've written in like pre-2022, like before AI slop became a thing.
Right.
So what happened was it noticed the pattern of like, I like to use compound complex sentences, maybe a little bit of gerund usage as well.
So it includes that into the cover letter.
I also, I personally like to write very enthusiastically in all of my messages, right?
Whether it's in DMs, cover letters, or just professional messages I send on Slack.
So it also mentioned that.
So in total, my cover letter critic looks at the four different paragraphs.
First is the beginning paragraph.
It checks whether you mentioned the role, you mentioned why you want to work on the role and how your experience, how, what you want to take away from this role.
Like, what do you actually want to work on and why?
Yeah.
Second cover letter.
One experience focusing on what you did.
Does it actually use the experience from my experiences.md.
Does it use all that information?
And does it connect back to the job?
Yeah.
Second or the third paragraph.
Same thing.
Another experience and explaining why.
How does it connect back to the job and whether it's impactful.
Third and then third care, fourth paragraph, sorry.
Fourth paragraph focuses on going back, summing up the work that I did for these two, like the last two paragraphs very briefly, and then describing this is the impact I want to make on this company.
I want to build X, Y, and Z. An example would be like, I want to build agent evaluations to ensure that research production is done properly or something like that.
Yeah.
But obviously with a lot more specification based on the job description.
Like, tailoring it to the actual role and all that.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It does link, going back to what you were saying earlier, to how you just do prospecting if you're in sales and thinking about like, you know, making a compelling pitch for your product, in this case yourself.
What I particularly like about this is something we were talking about earlier is like, you can really train these bots and they sort of, you know, grow in their memory over time.
Right?
Yeah.
And I think we've seen a couple of examples of that.
Lauren just has really driven this home to me.
Like, every time I talk to her, I'm reminded that it's like, as long as actually really all you need to prompt well is like attention to detail and just being extremely conscientious.
And so as soon as you see an agent do something that you don't like, you just say, why did it do that thing?
Help me understand like at the root cause of what that thing is.
And then I'm going to make a one line sentence in the like skill that the agent loads to make sure it doesn't do that thing.
And it's like, if you do that over and over and over, you actually get agents that like compound and get better over time versus like, oh, like, I don't really like that.
I'll just fix it.
And I'm not going to tell the agent what to do better.
And then you kind of lose, you lose that, you know, you have to save these things off.
Yeah.
You lose the feedback loop.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And then one other thing I was going to say is just, aside from sales, right, there are other connections, which I liked how you, you know, you described how you're using these agents to tell your like experience or these stories that you have from your professional career.
And I think, you know, having a job, one of the hardest things for me is to remember, like, this is going to sound a little silly, but when you're doing a lot of things like what you actually did in a given day.
Yeah.
For me, it's so easy.
I have an agent that every day and every week, like, looks at Slack, Notion, like, actually, you can cover pretty much all the services you work in as a knowledge worker, GitHub, right?
Just, like, look at my PRs, look at what I sent in Slack, look at what I posted on Twitter because I make content and then summarize that and then write it into bullet points for me each day.
That rolls up over weeks and, like, all of a sudden you just have a log of everything that you've done and you can more clearly speak to, oh, hey, I'm going to stand up.
Here's what I'm working on.
Like, my brain is, like, more focused.
Yeah.
I use that kind of thing all the time, too, where it's like, just help me maintain this sort of self-evolving knowledge base of the stuff that I'm doing.
And so, you know, I feel like when we're writing a lot of code, we do this in the code base.
And Lauren actually talked a little bit yesterday on the stream about how code bases are the best example of memory because they sort of have this history over the course of, you know, git commits and all this that kind of persist memory for how code evolves over time.
And I think there's actually an equivalent for this for knowledge work that we're kind of talking about where you can train a bot on sort of things that you've been doing and kind of, you know, build it over time so that it has its own sense of memory.
Of course, the bots have their own memory, but, like, kind of helping steer it based on the inputs that you're creating, the outputs you're creating each day, making that part of your process, I think.
It sounds like you've implemented a lot of those, a lot of those things.
Yeah.
Very cool.
Cool.
Go ahead.
I was just going to say, maybe we could do some work with our intern here.
Yeah.
Rather than talking about him applying to other jobs.
Like, what's the deal?
Let's do it.
No, I'm just kidding.
Yeah.
So maybe we could start talking through, like, one thing we haven't really covered in our sort of game studio is, like, the go-to-market motion.
So I think we need to think through, like, ops, you know, sales, like, basically, like, everything from marketing to, like, getting the message out there.
If we wanted to run some, like, creative ads.
We have all the code, so maybe there's some ways we could, like, create ads that are, like, on-brand or something.
But I don't know.
Maybe you can bring some fresh perspective to the situation.
Yeah.
What do you think makes a game viral?
I was...
Are you a big game?
Do you play games?
I play a lot of games.
Okay.
Whether it's, like, sandbox games like Minecraft.
Yeah.
Love Minecraft.
Daily puzzle games like Wordle or my own.
Okay.
So a lot of those are pretty viral.
Like, the puzzle games are all over the place.
Yeah.
I think the two biggest things for virality is word of mouth, which obviously it's very obvious because once you have enough people playing it, right, your friends tell you and then you eventually tell your other friends and then that becomes a big thing.
I think the second thing is just continuously and constantly posting about it.
I think eventually when you just see enough content about, like, this somewhat interesting game, right, people try it out, right, maybe the conversion rate is hopefully 10%, right?
Yeah.
It'll probably be much less.
But if you get one viral post, a lot of people play it, right, then you start to develop that, like, community and foundation, which then starts to expand kind of like a ripple effect.
And that, at least to me, seems like the way that games are usually made viral.
But there's also, like, other perspectives just as, like, paying for ads or, like, having it on commercials or something like that.
I guess, like, for the friends of yours that you're playing games with and kind of when you think about what catches your eye these days, like, is this Instagram ads?
Is it, you know, like, great posts on X?
Is it TikTok?
Is it something else?
Like, if let's say we were to go and build out some ads, like, where should we think about that?
How should we think about that?
Like, where do you find and how do you discover new products?
I think I would discover new products.
I wouldn't recommend Instagram.
I just think Instagram has a different niche for game development.
Like, instead of, like, games, it's just mostly, like, random reels or other random stuff.
Yeah.
I think the best places would probably be X.
I know there's a lot of, like, engineers or just, like, I forgot the exact term, but it's, like, early adopters who are going to be, like,
trying out the game and seeing what's up.
I think a second thing, and this is something I was also looking into, is posting on, like, random Reddit channels.
Like, maybe not the huge ones.
Like, for example, I was looking into daily puzzle games.
Maybe not that one, but, like, just, like, the niche channels that don't get a lot of love, a lot of attention, but there's a lot of people there.
Right?
Tell them to try out your game.
You're not necessarily publicizing it.
You're trying to get feedback, which then inevitably gets you more people to actually play the game.
Yeah.
Another thing would probably be, I mentioned X posts.
Probably, like, LinkedIn posts or even TikTok.
I would just make sure that for TikTok, it's just, like, really engaging.
Like, the first two to three seconds are key for any virality.
At least that's what I've heard of.
Yeah.
I don't know if they were viral.
So even if we're taking a step back, it sounds like you're talking about, like, motion or other assets that could engage the user.
Yeah.
That could be fun maybe to try out, like, in our own repo.
So something that I like to do, I make a lot of videos, for those that don't know.
And almost all of my videos are, like, me doing demos or, like, talking to the user.
So there isn't a ton of, like, generative content.
But what I think might go misunderstood sometimes is that you don't necessarily need to generate, like, videos using, like, an image generation model or a video generation model, rather.
Though XAI, you know, you can do some of these things.
Yeah.
What I like to do is, especially if you have code, you can use code as the source of truth.
So a lot of times you can add in nice elements if you, say, use a library like Remotion.
So what I'm thinking is, what if we send through some prompts to try and generate Remotion assets that we can then run as ads for our game.
I really like that.
We have, like, a design system kind of locked, too.
So maybe we could just build on some of those.
Should we get your screen up on the screen?
We can get my screen up, and I can walk you through what I'm thinking here.
Let's do it.
Coming up momentarily.
So generally when I'm doing this, what I'm going for is, like, okay, what you want in a platform is you want, like, aspect ratios that work for the platform.
So I was going to run, like, Twitter.
I've done some funny stuff on Twitter.
You can actually, like, I mean, maybe this is something we do at another point, but you can do, like, clever aspect ratios and, like, basically stretch things out on screen.
Yeah.
But a good starting place is, like, one-to-one aspect ratio.
For those of us who are not running ads or are messing around with aspect ratios, that's just the square.
So you can run, basically, square, portrait, or landscape aspect ratio advertisements, and different ads work for different platforms.
We're getting, there's a fly.
There's a fly flying around here.
There's a fly on set.
And it doesn't want me making ads.
So basically what I said is, hey, use re-motion for x ads with one-to-one aspect ratios and the current, like, scratch assets.
Those are just kind of, like, where the assets are located.
We could even use some, like, light motion across, for all platforms, prioritizing the hero on the land.
This is kind of like a rushed prompt.
But our chief of staff bot is using Dr. Eggbot to then onboarding a re-motion ads bot for a cupcake.
And so we should see that created and then spun up as a cursor cloud agent just based on how we like to do things.
So that's, like, the typical flow, right, with our sort of chief of staff bot.
Even though I just talked to Matt Berman about how I don't like to call my bots chief of staff.
We actually have the-- we're going to--
We should rename him.
Steve.
I don't know if you've seen Dr. Eggbot, but we've been using Dr. Eggbot a lot that helps you stand up with bots and has a lot of great context on how to make great bots and rockbots.
So kind of a meta bot, but it's been really fun to play with us this week.
So you use pstack, right?
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
Lauren is actually a legend.
Like, I just keep saying that.
Like, I was talking to Matthew Berman.
He's like, is that Lauren who just walked by there?
I was like, yeah.
He's like, dude, I see her all over Twitter.
That's amazing.
So what I'm noticing here is my-- Steve noticed that there was a Remotion plugin.
Oh, nice.
Which was cool because it installed Remotion skills, and that should ideally guarantee better outputs.
And some of these are the things, like, I just forget sometimes.
Like, on a new project to add the skills.
It really helps the agent behavior a ton, right?
It's like someone else has done the work to kind of make it-- make agents really good at working with a particular tool.
It's like, yeah, just install the plugin, install the skills, and they can really, you know, work a lot better.
Sweet.
Yeah.
So we got the Remotion plugin installed, and then I'd imagine it's just going to spin up an agent.
We'll start working on some Remotion assets.
Because Remotion leverages code, it's actually perfect.
If you look at, like, cursor, like our, you know, if we look at, like, the files that we're actually working with here in this sort of scratch repository, or in a repository that has scratch files.
It's in the scratch directory, the game loop.
It's just the HTML file, which is fine because, you know, you can do a lot of stuff with HTML.
And most of this is, like, there's some CSS in here.
Remotion uses, I believe, just TypeScript or React, rather.
I might be wrong about that.
Don't quote me.
But we should be able to translate, like, this CSS pretty well to get, like, on-brand assets.
So it'll be interesting to see what we get.
Maybe this will run for a couple minutes, and we'll have something to show.
Yeah.
Tim, maybe we should come up, yeah, come up with a couple of ads, a couple of cool ad stacks.
It looks like we got the plugin going there.
Yep.
You know, off-screen, while that's working, we're also talking about, you know, just how the job search is going and any questions you might have for us just while we're all hanging out together and so curious.
Like, yeah, what's up in line for you?
Yeah, I think I got, like, the first part of the interview rounds gotten.
That sounds like submitting the actual job application is done.
And then I think my question, and this is, like, very pertinent for me, is there's the final round of interviews for a lot of big companies, right?
You obviously go through, like, a technical screening with the recruiter, technical screening itself with, like, a senior engineer, and then going through a problem, AI or the code or whatever.
Then finally, you have, like, the final day, which is, like, three back-to-back interviews.
Yeah.
Right.
And I'm curious, like, A, how do you keep up the stamina to make sure that you, like, answer all those questions properly?
And second, like, what would you recommend as, like, general advice?
Obviously, off-air, I will ask him how to get an internship at SpaceX AI as, like, other than picking up coffee.
But in general, do you have any advice?
Yeah.
I mean, I'm curious to get Matt's take on this, too.
You know, I think it comes down to a few things.
I think a lot of it is what you mentioned, like, you have to demonstrate technical aptitude.
And so they're sort of, like, you can't get around that.
You have to be sort of qualified for the role you're applying for, whether this is software engineering role, as you called out, or product role, developer engineering, or, you know, like, any other role.
I go to marketing all these, there's, like, a technical aptitude that's sort of needed to kind of, you know, prove that you can do the work.
And I think, ultimately, one thing that I think some people sometimes forget when applying to jobs is that, you know, for employers who are hiring, job searching is a long process.
Like, it takes investment.
It takes investment from, like, the best people on your team to spend time interviewing.
And so, you know, one of the things that I've always told myself, and maybe this is just because I'm an optimist and I like to think of the world as half, the glass is half full.
But, you know, most of the time when people are bringing you in for an interview, they want you to succeed.
And so, really, I think just shifting your mindset to say, you know, hey, like, if you can truly, you know, if it all works out, you know, you're helping this team bring in someone who they really need to get something done.
So I'd say, like, to me, that a large part of it's the mindset shift.
A large part of it's obviously the technical aptitude.
And then to your point on the stamina and just keeping up with it, I think it's really figuring out what systems work for you.
Like the way that you get energized about something, the way you can bring that energy into the people you work with.
I think a lot of work is also person to person interaction.
Like as much as we're hanging out with our bots and like, you know, bringing bots in to help us with our work and chatting with our bots all the time.
A large part of what makes a great team is the people that form it up.
And so, just like, you know, making yourself kind of showing to that team that you're interviewing with that, like, you can be a really exciting part of that team.
And I think those three things really make a big difference.
I don't know, Matt, what would you say?
I mean, I guess the thing about it a little bit differently, which is that, I mean, it's tough for a first job.
Because it's kind of like, well, you might not know anybody.
You might be in a new city where you don't have any, you know, any connections or whatever.
And even if it's like, if we take a step back and you're talking about like your first internship, that's really hard, right?
But once you start to establish like a professional network and, you know, it's actually, it's shocking to me.
You don't, today, you don't even need to do that.
You can just make cool stuff and put it on the internet.
Huge advocate of making stuff and putting it on the internet, much like the stream.
And it's actually a free way to make friends who are also passionate about the things that you're passionate about.
And I really think about, you know, a career as finding something that you love to do and you love to work with people who also love to do the same thing.
And so if you think about it less like a job and more like, how do I just have a good time and create stuff that people want, right?
Then it becomes less like, oh, I'm going to like, by the way, what you're doing isn't wrong, obviously.
Like resumes and cover letters, this is a very valid approach to getting a job.
This is how I got most of the jobs in my career.
But there's this alternate way that I think is like very much embodied in like the open source ethos, which is just like I'm going to spend my time doing my free time doing things I like for free.
And if you do things you like for free, whether that's making videos or tutorials, writing code, creating stuff, making art, just talking to people, you just bump in, you just end up in the right sphere.
So this is like a very like sort of one people might even call it like backwards or like an unintuitive way of getting a job.
But through that, you usually find people who are passionate.
And if you're passionate, which I can tell by talking to you are, then it's like, OK, I want this person.
Like, I want this guy working for me because he's like, I see you with using GrokBot.
I'm like, there are not that many people that know how to do this.
Like, right.
Let's use GrokBot, you know.
Right. Yeah, I think it's totally right.
And I think, you know, what it just made me think of is that it's it's sort of like passion, but also, you know, like demonstrating the things that you're creative and passionate about and like opening up to a pretty broad audience.
Right. And like for some people, that's not like engineering.
Right. For some people, that's like creative physical projects like we had some guests on earlier today, kind of walking through how they are like, you know, have a real passion for a particular problem that they're solving in some way and just being able to talk about that.
I think you're actually right that, you know, sort of always been the case that like building a public profile and and kind of, you know, putting yourself out there really helps.
But I think even now more than ever, sort of like the the the distance between an idea and then seeing that idea come to life has gotten a lot smaller.
And so being able to, you know, take advantage of that in the current marketplace and like there are tokens of problems and see what you can come up with.
I think that's that probably makes a lot of sense.
Yeah. Yeah.
I definitely resonate with both of you guys' advice.
I think for your point, I always think of it as like it's like a very antagonistic, like the whoever is interviewing me is like my antagonist and approaching like a problem.
But I like your approach.
It's like you've already in that sense, like you've already gotten the job.
Now you just got approved that you got the job.
Right. And that you're like good enough.
Right.
Like you're starting from 100 and then now you can like slowly go down.
Whereas you're starting from zero and then you got approved by going all the way up the mountain.
Totally.
And I think that's like a good way to look at it.
And then also with your point.
I love that.
I think personally, like I don't post a lot on like X or LinkedIn.
And part of the reason is because I'm like a little bit scared.
Like what do people think about what I'm working on or do they think of them.
But then I like I started like building more stuff over the summer.
I started like talking to my friends and like realizing there's such a supportive community out there, whether it's like with your friends or like strangers on the Internet.
Yeah.
Regardless.
And I think even if there's like 1% of population who might be like saying, oh, what are you doing guy?
Like, what are you doing?
Like there's going to be 99% who are just to be very clear for the first.
I mean, people still think that of the content that I create.
But it was especially true when I first started creating content.
And I think anybody that has ever made anything and put it on the Internet would say exactly the same thing.
So definitely.
I mean, you have to do that.
Yeah.
That's like putting yourself out there part.
It is the hard part.
Be willing to suffer the criticism, but also be willing to establish yourself.
And yeah, I think it is a lot easier said than done.
But once you can get past those hurdles, like I'm notoriously bad at this.
Matt inspires me every day when I see the cool stuff he cooks up and I'm like, whoa, like where does the idea come from and how do you package it up?
And so, yeah, I think it's also cool, like follow those inspirations.
I think that's also a really great way to like learn how to do this work is, you know, finding people who you think are doing the best versions of this in whatever niche you work in.
Like maybe that's software engineering.
Maybe that's, you know, like craft making, whatever it is.
And kind of just like seeing how some of the best in the game do their work and, you know, seeing what you can learn from that.
I think even nowadays, like, yeah, put all that stuff in a grot spot that teaches you how to do this work.
I think that there's a lot of like tools now that make that even easier.
So I know we've been yapping a little bit, but Matt, I see some cool stuff on your screen.
Yeah, so I wanted to just show you an existing project just so that you could understand this workflow maybe a little bit better.
So one thing that I did, one of the first things I did when I started working on GrokBot, like we have an awesome design team and they have really great assets.
So I was like, well, what if I could take like our motion assets and translate those into re-motion?
So like I have basically re-motion assets that looks like we might be getting that express basically like GrokBot as code here.
And so we can then generate videos from those assets.
So like a spawn animation.
And then I can use those as overlays in the videos that I create.
So this is like generally the workflow.
If you have the code, if you have a very on top of it design team, like the SpaceX AI design team, shout out all the amazing designers.
Specifically, you know, shout out Kenny, shout out Justin.
The man helped out with this entire production.
Amazing, yeah.
And you can do really cool stuff.
And so like what I'm trying to replicate is this exact workflow, right?
Like, okay, take a look at main, right?
Essentially what I want is it to use the re-motion skills.
I want it to like fetch the card stack.
And it's like working through.
You can see some of the logic here.
And it wrote 6,000 lines of re-motion code.
Just to be clear, like animations like this are very code heavy.
So like this is kind of to be expected.
But we can kind of see what's going on here.
Where did it write?
Where did it write this stuff?
We can actually probably just look at the changes.
12 files change.
Oh, my God.
Apps, ads.
All right, cool.
So we'll go into the terminal.
So for those watching along, what Matt's doing here is he has a remote agent.
He's kind of interacting with the agent via the agent's command line,
via the terminal that he pulled up, and also looking at the files the agent generated.
So that was kind of what we just saw happen in real time here.
And it looks like we're making sure that things are installed.
Yep.
The sort of harness that's running that re-motion app is running correctly.
Okay.
This is stale.
So I'm going to have to clear the cache because I just had that.
Pretty sure it's because I had--
Oh, it's conflicting with the local host from the other app.
So I'm going to come over here.
Give me one second.
This is the fun of demoing.
Yeah.
I guess while Matt's continuing to pull it up, I guess Shredul, what else has been top of mind for you?
I mean, you've been kind of seeing the stream hopefully a little bit the past few days.
Yeah.
Like seeing our game idea.
I'm just curious, based on what you've seen so far, what do you think?
I think, first of all, there's like-- like you mentioned before, this idea of like-- from idea to actual execution is like so-- it's become so much smaller now because of like the use of agents and especially with GrokBot and then also with Cursor and any like agentic coding tool.
I also-- when I was watching the stream, like I saw like Dr. Eggbot and then I remember it again.
I remember actually-- so I visited the SpaceX office a few weeks ago and then Matt was actually-- I asked Matt like what are some of the stacks you guys use or like what are some of the skills?
So he mentioned Pstack and I-- like I downloaded it but I like completely forgot like-- and then after watching the stream and I saw Dr. Eggbot, I went back into it.
And now whenever I'm coding with Cursor, I always use Slashbro for pretty much everything.
It's amazing.
And then I guess the other thing I'm learning is like software development has gone a lot more quick in that sense, but it also means you have to pivot fast.
Like it goes back to that like sales aspect where if an idea is just like-- maybe an idea is like not working or maybe it's like too difficult, you should be able to pivot very quickly.
And I think when it comes to like your guys' livestream or like the SpaceX AI team in general or like any other like promising like startup-- like startup slash company that's working on agents or AI and production, all of that, right?
If you can't pivot, then you will like fall behind in that sense.
So it's like really cool how we're seeing that pivot and like all of those changes working really in the livestream, right?
Which is just awesome to see.
Yeah, that's a really optimistic way of explaining our last 48 hours here and kind of going through the first day and then going through the pivot.
So I appreciate that take.
I also think to your point, like there's some really cool things you can do with Pstack and, you know, tools like this where you can actually now just like swarm agents on helping you generate and test multiple ideas in parallel.
So actually for those who weren't watching earlier, one of the ways that we kicked off our prototyping this morning was we spun up a swarm of agents using Pstack using different models and some, you know, different models obviously have different tastes.
Yeah.
Kind of seeing how those tastes would come together and then kind of going through a couple of those options live.
So if you want to go back and see how we did some of that, you can rewind back to the stream and catch some of the earlier content.
But we kind of went through that process a little bit iteratively.
So actually, again, to your point, you can just spin up sub-agents, have them go figure things out and kind of quickly see all those prototypes really, really quickly.
So, yeah.
Cool.
Do we ever get re-motion back up?
Yeah, there was just some, like, basically I was using an agent to debug this.
It removed, like, a file and then broke the wiring.
So I was just using, basically, for me, it's usually easier to have Cursor sort of debug this situation.
The nice thing about using the browser here is that I get access to the console.
So, you know, the agent is able to kind of see the errors and the connections and start to debug these things.
But we should have something working shortly.
I think we might have, I don't know, do we have anything else to talk about?
Where are we at?
Well, so maybe to bring it back to the game, we were just talking about that a little bit.
So right before we started this segment, I worked on finishing up our prototype and started getting the prototype wired.
We started with some basic HTML, so just like Matt was talking about, we have a lot of, like, a couple thousand lines of HTML and CSS embedded.
That kind of was our initial prototype.
It's really snappy.
It turns out modern browsers are pretty good at rendering of an HTML.
But one of the things that Laura and I were talking about right off camera was, let's go ahead and start converting this into a React app.
So actually, this entire time that we've been working, I've had an agent, you know, working on converting our, you know, prototype into a React app
that we can then wire into the backend implementation that Lauren's been working on.
So I'm pretty excited about that.
It's like starting from a really strong prototype, kind of turning it into a proper front-end client app, separating the client code from the server code.
Nice.
So we can evolve the client separately and kind of be able to do it on.
I think it'll be really cool.
Sweet.
And it looks like maybe we'll have some cool graphics to go with it.
Yeah, so we got this kind of lined up a little bit more.
And you can kind of see here on the right, the cool thing, several cool things, as a matter of fact.
So nice thing about Remotion is that, again, it's all just code.
So what we did was we kind of pulled in that hero asset that we were working with a little bit earlier.
And I like this idea of like code as the source of truth, especially in content and in the creative assets.
Because if Lauren is back there, like, I don't know, she probably like rebuilt the entire app by now and the assets look different, I can just pull those assets through very quickly to this basically piece of content and I'm not losing anything.
Now, don't get me wrong, there's a lot of stuff that's wrong here.
But because Remotion is just like react and stuff, you can see it's restarting my server.
I can even just use the design mode and just be like, get this out of there.
Right?
So like we can start to like clean some of this stuff up.
Like I don't want shadows or highlights on these.
Like generally, I just want them to be simpler.
I feel like it started adding details and I'd like more holistically make the card stack tighter.
So again, we've talked about design mode and cursor a little bit.
I love the like how tight the loop can be.
And I can just kind of spam specifically models like four, six high.
I mean, could be low, honestly, if we're just trying to move fast, but I can spam fast mode and it'll just kind of like iterate on those things in real time.
And I get this asset where essentially this is a video.
And once I get this square video that looks the way I like it, I can then just generate like portrait assets.
I can generate really whatever I want.
And while a bit, you know, are you going to run an ad on this?
Like probably not.
We shouldn't be running ads on this.
But if you're someone who has access to these assets and this took us five minutes, it's not like hard to see how we could then, you know, build out this flow where in GrokBot we're just generating different kinds of re-motion ads.
Right.
Yeah.
I think it's also hints at like a really cool way to use agents.
I think for motion is just like magic.
It's like such a magical tool.
But I think the reason it's so magical with agents is that it speaks code.
Right.
So it takes this like what you, you know, what is still really a laborious process to animate and like, you know, go into After Effects.
And there are people who are like really, really good at this work.
But it provides a coding interface on top of it.
And every time I see someone use a motion, I'm always a little bit blown away with an agent.
And it always sort of reminds me that like you sort of like got to play to the agent's strengths sometimes too, right?
Like you earlier were talking about PDF formatting and text formatting.
Like obviously agents are really good at text.
So you can kind of lean into that to get some real leverage out of them.
I think similarly, like agents are really good at code.
Like we've been talking this entire time about how, you know, like coding is cheap and it's really easy to produce code.
If you can take the act of creating graphics and motion graphics and make that, like put a code, put a code interface in front of that.
I think you're sort of like speaking the agent's language in some ways.
And so, you know, one sort of pro tip for folks who are watching and following along is, you know, think of the tools that you're using and how you could try to, you know, make code, make them more code enabled or build sort of harnesses that involve programming on top of them.
And I think that actually helps your agents go a lot further, both in terms of what they can do, but also just in terms of like tokens they burn and the efficiency and all that kind of stuff too.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
And I mean, I have this like grand vision where everything is code.
Like in docs, you don't have screenshots.
You just have code.
Yeah.
The XAI and the cursor teams are already pretty good about this, but you could imagine we change the component in the product and it just flows through to our documentation and our content.
That would make me happy.
Oh, man.
Amazing.
So we got some ads cooking.
We do.
I feel like we made some progress there.
I love it.
Shardul.
Thanks for joining us.
This has been awesome.
Really appreciate you kind of hanging out with us.
Are you on X if people want to find you afterwards?
Yeah.
I'm on X at Shardul Marate.
I think all lowercase.
Nice.
All right.
We're doing actually before you get out of here.
Shard.
Oh, S.
Sorry.
I'm S-H-A-R-D-U-L, right?
Yeah.
M-A-R-A-T-H-E.
A-T-H-E.
All right.
This is for anyone who's a recruiter who's watching.
Shardul is awesome.
He gets to the follow, by the way.
He gets to the follow.
And then we're going to do a quick profile breakdown.
Oh.
You know, this is actually, I'm surprised we made it this far on the stream without breaking down X profile.
Notice how locked in Shardul is here.
Like, I just want you all to see.
My man is like, we're going to, I'm going to, we're going to clean shot.
And then we're going to edit this.
The gaze, gaze is directly at the computer.
Like we get arrow, eyes.
Oh, yeah.
There's nothing.
There's none of this.
There's not looking this way.
My man both laser vision on the machine.
So that's, that's one.
We get a, we're not going to save this image.
Maybe for later.
We'll keep it on my desktop.
Um, so first one locked in check.
That's, that's a plus second.
This is a great headshot.
I feel like people.
He's just a little good looking guy.
Like a lot of people that, you know, they do like the, the, the, a non PFP situation.
I like that you're out here.
You're repping the name.
You're being just very out there with it.
A plus there.
We got the portfolio site.
We're going to do a quick portfolio.
All right.
I love my, I love you.
I will.
I'm so sorry.
We brought you on here.
And then I just started going through your stuff.
Hey, no, no.
I'm proud of my website.
I will say that.
It's a trap card.
There's some good stuff there though.
He's like leveraging that hero photo from before.
Yes.
Some clear speaking engagements.
Some more headshots.
Actually.
The glow.
Lauren.
We should take some inspiration.
Beautiful.
So many, so many stars.
Okay.
A plus portfolio site.
You should click on the projects.
See what animation.
Okay.
I don't know if we have enough time to go into all of this guys.
The production is telling us that I'm doing too much.
A plus Twitter profile.
You got the follow.
It was great to have you on.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
We're going to run a quick promo for those who haven't followed along yet.
We are giving away a chance to win a visit to Starbase, Texas.
So if we can cut to my screen for a minute, we'll show that very briefly on stream.
And then we will switch over to our next talk downstairs in the main theater.
So if we can get my screen up, please.
All right.
So Starbase, just share your best rock bot templates with us.
This QR code.
We can move our camera off of the screen for a second.
Be able to see the QR code hiding underneath.
There you go.
If you want to win a trip to Starbase, Texas to see a launch of Starship for you and a plus one,
you can scan this QR code to learn how to enter.
You just got to share your favorite rock bot templates with us.
And then we will have several runners up.
We'll win a trip to learn to see where some of the stuff is built that powers some of these incredible, incredible vehicles.
So be sure to enter this.
If you missed the QR code, when we flip it off here, you could just follow at grok on X.
And we have some instructions on some of the latest posts on that account too.
Share by September 29th.
And we'd love to see some really great templates.
With that, I think we're going to cut downstairs to the main stage for our next talk.
I'm Simon.
I'm here on SpaceX AI's go-to-market team, specifically in SDR.
And excited to talk about GrokBot, specifically for this team.
All right.
So at a high level, we'll be kind of going over what actually is GrokBot, why we use it internally.
And then kind of dive into some of the actual SDR use cases we use.
And then I'll kind of demo actually what my environment looks like.
And then we can kind of dive into some of the actual, like, SDR use cases we use.
And then we can kind of discuss that and go into a Q and A from there.
All right.
So first at a high level, I wanted to kind of discuss the actual AI maturity curve and what
this looks like for SDRs.
So starting out, when I was using AI, I was just prompting back and back and forth.
And I wanted to kind of dive into the actual AI maturity curve and what this looks like for
SDRs.
So starting out, when I was using AI, I was just prompting back and forth with a chatbot.
I'd do typical things.
Like, I'd ask, can you help me actually draft this email or kind of perfect this copy or do this
account research for this specific account I'm looking at.
And what we've seen kind of progress over the last year is first the idea of co-pilots.
And so co-pilots are AI that can actually go out and carry out a true task.
So instead of talking back and forth, getting email copy and then copying that into your Gmail,
it's something now that we see like actually having the AI go and basically hook up to a Gmail MCP or an API
and be able to actually send that email off for you.
And really with bot, what we believe is kind of the next frontier is actually automating entire jobs in full.
And so going beyond just a task and actually doing an end-to-end workflow.
And really with the staff function of actually combining a team of bots, you can see how kind of automating a job,
but also combining that with different features of business like talking to RevOps or talking to your AE and getting context on an account.
And how bots can actually pull in that context for you and really help you do that full process.
And so just diving into what Grockbot actually looks like if you haven't seen it before.
So you have all your bots kind of here on the left-hand side and they're doing different things.
Like we have a sales outbound bot here, we have our chief of staff, and you can message them just like you message your own teammates.
And more interestingly, you can actually see them talk with each other.
And I have my own Grockbot instance set up where really there's only one bot that I'm actually talking to.
And so for the most part, I've kind of offloaded all that context to my chief of staff actually talking with other bots and doing that all for me.
And I think some important things also to emphasize here is that bots keep their own context at a per bot level and memory,
so they can really improve as you work more with them.
And as you go, their memory gets better.
And this is why I really emphasize you actually should be training your bots as well,
depending on the task with kind of the relevant info.
So set up your Slack, set up your Gmail connector, and you can actually kind of start to train it on what your voice looks like.
And so specifically for Gmail, what I do is I've had it go into my Gmail and actually look at how do I actually talk to people.
And specifically in my outbound messages, how do I actually talk to people in a way where they actually want to respond,
and they're interested in kind of seeing a demo or something forward.
And so I'll really go into more of what that actually looks like,
how I place weights on certain things to actually help Grockbot understand this.
But I think a big thing I want to talk about also is the ability to share your bots.
And I'll dive into this more in the next slide.
But I think as SDRs, one of the most important things is being able to see what your teammates are actually doing
and to kind of easily transfer those skills over to your other SDRs.
So you can actually really scale those outputs and do it very quickly.
I think the truth, at least at SpaceX, of what we've seen is that what's working for us today was not working three months ago.
And three months before that, it was something entirely different.
And so the ability to really just move quickly and always be iterating is something that the ability to share bots is really going to help you with and help scale the entire SDR team.
So diving into this more, like why are we using Grockbot?
I think to start, it's as easy and as intuitive as just iMessage or another general platform.
You can just talk to your bots.
And I think more importantly, bots are always on.
And so you don't have to walk around with your laptop open anymore.
You can actually close it.
I can go on coffee walks and continue prompting from my phone.
Or I can set it up on a long running task and then trust that it will actually complete that task end to end and do the thing without me having to kind of object in between and guide it.
It really is the confidence to go carry out and do things.
And there's many ways you can actually improve that by recording your own screen and some other stuff that I'll show more in the demo.
But again, it also uses the tools just like you do.
And so you can think of your basic connectors of MCPs, of APIs, everything that you've already kind of set up.
But beyond that, what's really important is it actually owns its own VM.
And so you can log into the browser.
And for the parts of your SDR work that are a little more difficult or there's no real way to automate them, you can actually show bot in the browser.
You can sign in to those tools.
And you can actually show bot by recording your screen, recording you go through it.
You can show the exact workflows that you do in there.
The really tedious and specific stuff that's kind of hard to explain or maybe there's no real like open API for it.
And so this is really something that I found immense value in.
And what's given me the confidence to be able to say, okay, grok bot, you can genuinely go end to end with what you're doing here.
And as I talked about before, I think shareable templates are one of the most important things.
And I think every single team at a team level should basically all be spending time building their own templates, sharing those with the team, getting an understanding of, okay, what are the things that are actually working?
And how can I not only just import that template, but how can I import it and then add my own nuance onto that of whatever like my tonality and my messaging is, or actually maybe it's just I like to do my workflow a slightly different way, but actually kind of taking this as a base template and then working beyond that.
And you can also prompt grok bot directly and ask for direct improvements.
So you can import templates and be like, hey, look at this template my colleague shared with me.
What do you think are things with my own workflow that you think would be a good addition to build on top of this or to kind of get more value out of that.
And so I really emphasize just actually like talking back and forth with your grok bots and kind of like starting to really push it to help you.
And I think this is why we emphasize so heavily that grok bot is really just a multiplier for your own work and really a way to scale the outputs you're doing.
And as an SDR, I don't think there's anything more important than actually doing that.
All right, so diving into really what I see as the common SDR use cases or the things that like I'm doing on a day to day basis, I think number one, it's really prospecting.
And so if you're an early stage startup, you can actually even help have grok bot kind of help you understand your ICT.
And so you can look into things like, okay, for the AEs that have closed deals or have deals that have moved to stage one, what is the common kind of title that we're seeing actually carry those deals through?
Or what's kind of the most responsive title or industry or sub industry of person to take an original meeting?
How does that actually vary from economic buyer, the person who's actually signing off on this deal?
And so you can really have grok bot kind of from a first beginning actually understand like, what is my ICP?
What's the most optimal way to reach my goal?
And personally as an SDR for me, that's how many S1s can I get?
And so you can kind of reverse engineer from that point.
And grok bot can kind of help you actually get to that point.
And so on top of really just understanding that ICP within prospecting, you can do the full flow.
So you can use enrichment tools, set those up within grok bot.
You can also use web search to kind of find more specific data like job postings or any funding announcements from some of your target companies and really just bring this all in.
And I'll show how I can actually tie that into my next point, which is a sequencer.
And so really what I've done within my own grok bot instance is I build kind of an ongoing list of all my prospects.
And this lives as a CSV today, but really what I think is nuanced about this is you can have things like grok bot routines and automations, which are constantly updating this.
And I think something that's really been a big value add on the sense of sequencing is the fact that when I'm multi threading an account, my A might have a call with them and that might have happened yesterday.
And whatever the context from that call is is truly golden and it should shape my messaging for today.
And so what grok bot can do is it can actually take that context in just like a coworker would.
They can go, hey, your A spoke with this person yesterday.
Here's exactly what they mentioned.
They mentioned a real pain point is they have all these tools to choose from and they kind of just feel stressed out.
There's tool fatigue, there's AI fatigue, and really that should shape your messaging for that day going forward for that company.
And grok bot has that context and it can pull that in and help you actually tailor messages at a company level.
And maybe even in a call or recording, they mentioned, oh, you know what?
Like this is actually the exact thing that Simon on the AI team is investigating right now or looking into.
You should reach out to him.
But a lot of those things never actually get actioned on.
And so grok bot has the ability to actually really sequence and kind of do the full process of prospecting them,
adding them into the sequence just off of the actual context that meeting they had with your aid.
And I think that's something really nuanced that I haven't seen before.
And on that same note, you can also do very high level account research.
And so for PLG-led companies, you can look at all the internal data.
Okay, who are my power users?
Who's actually using this product?
And more than that, you can look at the external signals for all companies in whole.
So okay, who's fundraising?
Who has job postings?
And how does that kind of tailor the messaging based on our product?
You can also look at things internally.
Like, okay, how does this new product that we've launched actually change our outbounding message for a specific person in XYZ industry?
And really have grok bot kind of tailor those messaging to each and every company specific.
And that's actually diving into my last point as well, which is drafting copy and what that looks like.
And so what I really highly emphasize is you actually sync your email with grok bot just as kind of a starting point.
And really push grok bot to understand your tone.
And I think some of like the nuances that I've added on this, because it's very easy to just sync your email, but you have to kind of push it further.
And the first thing that I've done on that note is I said, listen, Luke, specifically at my email copy that I've sent out to external or third party companies that also match the Salesforce account.
Where I'm an assigned SDR.
And then from that point, what I actually am pushing it to do is also look at, okay, just look at any of the emails from that filtered list that actually got positive responses that didn't get negative responses.
And then I think the most important thing that I've done on top of that note is I've actually put a heavier weight on emails that recently have received positive responses.
And I think for a company like SpaceX, what we're always seeing is the product offerings always changing.
Like I said, what was working three months ago is completely different now and might not work today.
And so I pushed Grokbot to put a really heavy emphasis on the actual recent messages and to draft my copy more like that, but still kind of pull in inspiration from my older messaging to understand like kind of the human aspect of actually what I'm doing.
And so these are kind of the real SDR use cases that I've seen, but I'll show you more in my demo of kind of how we can expand much beyond this.
So at a high level I just wanted to first show what does my Grokbot team actually look like here.
And so what I've really been emphasizing is you should have a chief of staff.
And I think one of the most exhausting things for me is switching back and forth between my different bots.
I'm always kind of forgetting the context, especially if I'm kind of shuffling many, many things at once.
And so what I actually really recommend is you have a chief of staff and that should be the first bot that you set up.
And what you should actually do from that point is set up all your other bots through your chief of staff.
And the reason being is when you do it this way, your chief of staff just has context on exactly the purpose and the end goal of that bot.
And so as you kind of ask your chief of staff, so Simon bot here for me, to complete tasks, it understands the right bot to actually delegate that to.
And when needed, it's going to understand the context of multiple bots that it needs to delegate to or actually get to talk with each other.
And so I think this is really an important way to actually think from the beginning of how to set this up.
And just for my other bots here, you can see, so I've got Shakespeare here, who is really the one I've like very meticulously trained on my email writing skills.
And then I have web search, which obviously is just doing web research, but he actually works in parallel with my Simon soldier.
And I'll show you, I basically have an entire army of Simon soldiers, which I basically consider sub agents or sub bots that when web search wants to delegate a task across say 50 or 100 counts.
The scalable way to do that is actually creating sub bots that basically respond directly to web search.
And lastly, I have customer bot who does a few things, but really is just taking in all the context on the meetings I'm having understanding for deals that are moving to close one kind of what's the context?
What are the things that customers are really receptive to?
And you can also get really nuanced with this.
So I think something you can do is look in Salesforce and say, OK, I have an account that's in the FinTech vertical.
OK, let me understand. Let me talk with my customer bot or ask my chief of staff to actually talk to the customer bot and figure out, OK, what are the similar FinTech companies that are closed one in recent deals?
And why were they interested? What were the main pain points they had?
What were the main parts of a product that were actually relevant?
And then I'm going to take that context and I'm actually going to my chief of staff pass that off to Shakespeare to understand my email drafting and to push that in specifically for the FinTech companies we serve.
And so this is where I really pushed that you can have these all as kind of your entire staff working on different parts of your outbound to make it genuinely productive.
All right. So now let's dive into the demo and see actually what my setup looks like here.
So here we've got it at a high level. I'm very serious about my color coding as you can see here, but I promise I have a reason behind this.
And that's I really like to understand at a high level when my bots are talking to each other and especially because all my work is delegated from my actual chief of staff.
I need to understand who my chief of staff is talking to at a section level.
And so whenever I see the orange here, I know that my chief of staff is working on an actual research mission.
It's doing something around research. When I see that it's message Shakespeare here, I know that it's doing some sort of outbound copy drafting.
It's kind of starting to understand that. And the same here I've talked about my army here.
But when I see the green messages, I understand, OK, it's delegating account research.
It's splitting these up between sub bots. And you can actually see here I have an army huddle as well, which basically has my web search bot talking with all of the soldiers here and basically just ordering them around.
And the soldiers are just giving all the context they need. And so you can see I'm researching kind of this demo account fly low here.
But it's you can see how it's basically broken all this up. And so now. Oh, yeah. Yeah, for sure.
Good. All right. So now what I really want to show is actually how I'm enriching prospects, how I'm actually going and sequencing these people and also what my daily routines look like.
Because I think personally as an SDR, one of the most important things for me is waking up every morning and knowing very much what I'm actually going to work on for that day.
I think that's just having a sign task that you wake up to is extremely helpful to start with.
And so really what I've what I've done here on my routines on the side here.
So the number one most important thing for me is every day I want 50 new prospects.
And really, these prospects have their own kind of internal rankings that I've trained growth on.
And so typically how I break this up is I have five prospects that I need to action on first thing in the morning.
These are going to be the most relevant ones. So maybe it was someone who contacted sales, but nobody ever reached out to them.
Maybe it was someone who just downloaded some of our content that's extremely relevant to what they're doing and conversations we're already having with that account.
And basically, this is my first five people that I genuinely need to action on right away.
And what I have is you can actually set up Grockbot to things like your calendar.
So my chief of staff has access to my calendar and they can basically understand the context of, OK, this is the five things you need action on now.
You have a 15 minute block I can make for you during this time, maybe 9 a.m.
So you can actually just knock those out of the way.
Then you don't have any other meeting for the 45 others that I know you want to get to today.
I'll block off time at 1 p.m. So you can actually carry those out over another hour.
But really, my chief of staff has kind of started to understand how I actually like to kind of break up my time and what's most important and really how I've seen the most results here.
And so on the same basis, I have an inbox manager who does something very similar.
So I get slack messages that I wake up to every morning.
I'm added to meetings when I wake up every morning and I have external emails that I wake up to every morning.
And I really just need a simple way to actually understand which of these I should action on right away, which of these are most important.
And so with a similar system, this is actually just going and it's really just ranking these for me on ones to action on and what the order to actually do that is.
And so on this on the same basis as a PLG company, something that's really important to us is actually looking through all of our accounts for some of the signals.
So where are power users living? What are the products they're using?
What are the things they're actually using the products for that are most relevant?
And so I also have every single weekday and you can see all these are at 8 a.m.
I have all of my accounts basically getting scanned for any net new signal.
So who are the new people who actually signed up for our product?
Who are the new people who have reached out, downloaded content, like everything?
And I really like this because I think speed to lead is one of the most important things.
And so even if it's not the strongest signal, being fed that on a daily basis so you can actually just go in action on that while it's as warm as possible has led me to some of the most receptive responses I've gotten.
And so finishing out here, I have my sequencer and I think just an important nuance on my sequencer is that I also have a routine basically set on a sales force trigger.
So any time one of my accounts, the actual account status updates.
So maybe it's moving from stage zero to stage one.
This is basically a trigger that works in parallel with the sequence to un-sequence people when maybe the deal is moving forward and we don't need to outbound any more people.
And so this is really a way you can kind of set up these kind of elaborate systems all just with routines and with GrokBot itself.
But I'm going to dive in now to what my actual sequencer looks like here.
And so here's kind of what it looks like.
I've spun up this demo one here.
And so you can see it's all saved as a CSV, which I will admit is like a hideous UI.
And it's like very painful to look at as a user.
And I think what my big emphasis here is you actually as a user shouldn't be looking at this much, if at all.
This should kind of just be GrokBot's brain and some systematic way to actually track these.
But you should genuinely trust GrokBot to actually have the context list and only look into it when you actually really need to.
And so you can see here I have all these different sequences.
A queue of prospects where I actually need to be added in.
My prospect board.
And then the most important stuff for me is the things I need to action on this specific day.
And so you can see this basically gives me all the things.
It's also drafting copy for the emails and everything.
And you can see here it's already got Gmail drafts ID.
So I can basically just go into my Gmail and review these all one by one.
And if I wanted to, I can just talk to my chief of staff.
And I can be like, can you actually give me a score on how confident are you that this email is accurate?
That it's solid.
And that they might actually give a response.
And this is kind of what I've delegated it to at this point.
I think I really emphasize that first.
And especially as you're kind of training it on your voice to actually like thoroughly look at these and honestly give it feedback.
But it's now at a point where I somewhat just trust it.
And I can actually push it to give me its own rating scores on how good these are.
But I think on that note, something important to emphasize when you're focusing on your copy.
So this could be Gmail.
This could be for any other platform.
Is what I've found works best is actually just prompting back and forth with GrokBot and asking it for examples.
And so, honestly, when I first had it pull in my emails and I even did all the stuff, okay, like let's wait the more recent responses.
I found that it was almost kind of templated and every response looked very similar, but just with swapping of names, of company IDs, things like that.
And so what I've really done is just kept going back and forth and asking, can you give me examples of these emails?
And then on each one basically critiquing and being like, this is why this email sucks and here's how you can make it better.
And really pushing for it to break out of kind of the standardized formatting it has and to actually kind of think and give nuanced responses at each single email.
And I think something I really push is not a single one of your emails should look like a template.
It shouldn't look like the same thing but just swapping out company or name.
And I think that's something really important to also push here.
So I'm going to dive now into actually like why I structured my setup this way and what this actually looks like.
And so obviously I'm my chief of staff at the top.
And as I said, this is actually the only bot I talked to.
And the one that I built the rest of my bots from.
And so obviously I have all my outbound actually just structured in a single folder.
And the reason I do this is I make one bot basically per platform.
And I think the important reason to do this is because you should be thinking about bots as a way of things that can run in parallel.
And so Shakespeare is doing all my email.
And so I don't need a second email bot.
But I might need a second outbound bot for a second platform that I'm reaching out to people on.
Or maybe I need context for some of the calls I'm doing.
And so having different bots for each of those different functions I think is the best way to actually handle this.
And understand the context of how your bots are working with each other.
And then so diving into my research here.
So kind of the six key bots that I'm actually using for this.
One, I have my PLG bot which is tied up to Salesforce.
So I'm actually getting to see, okay, who's signing up?
What does our usage look like?
It's also pulling in stuff like do we have any closed loss?
It's also talking with other bots.
And so chief of staff might be able to recognize that, okay, one of our prospect accounts is a closed loss opportunity.
Okay, what's the context on why?
Well, let's dig into the voice of the customer bot.
Understand the reasons why that opportunity closed loss.
Okay, maybe we didn't have support for a critical function for the business then.
But actually, as we've been updating, chief of staff recognizes that now we actually do support that.
It's seen some of the closed ones come in directly around that.
And so that will actually then take this prospect or take this account and start ranking them higher in my sequencing.
Because it's saying this is more urgent, because you need to reengage with them about this direct thing that they truly care about.
And we know that from a call we had with them.
And so being able to take that context and kind of have this full system running together, I think is extremely important.
But as we tie into this more, you can see I also have ample market, which kind of runs all our enrichment.
So once we actually find prospects, this is how we actually hook up our tools to get their emails.
And to understand, okay, is this actually their email?
Can we test it?
Make sure it won't bounce.
Things like that that won't hurt your email deliverability scores.
And then on top of that, I have a company research bot, which I think is something very important here.
And so I have this hooked up to my Sumble instance.
And what Sumble is actually able to do, the most important thing that I found is it's able to pull in a company's tech stack.
So for SpaceX's products, it's really important to understand, okay, this company is really operating with a legacy software stack.
And they're looking to kind of move off that.
Like here's the pain points we see from similar people.
And here's how we can kind of aim the messaging around that.
And on top of that, Sumble can actually pull in job postings too.
And so that's actually how it understands tech stack.
But more than that, it can actually try and pull in for you an understanding on their org chart.
So if you're selling, say, for GrokBot into a go-to-market org, Sumble can actually help you pull in information on, okay, here's actually the leader for maybe their SDR team, the person who would be interested in this.
And it's pushing all that context back into GrokBot.
And it's pushing it all back into the system and this understanding.
And again, back to the voice of the customer bot.
Maybe they said, oh, yeah, Simon on the SDR go-to-market team is looking into these exact things.
And it can talk with other bots like our company research bot here.
Pull that context back in of who exactly that is, where they sit in the org chart, and help you actually sequence that and rank that based on here's how high they are up in the company they are.
Like are they the economic buyer based on stuff like that?
And so really you can kind of have these all work together.
And again, I think this goes back to the point of the importance of building all your bots from your chief of staff bot is it understands this context better.
And it understands it just like you would.
And so moving forward here, I've kind of talked a lot about the voice of the customer bot.
But I think a cool one here also that I use is web search bot.
So I'm constantly looking at company fundings or like I said earlier, like job postings or any kind of public facing information, things in the news.
And what I've really found is a friction point with this is it's hard to scale this.
And you have 100 to 200 accounts.
And every single day, there's updates on some of these.
And so how do we actually like scan for this at scale?
So I've set up my web search bot here, which is hooked up to Exa.
And what I actually do have is an army for it that can actually break up and delegate this work.
And so you can see I kind of talked about this earlier, but I have an army huddle, which is basically just one bot telling the other bots, OK, we're going to break up these 200 companies to 40 each now run in parallel to actually do web search on all of these.
So we can actually get this information back to Simon in a timely manner.
And this is something I've really seen as like a practical way to scale some of the long running tasks and some of the ones that really have slowed down some of my workflows in the short term.
And so this has really helped me kind of stay on top of those things.
And so kind of on top of that, also, we're looking at usage.
For PLG companies, we're looking into how much are people using this product?
What teams are using this product?
And I think for Grokbot, it's something important.
We're trying to understand like how many go to market people are using it and what are kind of the use cases they have.
So being able to pull in data like that, too, and have my chief of staff actually understand all that context makes it all the more easy to actually like kind of rank every single prospect, understand priorities and understand really like who are the best targets to go after.
Because I think it's so easy to be overwhelmed as an SDR with all these different tasks and all these different things you have to do.
And it's really hard to kind of mentally try and try and understand and rank these different prospects.
And so I think having some sort of like systematic ranking here with Grokbot as I've kind of built myself is a really good way to do this.
And like I said earlier, I think a really nice part of this is you can actually share these with your team.
And so you can get the learnings and kind of share those learnings.
And I think one last thing I just wanted to show here is I've actually built some skills that kind of go deeper here.
And so I actually have a entire just prospecting skill.
And so our company here is Flylo.
But we can just type this in.
And so prospecting understands already all of the different things I want.
And this is more something at this point I just run for one off maybe net new accounts I have or things I want to research like midway through the day.
But most of this runs at routines at this point.
But I think something very interesting that I also want to talk about is the skill I've made around Grokbot ICP.
And I think this is something that's really widely applicable here.
And what this is is we're still figuring out all the different use cases for Grokbot.
And we're not sure really like who the best ICP and what that looks like.
And it's really something that's kind of an ongoing development.
And so what I wanted to do here is I wanted to turn our own findings on Grokbot's ICP into a skill.
And I did this because this way I can constantly update this as it kind of gets more and more clear what this actually means.
And so, obviously, it's something I've talked with Grokbot before about.
Okay, let's see.
What are the deals for Grokbot that are actually moving past stage one that are showing interest?
What are the things from Voice of the Customer Bot that are showing interest around this?
And why are they interested in this?
And this has really helped me kind of iterate on this skill more and more.
And I think it's something that really I want to keep building out.
And the reason I've kept it as a skill, though, is because it could drastically change.
And I want it to be able to be flexible and be something that my systems can basically call upon at any point.
And it's updated.
So as we kind of iron out more and more what Grokbot's ICP is, we can really change this on the fly if we save it as a skill here.
And so, basically, I can run that in the background.
And you can kind of see some of the high-level stuff it's going to do.
But really, I do all my work and it kind of orients it all around CSVs that look like this.
That are pulling in everything.
Like titles.
Like what's their actual ICP persona?
Like the owners and everything.
Like what's the context on why?
And then you can see it's talking to other sources.
Like Ample Market to actually get email data.
LinkedIn.
Locations here.
And really just a lot of the context on these profiles.
And you can see that it's already basically running and doing something like this.
But really at a high level, this is how I actually run all of my sequencing here.
And you can see that now it's messaging all of my orange bots.
And I think just for my own sanity, it's very clear now that it's in the research phase.
And I understand that.
I think now, boom, it's doing web search in the background.
And I'm very clear in understanding on exactly what it's doing there.
And that's, I think, why it's important to kind of actually do these somewhat in a color coded fashion.
Or maybe some themes.
It's easy to remember and to actually kind of at a high level look down and see what's happening.
But all right.
That is the demo.
And so now I'm kind of just going to discuss like what we actually learned.
What I think are genuinely like the takeaways that you guys should have and carry into your own setups for this.
Is SDRs.
All right.
So I think one of the most important things is going end to end.
And this is something I hope I showed in my demo, but that I'm really trying to push.
Is that it's very simple to just like prompt back and forth with GrokBot.
Or to have GrokBot do a single task.
Like sending an email for you.
But I think really you should push it to do the entire workflow.
And it's a lot of pain up front for you to prompt back and forth.
To build this system.
To figure out like what actually makes this system work.
But if you stick through it and you're persistent.
And you train it on your style.
You will get so much more benefit when it's able to go end to end.
When it's able to pull people in from prospecting.
It's able to enrich them.
It's able to understand all the context.
And then it's able to push that out and actually outbound them.
And do the full process.
And I think that's really what differentiates GrokBot.
And what makes it a true like force multiplier for SDRs.
So I really emphasize like thinking at a high level.
And kind of thinking how you can actually build that system.
And I think on that same note.
You should be intentional here.
So it's really intuitive to just prompt each bot.
And what I highly recommend is just taking a step back.
And thinking, okay, let me build this all through my actual chief of staff.
Bots should be able to talk to each other.
They should have that context.
The point of this is to offload more work from you.
And help you actually get higher outputs.
And so you shouldn't actually be focusing even harder.
And messaging even more bots.
It's exhausting from just all the prompt and context switching you're doing there.
And lastly, what I kind of hope I really showed my demo.
Is how to think systematically about your setup.
I think it is very easy to just always want to make new bots.
It's kind of fun.
And it's kind of exciting.
But as someone who's built an army of bots.
I promise you I've had way too many at some points.
And it's honestly more chaotic.
And it does more harm than good.
And so you should really be questioning like.
Why is it important that a new bot does this?
Why can my existing email bot.
Not just write my emails.
And also be able to be my inbox manager.
Like why do I need a second bot for that?
And also on that note like when should I just turn things into routines.
That that bot runs.
But really I emphasize kind of thinking about all these different things.
As ways for you to actually just save more tokens in the first place.
But actually just also not confuse yourself.
And not kind of just get overloaded with bots that are just doing like kind of similar things.
And again making these through your chief of staff.
Makes it all the more easier to actually do that.
All right.
So I just wanted to thank you guys for taking the time.
And I think we're going to just open it up to questions now here.
Go for it.
Yeah.
So you had a daily routine for 50 prospects and 50 leads.
Right.
So if you keep running the same workflow every day.
Approximately what sort of consumption from a token perspective do you see.
Right.
For this.
And you have any numbers that you could share like per day per week.
Kind of thing like what that translates to into a dollar amount or anything like that.
Yeah.
So the question is how many tokens does it kind of consume to run these on a daily basis.
And I think it very much depends.
And it's hard to say.
And I think the best way to actually do it is you kind of have to see what it looks like for your own instance.
Because it depends on kind of the amount of maybe gone calls you're pulling from.
The amount of context you have in your Databricks instance.
And also on top of that like how many prospects you need to like freshly enrich.
Versus how many are kind of old context that you're pulling in from Salesforce that you already have context on.
So I think it very much depends.
It also depends at the scale you're running this on.
But I think the best way to kind of do this is honestly like prompt back and forth with GrokBot.
Get an understanding of where your token usage is at.
And you can also talk back and forth with GrokBot to find ways to optimize your workflow.
So maybe 50 daily prospects isn't something practical.
Depending on like the scale of outbound you're doing.
Like maybe it makes more sense to actually run 250 on a weekly basis.
And that just sends on a Monday morning.
And then you have that to work through the whole week.
I think mine might be just a little more daily because I like pulling in all that context and really like pushing GrokBot as hard as I can.
And I think I'm just using a little more tokens doing that.
But yeah, I highly recommend just trying it out on that front.
Yeah, go for it.
Yeah, first of all, thank you so much for a great demo and the presentation.
It's really fascinating to see the actual, the use case from your own workflow.
So I think the part of your demo, I think I saw you kind of have a group chat among your boats.
So I'm curious, like, where do you see the benefit of creating that kind of the group chat?
Because you already have a chief of staff already connected all of your boats.
So what is the use case that you found like it's more beneficial?
And my second question is, I really like the naming of the Simon soldier.
So I think the other, like the orange boats were pretty intuitive for me regarding what their, like the role each of them is.
But I'm just curious, what is the soldier boat for you and then how do you use it for your workflow?
Yeah.
So I built my soldiers really just as like, okay, like these are my troopers that I'm going to send out to go do web research in general.
And I think the reason I put them in a group chat instead of actually like setting them up just as messaging my chief of staff directly.
Is one, I think it's easier to see the outputs come back to my actual web search bot.
So I can actually go in there and make sure that the outputs at each of the sub-agents is somewhat accurate and is flowing correctly.
And I think on top of that, it's much easier if I wanted to scale that from five people in my army to 20 or something.
It's much easier to scale that if I have my web search bot basically handing off the context and all those sub-agents really have like low context.
And so it's very easy just in that way to scale that up or down on a whim.
And so that's, that's kind of like why I thought of doing it that way.
Um, sorry, I might've missed it, but like, uh, I guess like, so if you, let's say you come in, right.
And you create a chief of staff bot, can you then just task the chief of like, just show what like your work is or what you need to be doing.
And then the chief of staff like spins up the appropriate number of bots automatically.
And, and where did the sub-agents kind of come in?
I guess like, because I think when I come in, you, sorry, you were saying like, you should think about work being done in parallel and show there should be different bots for things being done in parallel.
But that's difficult for like a user perhaps to think about.
Um, unless I guess maybe you just really know that job very well, but it could be different every time.
But what's like the way to just get going really quickly where just the time to value is minimized as if someone just comes in, just wants to set up for me based on best practices.
Perfect. I'll answer this quickly.
And then I think we're going to, we're going to go back to live stream upstairs.
But, um, I think at a high level, really just talking back and forth with GrokBot.
When some of this stuff is extremely overwhelming, I think GrokBot can actually help you understand what a practical setup is.
And if you just kind of talk it at a high level of what your actual workflow looks like and what that is.
Um, it can really help you kind of divide up when it makes sense to use new bots.
And, and I think that's kind of the easiest way to kind of answer that broadly for all the different use cases.
Just one quick, they hand me the mic.
Um, first off, I love the Simon soldiers.
I was telling everyone at dinner last night about my beautiful, beautiful, sweet GrokBots.
And I call them all soldiers for Christ.
Oh, right on.
Um, because they marched forward on my behalf.
All right, welcome back.
We are back here in our studio, uh, back on the stream, back with some updates on what we've been building.
If we can get my screen up on the slides or on the stream here, wanted to make sure you all could see that slide that we flashed up at the end of that talk.
So you can scan that QR code if you haven't already, uh, while we get my screen up.
If you want to win some free GrokBot, you can, uh, follow these steps to get a free month of GrokBot for $200 in values.
It's a pretty, pretty big free month at our highest tier.
Uh, if you duplicate and create a bot with Dr. EggBot.
So go get the Dr. EggBot template, uh, create a bot with Dr. EggBot and, you know, work, go through the experience of, of installing Dr. EggBot into your own GrokBot instance.
If you do that on stream, uh, following this QR code, the first 1000 users who go through this will get a free month of GrokBot, uh, to be able to do all the things that we've been doing and much, much more $200 in value.
It's a lot of credits.
It's a lot of usage.
And, um, we're really excited to give you all a chance to kind of do a little bit of what we've been doing.
If you haven't had a chance to try GrokBot already, great way to get your feet wet with a lot of credits.
And it's an exclusive on stream offer.
So, uh, now's your chance.
Grab it before it's gone.
Okay.
Um, well, welcome back.
We are working on our business here.
Uh, we've been spending the last few days working on building a gaming business and a game studio.
And for those who haven't been following along since, I don't know how many hours it's been.
We are some number of hours.
Yeah.
It's like almost over two days into this process.
Um, but the plans are starting to come together.
We've had a lot of fun guests on today.
Um, a few of us have been peeling off to go work on some of the builds in the background too.
And so we've been really excited to make some progress, show you guys what we've been up to.
I've got a few bots that we're going to cook up and kind of walk through some demos on today.
Um, where do we leave things off?
So I think what, what I did while during our last break was I spent some time taking the prototype that we built and turning it into a Next.js React app with some placeholders for the server side that we're going to build.
So we're going to kind of split out the client and the server app into, you know, separate, separate apps so that we can evolve those things independently.
Uh, and Lauren, you were sharing a little bit about how this is going to make it much easier for us to rev on the client, right?
Yeah.
I mean, I think for the client and the, I mean, for like a competitive team like this, uh, you do want to have a server that is, you know, deciding like the, the things that like people, like you can just modify the client and cheat.
Uh, so I think that will be a good thing.
Uh, we'll have off as well set up and, um, I'm still not a hundred percent sure on what the client will look like.
I think like this, what we have with the web version looks fine so far, but it makes me wonder if like, maybe we should, uh, it'd be interesting to get a few bots, uh, you know, started up.
Yeah.
Maybe with Dr. Eggbot and then maybe even prototyping different versions of the client.
Because now that we have a backend, like we could have multiple clients.
Uh, well, I don't think we'll have multiple clients at launch.
Yeah.
But for us to iterate, because maybe there's an interesting 3D version or, I don't know, a pixel art version.
Get the blender MCP involved.
Terminal, terminal client.
Yeah.
Well, what's cool about this is, yeah, now that we've kind of separated these things, we can have the server maintain the state and then just like follow the server contract that we've established with that API and go and let the client, you know, prototype a little bit.
We've added in a few new features.
We have a global leaderboard here.
It's obviously not fully wired in.
So these are all just fun names for now, but hopefully be able to get that.
So once you guys are into the game, we're going to have a leaderboard and then I'm actually excited to get something launched in the next few hours.
Yeah.
So what I was thinking is maybe to help us make some progress is let's start kind of tracking all the things we need to do.
So I have my chief of staff bot here and I'm going to ask my chief of staff bot to get our Notion.going that has our to-do list and then help us keep an eye on it so we can track all of our ongoing tasks together.
We've all been dumping some stuff into Notion.
I think as we go, Warren, I think you have a great, you know, a game design bot.
Yeah, I spun up a game designer bot to do some research on, well, I think like our game mechanics are pretty simple right now.
So I created, I got Dr. Igbot to make me a new bot to do, I guess, game research.
Cool.
So it looked at some other battler games for, you know, interesting mechanics and interesting features for us to be inspired by.
And I got it to write a Notion doc that's not wired up to anything right now.
It's just a standalone doc, but it'd be interesting to have like a, you know, as we start to build out the game studio business,
start just thinking about like operationally, you know, like how do we actually keep each other informed of what we're doing?
And like, it could be nice to have a Notion doc that's just tracking all of the work we're doing on the project.
We don't really, I guess we do have a deadline, right?
We have some milestones we want to hit, so it'd be good to actually start tracking that.
Yeah, let's do it. I have my chief over here working on that.
And then we have my founding engineer, Bake, who's been keeping an eye on all the PRs that have been coming into the repo.
So we have a bunch of PRs that we've been shipping.
And I kind of have this, my bot over here is, well, let's see if I can pull this up the right way, is, yeah, watching the repo.
So you can see there's some GitHub kind of, you know, integrations tied in here where anytime a new PR is opened or changed,
I'm getting notified about it in my bot.
So that's been really helpful for me to see on top of all the changes Lauren's been making.
We've been dual merging here.
So I'm kind of making changes to the client.
Lauren's been making changes to the server and backend.
And so you can see I got some updates here, which is great.
And then my bots are messaging each other to put together this plan.
So as soon as we have that, I'll pop up a Notion page and hopefully we can get that going and look at it together.
Maybe just like pin it to the chat over, pin it to the stream over here so we have our--
Yeah, it'd be good maybe like to even have it on the side, right?
And then you can apply half of your screen Notion, half of the graph box.
Yeah, let's do that.
And we can kind of like try to burn down the tasks as much as possible.
What do you think are the main ones?
We can help steer the agent here a little bit.
We need to--
Well, for sure, like I have to get the backend shipped and deployed.
Do you want to do the client thing?
Actually, I don't know if we should.
Maybe we'll just keep it web for now because web would be the easiest.
Yeah.
I guess we could maybe try like a 3D version.
Oh, yeah.
For the animations, maybe.
Just to see.
And maybe just not make that a blocking task.
That can be like a little side quest for one bot to go and just try.
And if we like it, we can take it.
If not, we'll just scrap it.
And then I think it'd be really good to maybe make some progress on just thinking through the ad stuff.
I know we kind of like briefly talked about it.
I don't really know what our plans are for that yet.
Yeah, we can think about that.
So it'd be good to--
We had a cool remotion prototype.
We have remotion for like actually running some ads.
Oh, nice.
So we have some assets.
We can think about like, okay, if we have this like stadium theoretically that the bots are in.
Right, right.
Number one, what does the space look like?
And then two, like how do we--
I mean, the question would be like, okay, how do we sell these things?
Like how do we account for that?
And then which ads do we choose?
Is it like a marketplace for ads?
Are we just like selling definitive slots?
Like how do we price those?
So I think that's like some exploration to think through the framework.
But then also like we can start to build out that system since we have server, right?
Yeah.
Cool.
Okay.
I got those captured as we were talking.
So I'll get those into the Notion doc.
And hopefully we should be able to pull that up in a second here.
Let me find my Chrome window.
Here we go.
Working to do's.
Maybe ask your bot to share this doc with us.
Oh, yeah.
Ping us on Slack.
And actually something I haven't set up yet that I usually do is to have a kind of like a Slack manager bot that kind of like watches for pings.
And then it can kind of, I'll just tell it to like, hey, you know, every time we do a task, update the Notion.
That's a great idea.
Maybe we can all do that.
Yeah.
Get a, get a.
Oh, you want to try something fun?
Why don't we all turn on voice mode at the same time and create the same bot?
I think that could be really cool.
Should we try it?
Sure.
Let's do it.
Who's going to do the prompt?
Why don't you do it?
It's your Slack bot or your Slack idea.
Okay, okay.
All right.
So on three, we hit start on voice mode.
Wait, wait, wait.
Which bot are you on?
Are you on Dr. Egg bot?
Yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yep.
Ready?
Okay, go.
Three, two, one, go.
All right.
Hello, Dr. Egg bot.
We are interested in building a Slack bot.
So the job of the Slack bot will be to listen for at mentions of our username on Slack and process
them.
So there might be things like...
We might get notified of things like, you know, here's a task that was completed and there's
going to be a Notion doc that's tracking all of the progress we're making on our game.
So maybe let's start with that for now and we kind of tweak the instructions as we go.
But yeah, for now, a Slack bot that just responds to mentions on Slack.
Let's hope that works.
Hey, it worked for me.
Wow.
Then when do you just say restate this in your own words?
Oh, I just hit send.
I just hit send.
I mean, I send it.
Whatever.
Okay, cool.
That was kind of fun.
I don't think I've done a multi-bot creation flow before.
Maybe we should publish that one.
Okay.
It looks like we have our to-do list up here in the top right.
So I have...
Let me zoom in a little bit so this is more visible on the stream.
We got some...
Oh, wow.
It's given us a minute-by-minute plan.
We'll have to see.
We're going to do some corporate MUT stuff.
It looks like we have some open PRs here.
So maybe we actually...
Yeah, I have a full autopilot system going.
Okay.
And a bunch of to-dos.
It looks like it actually took the liberty of making new pages for each of our tasks
and putting them in a Notion database, which is kind of cool.
So a bunch of other stuff here.
What do you typically do as a PM tracking tasks?
This is actually exactly how I use Notion.
Do you just use a checklist or do you have a specific view that you like?
I know some people like a Kanban or different...
So I actually switch back and forth.
I like Notion for this because Notion can just make you a database
and then you can flip the views of it to be whatever you want.
So for certain things, I like Kanban boards
and I can just like go from in-progress to doing.
And then what I will sometimes do is just have a bot listening to that Notion board
every little while.
So if I move something to in-progress, the bot just goes in and starts to work on it.
But for other things like for this, I think the checklist is just easier in my head
because I'm like, here are the five things we need to do.
So yeah, I kind of go back and forth.
But for a lot of the work that we work on GrokBot together on,
I have a Notion board that pretty much just does the database thing.
So yeah, it's kind of cool.
A lot of options.
Okay, so that's our to-do list.
Let's see if I can structure my screen here where we can see everything.
Cool, cool, cool.
And then we have a looks like we made a new Slack bot called Ping.
Oh my god, I had the same name.
How did you know?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I don't know.
I guess Dr. Eggbot is really good at naming.
What is your Slack bot's name?
I'm installing the Slack plugin right now.
Okay.
Yeah, I need to connect Slack, but I might do that when we're not looking at my screen.
So I'm not showing any secrets.
So can we go to the wide angle shot for a second and give me a chance to connect Slack?
Thank you.
In the meantime, I'm kicking off a couple agents.
I got some ads research.
So running like an agent to kind of understand like, okay, like how do video games sell ads?
Like how do other businesses think about this problem?
And then making a recommendation for how we'd implement that on the client in our server.
And then also like Lauren mentioned, checking out some like maybe prototype pixel implementations.
Because that could be cool.
So I feel like pixel art.
Sometimes it's good.
Sometimes it's like really bad.
So we'll have to see.
Maybe play around with that a bit.
Cool.
I almost got Slack connected here.
I'm just doing my last GitHub setup as well.
Cool.
In the meantime, if I want to cut to my screen, I can show off some of what these, like the
remotion assets ended up looking like from the last time.
And then we could also walk through some cool rockpot uses that have queued up.
That'd be cool.
Anything we should be thinking about for client server implementation while I'm not pulling that up?
Okay, cool.
So basically what we talked through before is like, right, how remotion built these as code.
So the cool thing is that you can just like start to create different aspect ratios.
Obviously, like, you know, is this perfect?
Like, do we want to adjust the crop?
Like probably.
But now we have like a 16.9 asset.
So you'd imagine like, or 9.16 rather.
We have 1.1, 9.16, 16.9.
So now we could advertise like maybe there's a platform that prefers this.
Probably like LinkedIn, Instagram, X.
And there's like a way to easily start like distributing these assets.
Is this like perfect fidelity?
No, it doesn't really explain much about the game or how it works.
But like once we have the assets in the game and the game mechanics, we could then slot those in for the react components that we have.
And sort of like build out some like dynamic videos, right?
So the whole point here is I could pop this open and then like render this out as a video where we'd have like a video asset on my laptop.
So yeah, that was pretty cool.
That was really cool.
Yeah, I love remotion.
Yeah.
One of my favorite tools.
Yeah, you can just like create these so quickly.
Yeah, it might be cool to even get a bot to like put some of these in some iPhone frames and see how they'd show up.
I don't know if that's like because the bots are pretty good at generating just like in like live HTML in the chat.
They are.
You can also typically what I'll do for iPhone frames is like if you use Figma, you can find like like there's an official number one.
There's there are official Apple frames like there's an official Figma pack to do this and then like you can you can like dig through some of these things and find like good device or assets.
So one thing I think I'd have to set up separately is like Figma.
We have to set up like a Figma workspace.
We could pull in some of these phone frame assets and then actually this could be a pretty cool workflow because bot is quite good at using Figma.
So maybe I'll maybe I'll kick it over to that in a bit.
Nice.
But I want to share actually.
So we had a guest on earlier, Karen, some cool, cool growth by use cases.
She basically had like bought print out like a morning summary on her printer.
So she has an Internet connected printer.
And this is like personally one of my favorite use cases.
So I want to share that.
I think I want to do because like I try to journal.
Everybody tries to journal.
Most people try to journal.
Many people fail to journal.
I actually do like try to write first thing in the morning, whether it's like creative or about like about my life.
And I feel like it would be really cool to have like a template with the date that just gets printed out every morning.
And that would like to me, that feels like almost more tactile than opening a journal.
And I feel like it's a better reminder.
So that's something I want to play around with.
And then also I'm thinking about getting like a receipt printer and then like hooking it up to Twitter and like printing out tweets.
I think that's actually another one I saw.
So this is Lenny shout out Lenny or Chinsky.
Super, super big rock by power user.
Awesome dude.
He paid a parking citation.
We all get parking citations, especially in the Bay Area.
It's like notorious.
So using our like payments link integration, he paid his parking citation.
So I thought this was pretty cool.
That's cool.
We might we might have some Stripe friends on the on the show at some point.
That would be fun.
I got a third one here.
The similar to what Matthew Berman talked about.
This is Alexandra here.
Using the rock plot to sell items on like online marketplaces, which is pretty sick.
I think the hardest part for like I sell a lot of stuff on like Facebook marketplace.
The hardest part about buying and selling stuff is like you have to take the photos and then do all the meta tagging like all this stuff.
It's so annoying.
So this is pretty cool.
Cool use case.
And then the last one I have similar printing use case.
There's printing out like if you I mean when you're a kid like everybody has seen sheets like these and has probably has like PTSD from like doing that homework.
Oh homework.
Yeah.
So they just print out like arithmetic worksheets for the kid, which is pretty cool.
And I like that as well.
So yeah, those are some four things I had queued up that I saw on the timeline that I thought were pretty cool.
Yeah, that's so cool.
I think yeah, like one really underrated part of GrokBot is are the routines, right?
Like these daily routines are really nice.
Yeah.
But then there's also routines that subscribe to events.
So like Slack messages is the one we were just talking about.
But it can also subscribe to things like, you know, for like if you're doing coding and doing technical things, you can subscribe to like Datadog, Sentry, whatever.
And have, you know, you start to think about like a factory type setup, right?
Yeah.
Where you have alert.
Oh, our backend is down.
Like then spin off some bots to go investigate triage.
100%.
While you're working on that, I got our Notion doc cleaned up a little bit.
So if we can.
Okay.
Let's pull up Roshan's screen.
We'll take a look at the Notion doc.
My bot's starting to merge some of the backend peers too.
Awesome.
I'm getting all these notifications.
So Bake, my engineer is getting all these notifications.
I need to remind it to actually check off the Notion doc.
Oh yeah.
Well, I was actually about to send a Slack message to both of you.
Oh.
And so here we go.
Yeah.
My screen's back up.
So I retooled our Notion doc to look like a Kanban board.
You inspired me just now.
Cool.
So here's the cupcake board.
We have like not started up next.
And I just asked my chief of staff here to send you all a message.
And I actually really love this feature.
It just sort of like gives you a message option and you can just send it.
And there you go.
And so that's going to send.
And it lets us preview the draft of the message and be able to send it.
So we have a message off to Slack for both of you.
And then going back to bake over here is our founding engineer, seeing all those PRs come in.
Hopefully your Slack bots get that message and then can know the canonical source of truth for our Kanban board.
Sweet.
Cool.
Yeah, I decided I'm going to make like a personal PM bot as well.
I like to have like specialists for my bots.
So this bot's only responsibility will be to update the Notion.
Great.
Then I have my Slack bot that's only responsibility is to handle my @ mentions on Slack.
And then it's going to work with the rest of my team to, I guess, I don't know, like when I merge a PR, update the Notion and things like that.
That's awesome.
Cool.
Okay.
So we have a task list going.
It looks like a couple of these are in progress.
Hopefully all of our bots are able to pick up tickets.
Almost like we've made our own little ticketing system in some ways, you know, and assign our bots to various tasks.
So I think that seems really good.
Seeing a bunch of PRs coming in.
How are we feeling about the actual app?
Do we feel like it's in a good spot to take a look?
I don't think it's finished yet.
Cool.
A lot of rebasing.
Any good software engineering project?
Let's see if there's any of these other things that can maybe, we've got to wait on the play test, working on the backend, working on auth, the 3D client experiment.
Do you think I should send some agents off to work on that?
I think we need the server in for that first, right?
We can still do like some prototypes.
Yeah.
Like maybe you can just tell your bot.
Hey.
I'm going to start a new Docker egg bot.
Or like talk Docker egg bot and make a new bot.
Yeah, you could make like a prototype or bot.
I think it'd be interesting.
Maybe the 3D only needs to come in at the battle part, you know?
Just to make it more interesting, maybe.
Although I guess then the question is also how do we translate the bot to 3D?
Yeah, yeah.
Well, let me see what our agents come up with.
Maybe they can try some things.
Maybe because like the bots are all in a standard shape anyway.
Right, right.
I guess the complexity of 3D is like we'll have to think about how to visually disambiguate them.
But maybe it's not a big deal.
Yeah.
It'd be good to just see a throwaway prototype.
Hey, Dr. Eggbot.
We want to try some more front-end client explorations for the client application that we've built in the Cupcake repo.
Can you spin up a bot whose job it's going to be to try and prototype ways that we can add more 3D animations while keeping the app super lightweight?
The bot should be able to use cursor cloud agents to get this work done and interact with the repo that we just talked about.
I'm really interested here in being able to swarm agents using potato mode on a bunch of different front-end prototyping tasks.
So the core purpose of this bot is going to be the prototype stuff.
And then as we find stuff that we like or find examples of these prototypes that we like, we'll try and merge those in if they make sense.
So let's go ahead and get that spot.
All right, cool.
Got a bot going.
I'm seeing more PRs coming in, too, which is great.
What did you think of the game design research that I sent over?
Oh, I haven't had a chance to look at it, actually.
Maybe we could pull that up.
You had a doc for this, right?
Notion?
Yeah.
What is it called?
Hmm.
I think I messaged you on Slack.
Oh, let me ask Ping.
I'll go back here to my to-do list.
So we should have a stone screen.
Oh, it's in the RDN.
Yeah.
I'm seeing more PRs coming in, too, which is great.
What did you think of the game design research that I sent over?
Oh, I haven't had a chance to look at it, actually.
Maybe we could pull that up.
You had a doc for this, right?
Notion?
Yeah.
What is it called?
Hmm.
I think I messaged you on Slack.
Oh, let me ask Ping.
Oh, it's in the RDN.
Okay.
But yeah, I think our game mechanics are a little bit too plain at the moment.
It doesn't have to block the launch, but it'd be good to just start thinking about…
I mean, we have some ideas in that doc.
Yeah.
But maybe we can figure out which one's the best one to fast follow after we get it launched.
I was spinning up a bot for that.
Oh, wow.
I just saw some updates filtering on the Notion board, so our bots are definitely doing something
there.
I just asked Dr. Eggbot to spin up a game design bot for us that can handle ingesting that information.
Nice.
And yeah, it looks like you did DM me.
There's the Notion doc.
Thank you.
Yep.
Yeah, and here's our new bot, Glow.
3D.
I like using these labels, too.
It just helps me keep them all organized.
And I like fun names for my bots, so it's kind of fun to be able to do that.
So Glow is our 3D prototyping bot.
It looks like it's asking me what we'd want to try.
Which motion lane should we bias the first system towards?
What do you think?
UI Chrome depth?
Match and fight flourishes, actually.
That's what we were talking about before, right?
Yeah.
Or I can give it a few more.
This is a multi-fix, so I guess…
Yeah, I don't know.
I mean…
Let's do the match and fight.
Match and fight could be probably the best place.
Cool.
And I have a new bot here, Crit.
That's our game designer.
Hey, we got a whole team cooking.
Watching Slack, watching GitHub, game designing.
Actually, I don't know that we've told anybody this.
We just launched 1Password integration.
Oh, cool.
Did we announce that?
Yeah.
I think we did.
I saw it on stream.
No, I meant on stream.
I see it on Twitter.
I have it open on Twitter.
Or X, rather.
Whoops.
A little bit of feedback.
We could actually cover my screen real quick.
We'll talk about it.
X.com/bot.
It was actually just right at the top.
There you go.
Boom.
1Password.
Awesome.
So maybe we should start to…
I mean, this would have been super helpful to have when we were setting all that stuff
up with 1Password.
Yeah.
We spent like a day doing that.
But the team shifts fast.
Maybe they knew.
Maybe they saw our stream.
Yeah.
We have a feature for you.
Okay.
Well, hey.
We have a whole other day of stream.
There you go.
All of our secrets management tomorrow will be such easier.
This is awesome.
This is really cool.
I want to try this out.
All right.
Cool.
So where are we?
You're working on some of this design stuff?
Yeah.
I'm totally lost here.
Working on…
So I have bots trying to work on the…
Actually, I don't know.
Could you double check if that Notion page that you shared is in our Notion space?
Because my bot is having some trouble getting it.
Let us see.
It is.
Okay.
Do I need to share…
I think it's only private.
Oh, okay.
Let me change that.
Okay.
You should have access now.
Cool.
I just asked my bot to try it again.
Oh, yeah.
It came out with some good feedback.
The fleet.
This is a crazy doc.
The fleet?
The fleet pulse.
It's a rollup of durable facts from active ship by Thursday bots.
That's really great.
I guess they just decided they'd want to make this.
This is the…
Our bots are writing updates from PRs that merge.
One of our bots is.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
It came out with some good feedback.
The fleet.
This is a crazy doc.
The fleet?
The fleet pulse.
It's a rollup of durable facts from active ship by Thursday bots.
That's really great.
I guess they just decided they'd want to make this.
What does that mean?
Our bots are writing updates from PRs that merge.
One of our bots is.
Yeah.
Cool.
I have two bots spinning on the 2.5D 3D prototyping.
So, hopefully we'll get some cool examples there soon.
Those are cursor cloud agents that are running.
I got my cursor cloud agents page.
I think our backend is almost done.
So, I'm going to start wiring it up to the client.
Oh, awesome.
Okay, great.
And so, hopefully in a few minutes, maybe after the break, we'll have it playable.
We'll definitely try to play with it in the background as well and continue iterating.
But we're getting really close to being able to share the game with the chat.
Yeah.
And maybe getting some real games and feedback as well.
So, one thing I'm actually really interested in is like setting up like a…
you know, like kind of what I was saying, like a feedback factory where we'll get feedback
from people playing the game who like, you know, this is boring or whatever.
And we'll get that and start to automatically, you know, triage, put it into our notion,
you know, get the whole system going and try to move really fast.
So, yeah, my agent, my bots are wiring up the backend now.
So, hopefully we'll make some progress.
Cool.
So, I was just looking at this MVP here for like an ads, a lobby-sponsored billboard.
And it looks like it's proposing like an endpoint for serving the billboard.
And kind of describing, hey, there's no ads route, so we need to add one.
We might need to add a table that allows us to like slot those in.
And it's describing like a data modeling for having advertisers, campaigns, and creatives.
Honestly, it seems a little too complex.
I might slim this down a little bit.
But yeah, I mean, I think this isn't, I don't think this seems to be too complicated.
It's interesting to see.
Oh, I'm actually also looking at the chat and I guess there are some questions around like
what game we're building.
Yeah.
For the people who are joining late, maybe Roshan, you want to give a quick update?
Yeah, I would love to.
Maybe even show what we have so far, the web prototype.
Yeah, let me see if I can find my prototype.
I had it running somewhere.
Oh, there we go.
We'll cut to Roshan's screen here.
Yeah.
If we cut to my screen, I can show you a little bit of what we've been building in the background.
So.
Cool.
Yeah.
So this is what we're building.
So we are a, we're building a game studio in our first game.
And that's the business that we've been building on stream for the last little while.
We have a working name for our game, which is Cupcake.
And the whole premise of the game is that you'll be able to log in with X and pit your bots head-to-head
against other bots in order to win the global leaderboard and get to the top of the global leaderboard.
And so.
How did you get first place, Matt?
I don't know.
You.
You know, I don't make the rules.
I don't make the rules around here.
What the hell?
How did you?
It's a placeholder leaderboard.
We'll match up for real.
I'm very competitive.
When there's a leaderboard, I'm like, ooh, I'm going to optimize.
That's what we're hoping we'll make.
We're hoping everyone's going to be competitive to drive a bunch of users to the game, right?
So this is our prototype that we built, which is just a bunch of HTML.
And we have a client app now that we're wiring into a proper backend.
But the idea here is that you'd be able to customize your team with bots that you're uploading.
So if you create a bot template using GrockBot, you'll be able to add that bot in.
The bot will be assigned some stats, subject to some rules that we built.
And if you're curious to learn more about some of that, you can go and check out some of our sessions from this morning.
But basically, you have a team of bots here, and you create a lineup for any match.
So you'd choose a captain bot, get a few friends that join your team, and then be able to have your bots face off against someone else who's logged in
and who's also in the app at the same time and kind of earn some points and grow your rating and get onto the leaderboard.
So that's the end-to-end mock-up.
Obviously, we're going to continue adding to this, but that's kind of where we are.
Yeah, what I like about this is, like, so right now it's obviously very simple.
But I think there's, like, a lot of really interesting mechanics we can add to the game.
Like, you know, we have a leaderboard, it's competitive.
We have this notion of, like, a captain bot.
Don't really know what that means yet.
Yeah.
But maybe that can have some special, like, maybe there's some special difference for the captain.
Yeah, I think that could be a lot of really interesting ideas.
Like, maybe there's a chance as well to, like, if you win, like, you get a chance to take the other person's bot or something.
I don't know, you know, something like that where I feel like there's a lot of interesting ideas there.
Yeah.
That's actually my favorite part about this idea is, like, there's so many requests that we can go with it, right?
So it's like, once we get the core out there, we'll be able to kind of go from there, so.
Cool, okay.
We also have a task list that we're working towards.
So it looks like auth work is in progress.
Promotion ads are in progress.
Working on the API in the back end here.
Let's see what my-- so I have a game critique bot here that Lauren had a bot that wrote up some thoughts on our game design pattern here.
So just to kind of recap for folks, we basically built some game mechanics here for these bots to go head to head and wanted to kind of validate, you know, are these best practices for game design?
None of us are pro game designers.
Some of us are pro game players.
Or not pro, but, you know, enjoy playing games.
What's really nice is we can just go and, like, you know, get some wisdom from the world here.
So it looks like we have some proposed changes to the mechanics.
Do you want to zoom in a little bit so I can see?
Yeah, let me do that.
There we go.
I can actually just make Dropbox the screen here for a second so you can see that a little bit better.
Yeah.
Type only.
Okay, so maybe some suggestions here.
Actually, one thing I'm noticing is-- well, a meta thing I'm noticing is, like, some of the writing here is kind of--
It kind of looks like AI writing.
So I wonder if you could use the handy dandy unslop skill or the bro skill in PSAC to--
Oh, you can't see that.
Let's get, like, a plain English--
Unslop bro.
Plain English.
These two are the most-- I hear they're the most useful skills in PSAC.
So very, very handy for, like, what-- what did my bot just say?
Very, very useful.
Yeah, and if you have not installed PSAC, go into the marketplace.
You can install PSAC.
You get all of these skills.
There are over 40 of them here that will help you be a potato engineer.
Okay, so it's a clean version here.
Social Truth.
Looks good.
Cool ask.
I'm gonna have this crit agent actually talk to our founding engineer.
Just make sure it follows these rules.
It might be good to have a canonical game design document as well.
Mm-hmm.
So it's like one thing that's really useful when you're starting to work in a team with GraphBot
is, like, sharing context with each other.
Yeah.
And, yeah, I think it'd just be good to-- like, I have that one scratch doc for the game design,
but it'd be really nice to have a single document that, you know, we can all reference or the bots can reference.
Great idea.
I'm gonna spin that up right now.
Okay.
Send it to one on that on Slack.
What I like about this is I know you both have bots listening to Slack, so I can just say, "Send something to Slack," and it just hopefully will make its way into your bot ecosystem.
I haven't seen anything in Slack.
I'm gonna ask my bot as well.
But my bot is definitely listening.
Yeah, let me pull up mine.
So I have a bot here called Ping that is monitoring Slack.
And if I look at Ping's routines, yep, anytime Slack is mentioned-- when @ mentioned anymore on Slack.
So anytime I'm at mention, it should be working.
Make sure you watch DMs too, not just @mentions in random channels.
Yeah, one thing I do as well is when I start to feel like there's almost like a workflow that I want, that's the point where I start thinking about, okay, how do I get Dr. Eggbot to actually fix up not just one agent, but all my agents.
So, you know, example, you know, let's just say that we want it to be very communicative.
And like, you know, every decision we make should go onto Slack and, you know, we want to always keep each other informed.
That's something Dr. Eggbot can actually help you with.
So you could tell it like, "Hey, Dr. Eggbot, we want to be very, you know, fluid with our comms."
And every time we make a decision post to Slack and hopefully that it doesn't overdo it and literally like spam this.
But like the point being, you know, when you're starting to feel like you are almost like micromanaging your bots too much with individual commands and prompts.
It's a good time to kind of like take a step back and think like, "Hmm, how do I actually, you know, think about orchestrating my team of bots?"
And, you know, Dr. Eggbot's like really good for that.
Cool.
And it looks like my Slackbot is updated to be listening to DMs as well.
Yeah.
Out of curiosity, are our bots updating the Notion?
Let's take a look.
So I see a bunch of tasks here.
I did see a few things flip over from up next to in progress.
Like, Clark was not in progress a few minutes ago.
And so I think we have our bots updating Notion, which is great.
I'm just gonna, let's see here.
Switch back to, okay, we have a feature here for the replay tape that just got merged.
Yeah, I'm gonna tell my Dr. Eggbot to tell all my team that the Notion's gonna be the source of truth.
And every bot should keep it updated.
I'll do the same.
Cool.
It looks like we have my founding engineer earlier.
I had my game design bot here asked my founding engineer to take a look at the client implementation and make sure we have the latest feedback from our game design overview.
And so looks like we were messaging back and forth from the bots and looks like we maybe need to fix some stuff here.
So just go ahead and have bait have our engineer just start working doing what it thinks it's best.
Okay.
What are you all working on?
Updating some of the ad stuff.
So we're working on that like maybe like a little bit of a marketplace.
And also just make sure that my Slack missions are live and listening.
So we should be good there.
Awesome.
I see how I agree.
I am continuing to build our back end for simplicity.
Well, actually I'm reworking it a little bit because I'm going to use Vercel functions.
Cool.
I'm going to try that out.
I've never used Vercel functions before.
But it's going to be an interesting setup because it's going to be like serverless.
So we'll see how well that works.
Nice.
I like it.
Yeah.
It's going.
I'm also going to wire our web client so that we can actually start playing with Vercel.
Nice.
Let's see if we can get some of these videos working.
So while we were talking, I kicked off a 3D prototyping bot that was going to take a look at some possible ways we could add some more 3D to this experience and explore some mockups for that.
Let's see if this video works here.
Maybe it won't.
We can figure out what's going there.
But what's cool about this is the bot seems to have generated some videos in the back end and try to put some mockups together, which is pretty exciting.
Well, we got some tests failing.
Maybe we can go clean up.
Yeah, tests are interesting because I feel like agents in general are not super good at writing tests.
So one thing actually we haven't really done yet is, you know, so I think I care a lot about code quality, of course, but I think at such an early stage of the project, it's more important to just actually get it out the door.
So we haven't really spent any time on that.
But I think once we have it up and we're trying to iterate, I will set up the kind of like code quality factory, start thinking about, you know, performance, things like that.
So tests are, yeah, I almost wonder if like tests are slowing us down.
Should I delete all the tests?
What's there to test right now?
Yeah, you know, maybe let me tell my bot.
Yeah, let's delete all the tests.
We're pushing to main and deleting all the tests.
True scrappy mode.
We'll, we'll write the test later once we know what we want.
Once we know what we're testing.
Right.
Cool, it's like our agents are here.
Okay, and I think we should have a mechanics doc.
Oh, I gotta figure that out and clean that up.
Yeah, I think my bots are updating the Notion.
And I think if we, if we cut to my screen for a little bit, I can show off what my project agents are doing.
So if you haven't used cursor projects before, it's a new feature that we launched.
When did we launch it?
I think either a few days ago or last week.
I'm blanking on when exactly we launched it.
But very recently and projects are like one of the best features in, in cursor.
The way I imagine, I think about a project is really, it's a long, it's a long running coordinator agent that, you know, does a really good job of keeping track of like sub agents and smaller agents that, that it orchestrates to do tasks.
And so it's kind of similar to the multitasking mode that Roshan shared earlier.
But this one's like a little bit, I think projects are a little bit more powerful because projects have access to certain things like a shared, so one thing that projects have is like they share this, like almost memory between the cloud agents that it spawns with the main project agent so that they can sort of communicate with each other and share context.
So you can see that actually I'm not even piloting this project.
My GropBot, Tater, I told it to actually, you know, work with my project agent.
So it's going off and doing that.
And you can see here in this working tray that there's, it spawned five different sub agents and it's just orchestrating them all and driving them to completion.
Another really cool thing about this is like we have potato mode in here and potato mode has this really cool playbook, my favorite playbook called full autopilot.
It's like the, I wouldn't call it the YOLO mode, but it's like the, it's the mode where you are trying to get a lot of PRs merged and you're, you want to kind of like opt into a full agentic loop.
So it does a lot of things like it will obviously have agents that go up and implement those tasks.
And then it will also spawn like verification agents that will actually try to run the code and make sure it's correct.
And depending on like how much, I guess, how much reasoning you apply in setup Pstack.
So setup Pstack is a skill in Pstack that lets you adjust how, how much multitasking you do on the max level.
You know, we'll spawn like a swarm of agents to actually run the application and fuzz the application.
And fuzz meaning like they'll actually run it and like kind of, you know, click around, make sure that things are working.
And you have like lots of bots, like almost like simulating like real users.
And I'm, I'm, I'm, for some reason, the project agent has picked up on some potato nomenclature or terminology here.
Like it, instead of saying merge, it says mashed.
I don't know why it's doing that, but that's fun.
It's that personality.
I love that.
I think, I think Tater must have told it like, yeah, mash it in.
We do have a, we do have a bot here called MASH.
So I wonder if it's doing that.
That's great.
And what's really cool too is like while you're doing all this, I'm seeing the Notion campaign board just like all these updates.
So we had a bunch of stuff that was next up that is now all in progress.
And a few things have moved over to done.
Like we need to rebase PR21 and land PR19.
So it looks like both of those are in.
So, yep.
That's really cool.
I'm seeing like the Notion thing kind of just fly.
It was kind of cool.
It's like, you know, if we had an extra monitor in here somewhere, just like put the dashboard up on a monitor and just see all of our tasks flying around in real time.
That'd be really cool.
The real ticket, the ticket burned down.
ETA to complete.
Yeah.
Cool.
We're going to see if we've made any progress on our 3D design prototypes.
Kind of see what we came up with.
Oh, yeah.
Should we take a look?
Yeah.
Give me a second.
Let me pull up these PRs.
I think I have one here.
You can probably pull them both up right quick.
PR.
Oh, I forgot to mention about while you're working on that, that Projects is really good at.
The fact that every single agent on the project is actually a cloud agent.
So I could actually just go off, turn my laptop off, go and have dinner.
Yeah.
Go get some boba.
And it's going to keep working.
And oh, it looks like we have your screen up now.
Yeah, yeah.
Actually, you're minding me on the boba thing.
Don't let me forget.
Oh, yeah.
We should get some snacks.
Yeah, yeah.
I asked earlier an agent to spin up some 3D demos to get a sense of, you know, how we might,
you know, bring in some 2D or 3D.
Oh, yeah.
Let me zoom in.
Yeah.
Well, let me just see if I can just pinch to zoom.
Yeah, there we go.
Yeah.
It's a video.
We'll slow it down a little bit.
And so what's cool about this is the cursor agent, you know, prototypes and stuff, and then
also went ahead and took a video of how this would look.
And so, eh, did okay at that.
You can kind of see it.
Wait, is this supposed to be 3D?
I think it's told itself this is a 2.5D tape clash.
Oh, interesting.
And so I think it gave itself a couple of different prototypes.
This is slam 3D.
Let's see what slam 3D is.
That's kind of cool.
Okay, let's see if we can-
Why is it so fast?
Oh, did you put it on?
Well, I think it's just the-
It doesn't have a good sense of the game engine yet, but-
We'll need to fix that.
Mash, mash, mash.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's another one here.
That was a 2.5D.
There's another one I think we had going on-
I almost wonder if you actually need to explicitly say let use 3.js maybe.
Yeah.
With the 3D.
I'll try prompting for that.
I was hoping we'd have some other videos to see.
Okay.
You can see a sense of how these would look.
These are more static, but-
A lot of PRs are getting merged.
Nice.
We have our bot factory in full swing.
Love it.
Okay.
How's our task list look in Notion?
Can we pull that back up?
Oh, cool.
I did actually get the videos in GrokBot.
That's what I was hoping would happen.
So there we go.
We got these videos in GrokBot to take a look at what we just saw.
So we can actually just do this in GrokBot.
Again, the animation speed is not perfect, but-
We can give it some feedback here.
Someone in the chat also mentioned that maybe we should have some game music.
I actually forgot entirely about music.
Oh, we totally forgot about music.
Or audio.
I don't know.
That could be fun to add later.
Let's actually add that in.
Where's our PM?
Let's add a task to the Notion list for sound design.
I'm actually curious.
Do we have plugins that help you make sound?
How does that work?
I'm not sure.
We'll probably find out.
We'll probably wonder if we could just engineer some quick sound effects.
Probably do some 8-bit type stuff for you.
Yeah.
That seems like it would be-
Would it be annoying?
It would probably be annoying, yeah.
I mean, we could make it good though.
Yeah, I'm going to make a new bot that will help us explore some sound design for the game.
We have a task on the Notion board, so we should be able to just pick up that task and run with it.
I want some really high-level exploration.
Maybe we could explore some styles that are 8-bit music or something that we're generating.
And it should be not too annoying.
I find annoying sounds are always the worst when you're especially on a web browser and you don't expect the music to be playing.
So yeah, let's spin up a bot whose job it is to be our audio engineer and go figure out some prototypes for that.
Would it be worth, since we're going to generate these songs-
Oh, I didn't read the whole problem, but maybe we could put them all into Notion.
Oh yeah, that's a good idea.
Into our backlog and then we can review it later as a team.
Yeah.
Since we're trying to move more into tracking everything with Notion.
Cool.
I also like to give your bots feedback.
See, as soon as Dr. Eggbot spins up a bot here, I'm going to let it know that we want our audio designs to live in Notion.
Well, a lot of PRs got merged.
What a good name for a bot.
Okay, we have Tone, who's our audio sound engineer.
Make, drop the audio in Notion BTW, so we can all listen and check it out.
Thank you.
Roshan, do you want to share the Eggbot promotion again before we cut back to the main stage?
Oh yeah, I didn't realize we were losing, got so into the build that we are going to be cutting back to the main stage in just a minute.
So yeah, let me cut over here to our Eggbot promotion.
So for those of you who are just joining or if you missed this earlier, we are giving away some free Grokbot if you want to be able to build the way we've been building or want to be able to try Grokbot out for any of the use cases you've heard today.
We showed a bunch of really fun, you know, personal use cases, being able to print newsletters.
If we can actually get our camera off of the overlay, this will make the QR code easy for folks to see and stop covering that up.
Thank you very much.
If you want some free Grokbot, you can follow these steps.
$200 in value, so a really great deal here.
The first 1,000 users exclusively on stream, the first 1,000 users who duplicate and create a bot with Dr. Eggbot will get a chance to get a free month of Grokbot.
And so hopefully you guys get to try this out and hopefully you've seen us use Dr. Eggbot over the course of the day to create a bunch of bots of our own.
It's really great. Highly recommend it.
So up next with that, we're going to go to Grokbot for customer support on the main stage and we'll be back right after that.
Nice.
Hey, everyone. Thank you for joining today's workshop on Grokbot for customer support.
My name is David and I am a software engineer here at SpaceX AI in the user ops org.
I'm really excited to share what we've been working on and how we're using Grokbot for customer support.
So here's the agenda for today.
I'm going to quickly give some context on Grokbot in case you haven't been watching the live stream or been to one of the other sessions.
Then I'll share a few specific use cases for it around customer support.
Then I'll demo a lot of these.
My goal is that the session is a little bit more demo heavy so you can really see it in action.
And finally, we'll finish with some Q&A.
So let's get started.
So first, what is Grokbot?
Grokbot is a new product that lets you hand off real work to an AI coworker.
The interface looks very familiar, just like a messenger app on your phone or a computer.
But under the hood, it's built to keep working after you've sent your original message.
So you aren't just chatting back and forth with quick, simple one-offs here and there.
You're really able to delegate a real project to Grokbot and it can go off and take it from there.
One of my favorite things about Grokbot is how flexible it is to the way you work.
So you can start with a single general bot to help you get set up quickly and easily.
Or create a team of specialists that coordinate around the task and work in parallel on certain subtasks.
And however your team operates, Grokbot can fit in and be very useful very quickly.
So why Grokbot?
Why does it feel like interacting with a capable coworker rather than just another AI tool?
For me, there are three big reasons.
First, Grokbot is always on.
So by now you may have heard that Grokbots have their own computer.
All that really means is that they can work without using yours, which is a little bit more powerful than you would think.
So if you close your laptop or you are working on something else, your Grokbots can still finish the task you assigned them
without you having to check in constantly and steer them too much or slowing down your local machine.
There are also routines, which are cron jobs or event-based triggers that you can launch your Grokbots with and make them super reactive.
This way you don't have to be online at the exact moment you want them to run or start working on the task.
And these are super simple to set up.
All you have to do is tell it, create a routine at this time or on this event, just like a normal conversation.
And it will set it up for you.
Second, it is really easy to use.
The interface is familiar for a reason.
You don't have to be an engineer that is familiar with the ins and outs of an IDE to use bots effectively.
You can just talk with it normally like you would a friend or teammate on Slack.
And finally, it fits how you actually work.
There are already connectors for most tools you use.
You just have to go into the marketplace and search for them.
And there is likely one for you.
So you can plug Grokbot immediately into your ticketing system,
whether that's Plane, Zendesk, Intercom, where your team chats like Slack,
where your knowledge base is like Notion.
And then from there, you can use the bots and routines like building blocks
that fit the way your team actually works.
And one really powerful thing about Grokbot is if there is a missing piece,
you can likely have Grokbot build it.
Grokbot has access to cloud agents.
So if there is something that you're missing,
you can just have it tell it to spin up a cloud agent to build a certain connector
or a certain thing, and it can go off and do it for you.
So you can get creative and build around,
and you're not stuck waiting on Eng Roadmap or a third-party vendor
to add support for the thing you need.
Cool.
Now we'll get into some customer support use cases.
So the big one is always, can it answer support tickets?
The answer is yes.
And I'll show this later in the demo.
I know this can be scary at first to let an agent sort of reply to your customers.
So you can definitely build up to it.
So you can crawl, then walk, then run.
At first, you can have it just read tickets.
Maybe give you a summary and the root issue of what the user is asking about.
And maybe it can draft a response.
Then you can have it add the draft to a note in your ticketing system on the ticket.
So you can sort of see it before you press send.
And finally, when you're confident, then you can have an answer and actually respond to the ticket and the user.
There's also things you can do around the guardrails and environment you give GrothBot.
So you can set up evals and traces fairly easily so you know what it's thinking and what actions it will take before it publishes.
So when you can add traces to those draft steps and then sort of make sure it's behaving the way you want it to before going on.
Cool.
The second one.
So at scale, you may have a lot of support tickets with a ton of different customer states.
And it can be really challenging to find the things you should care about in that exact moment that need your attention.
GrothBot can make this a lot easier through alerting.
So you can spin up a bot that looks for certain things.
For example, maybe your team is hyper focused on churn this quarter.
And you want to know when someone writes in that is threatening to churn that has been a customer for six months or more.
Anyone on your team can spin up a GrothBot that you have connected to your ticketing system.
You can just tell it to create a routine that looks through your tickets.
Every hour classifies if a user is threatening to churn and has been a customer for a certain period of time.
And then send you an alert in the Slack channel so everyone has visibility.
Yeah.
And another one that maybe is more powerful than you think or is harder to get to than you think is an internal question and answer agent.
So if you've used other support agents, they are primarily focused on customer replies.
It's surprisingly cumbersome to leverage the knowledge knowledge base you've already sort of created or accumulated to answer your own teammates questions.
You may have someone in GTM that is trying to get up to speed on today's release about cloud agents.
So they can come prepared to a customer call or a TSE manager looking for changes to the internal refund policy over time and if that has impacted certain customers.
You have already done the hard work of creating this knowledge base of both public info so think your docs and help center as well as likely some internal info so you might have suggested operating procedures around how your teammates handle refunds.
So that is not public information.
You should be able to query this intelligently within Slack and GrokBot makes this really easy.
And maybe the last one and one of the cooler ones is it can improve itself.
So finally, you can give GrokBot your traces or have it look back on the last week of tickets and sort of ask it to look and try to find improvements for tickets that maybe could have been handled better,
could have been flagged earlier, and it can go and do those things for you.
Cool.
So next we're going to get into the demo.
I have created this demo.
I have a team of four bots.
They are build, so it sort of runs the setup and the infrastructure reply.
So this actually answers users in both our ticketing system and then Slack.
There is an alert.
So this one usually gets pinged by reply and post an alert in Slack and tags me.
And then tune, which tries to improve the system as we go.
I want to call out that you definitely do not have to have these in mind or set them up before getting started.
In fact, I don't recommend that.
Instead, you can start with one bot, name it a generic name, and try to teach it one workflow.
Then when the scope grows or you need more than one running at a time, I recommend breaking them up naturally then and reorganizing them in a way that makes sense to you.
Cool.
So now I'll get into the demo.
I have GrockBot set up with the bots we mentioned.
And then I have a few things that might look familiar if you are inside of a support org.
So first we have a knowledge base.
Right now I just set this up in Notion as an example.
So we have public docs.
So think of this as, like, this could be your documentation or your help center that has a few things on product and common issues like auth and billing and an FAQ.
Oh, I should have mentioned that I'm going to use the fly-low example that you may have seen in other ones, other presentations.
So this is basically like a pretend airline.
And I'm going to simplify it.
So the only, like, skew we have is a monthly internet subscription that is billed monthly and is $20 a month.
Cool.
So we have this public information that a user could find if they searched Google.
We have some internal policies.
So right now this is stuff that we want maybe a billing support member to know if you have a human answering, but you don't want to share broadly with the public.
So this is just a very simple example of if a user asks for a refund, you can approve it within 14 days and cancel and refund.
If they've been subscribed for more than 14 days, deny the refund.
And then finally, I just have a little bit of process for the GrokBot agent reply to use when replying to some of these tickets.
So we just have this loop of what it should do, read the ticket, look for the knowledge, and then decide to reply or handoff, and then act, leave a note, and yeah.
Cool.
This is plane.
This is our ticketing system.
So I've already prefilled a few example tickets, and we'll walk through those.
I have Stripe pulled up as well.
So I mentioned there's a subscription that users may pay for that is basically the Wi-Fi pass on a plane.
And then I have Slack that I'll pull up for later.
Cool.
So first, let's start with maybe this first ticket.
So I'm going to go through alphabetical.
So this is just a very basic question.
I forgot my password.
How can I sign in?
Or how do I reset it?
So let me ask GrokBot to try to reply to this.
So like I mentioned, I have the GrokBots I mentioned.
There is build.
So I've already set up some of the connectors to make this a little quicker.
So I've added plane.
I've added Notion, Supabase, and Slack.
So if you aren't familiar, you can just click the marketplace and search and click and install.
Cool.
So let's tell reply, hi, can you reply to Alex in plane?
And it is going to go off and try to reply.
So let's see.
It's going to look it up.
I pulled up.
So basically, while I wait for it to reply, it's going to go through this process.
So I've sort of made this loop pretty simple of just what I wanted to do, how I wanted to behave, and sort of show some thinking.
And we'll see that it replied.
Okay, cool.
It replied.
It said it replied.
If I go back into the ticket, you see that it followed the sort of tracing, or it followed the process that I gave it.
So it showed some of its thinking where it says it can reply with high confidence, the root issue, and the source that it referenced to answer the question.
Cool.
And then it gave the right information.
So these are the exact steps on this public auth forgot your password.
So if we go to public auth forgot your password, these are the exact steps.
Cool.
So that's obviously a pretty basic example.
But let's go on to a harder one.
So this is an example of something that is not covered in the toy knowledge base we created, so some SSO Okta stuff.
Let's see.
I'm going to try to prompt it so it will try to reply, but in the instructions, I told it to not reply unless it's pretty confident.
Try replying to Ben.
And playing.
And once again, it's going to go through the exact same process.
If I were to change something in this sort of loop, it would-- I've already told it to make sure to read this every single time.
So if I were to add maybe seven and some other step, it would know to do that after every time.
So let's wait on that for a few more seconds.
And let's make sure I have Slack pulled up for later.
Cool.
Okay.
Nice.
So it says it tried to do that, but there's no public docs or internal policies.
So low confidence and handoff, which is exactly what we wanted it to do.
And then you'll notice that this is new.
So it messaged alert.
So I've set up that if something-- if it looks like maybe an enterprise customer that's locked out to make sure to alert me so I can know in real time.
Alert activated and posted to Slack.
And our alerts DG channel, it is this one.
So yeah.
So now I am-- without too much work, I can already see in real time that important tickets that I need to maybe action on right now.
Cool.
Let's go on for now.
So I'm going to mark this done for now and go on to the next one.
So the next one is going to be two refund-related tickets.
I mentioned at the beginning that we have an SOP specifically around that.
So we have two users, Carter and Damon.
If I go into Stripe and click into them, I've set it up where Carter just subscribed and is requesting a refund.
So today is September 16th, so his renews in exactly a month.
So we should grant him this refund.
And then Damon, you'll see that it renews in about 10 days.
So it's already been-- call it 20 days, which is-- and our policy is only 14 days within.
So it should deny Damon and grant the refund to Carter.
And it will-- we've already set up Stripe, so it can take these actions for you.
You can set it up to have you approve the actions, or you can tell it-- let it run loose.
Okay.
So let's say, okay, now try to answer Carter and Damon.
And this one may take a second, because it's going to run through the loop, sort of make the call,
and then if it needs to, it will have to run the actions through Stripe.
So let me have those pulled up.
And we'll see this state get changed here shortly.
Let me pass in the customer IDs.
Maybe it'll make it quicker.
Cool.
Let's-- it should be on its way now.
So it's thinking it found them now, and it says both replies are already up.
So let's go look at them.
Cool.
So it just answered.
For Carter, like I mentioned, it should have canceled and issued a refund.
It's saying that it did that.
If we go to Carter in Stripe and refresh, the status should have just changed.
So next, it went from active to canceled, and this payment has been refunded.
And then that is what we-- that's what it said it did.
And then for Damon, it says we have denied your refund.
It didn't give like the full SOP, so it didn't leak the internal information.
It was just vague.
And then it says I can cancel-- I can schedule a cancellation for you at the end of your period
so you don't get billed for the next month.
And then if we go to Damon and refresh, this should all stay the same.
And it does.
Cool.
Great.
Okay.
So now we'll go on to the next one.
So Elena is asking if we can-- if she can share her Wi-Fi pass with another person.
This is something that's not actively in the knowledge base.
So let's see how it handles it.
It would be under public docs.
Let me leave that.
And it would likely go here.
Cool.
So let's tell reply.
Let's clear that out.
Great.
Can you reply to Elena now?
Okay.
And it should go from there.
So it's already come back with some thinking.
It's found the ticket, and it's checking-- it's sort of already classified that pass-sharing
is the root issue and looking if it's in public docs.
And now it's saying that it couldn't reply yet because public docs and FAQ doesn't have pass-sharing.
And it's recommending to tell Tune, which is the self-improver, to add it to the knowledge base.
So yes, we'll say add pass-sharing to the FAQ.
Say this is not allowed.
So this is an example of it asking before it doing something by itself.
So for your knowledge base, this is probably something you want just to make sure you have
the final say over what happens because if this were to go out without you looking and you didn't check it
and it wasn't correct and 100 people asked about the same thing, then yeah, that'd be an issue.
Okay.
So it says it added it to the knowledge base.
I told it to do it in green so we can delineate it.
And it just did.
So pass-sharing, no, you cannot share your Wi-Fi pass with another person for simultaneous use.
Great.
Let's see.
I actually had one more thing pulled up.
Okay.
Actually, let's skip that then.
Cool.
So back to GrokBot then.
It's -- we've added the knowledge.
So now let's try to respond.
So in the ticket, it left a note saying to hand off that the information was missing and it still needs a response.
So let's tell a reply.
Okay.
Can you try again now?
That the information is added.
And it says it's answering.
And it says it's replied now.
It's replied now.
So now we have a new sort of thinking note.
Now it can reply with high confidence.
There's a root issue.
And it links to the new section in Docs that covers it.
So you cannot share your Wi-Fi pass with another person.
Great.
That's exactly what we wanted.
Let's mark this one as done.
Cool.
That covers a lot of it.
Now let's go to the other -- one of the other use cases I mentioned.
So if we go into Slack, we've already seen that it can send us alerts.
But we have another use case where you can have your teammates ask the bot you've already
set up to answer customers and the knowledge base to answer your own teammates.
So let's say I am someone on your billing team.
And I want to know what is the refund SOP.
So this is -- I'm an internal user.
I'm asking a question.
And it should give me the internal knowledge for it.
So that's the most helpful.
So we've sent it.
This may take about a minute.
But yeah, we should see us getting a response here pretty soon.
Cool.
So it's asking for permission to post in Slack.
Let's say always allow for this.
And it should reply here in a second.
Thank you.
Oh, okay. Let's try that again.
Let's make sure it's running.
Did you see the message?
Okay, it's going.
I ran this right before, so you can see that this is what would happen.
It would reply and go from there.
Let's give it maybe 10 more seconds.
If not, we can go on.
Okay, now it says it's replied.
Great.
So it added the emoji and it replied.
Awesome.
So that's the one of the other use cases.
Cool.
So that wraps.
I'm going to cut the demo there.
So what we learned.
First, you can and should feel comfortable setting guardrails for your bots.
You can see, saw maybe at the end there it was even more protective than I wanted it to be, but that's probably better for writes.
Have them be read-only to start and then work up to writes and have manual approvals for certain actions.
You can also scope permissions to your different bots.
So one bot might have permission to post automatically to Slack, one might not and make them approve those actions before they do them.
Second, start simple.
So the whole product is still so new.
I don't think there's one meta or one clear playbook.
And the product is meant to be very flexible.
So try to make the bots fit into how you work and not vice versa.
Third, try to get a little creative and experiment.
You can really have it build what is missing.
Cool.
Thank you so much.
That is the rest of the presentation.
And we can go into Q&A.
Oh, yeah.
So any questions?
Yes.
What's the price like for this?
So it uses your usage that you would have through any of your Grok subscriptions or currently cursor subscriptions.
So it just tracks usage.
I'll say it can really depend on how involved your loops are.
So if you have classifiers that run before every ticket.
If you have it right traces and evals before doing that, that can also change.
So right now, the way I use it, it's around $1 to $2 to answer more medium to complex tickets.
And there are ways -- I've already tried to like experiment and found ways to get that down a lot.
So there are a lot of maybe low-complexity billing tickets of like a user just asking for a refund or a user asking about a certain new email they received.
You can sort of bucket those, you can run a script, have it run a script to find those first or run that manually so it has more of a contained sort of set.
And then have it reply all at once with the script to those tickets.
And I found that I could get that down to about $0.20 a ticket for those like low-complexity tickets, which is a huge sort of change.
If you've used any of the other sort of support agents, you know that like the cost per -- they usually charge per resolution.
And that's easily at minimum $1, if not between $1 to $10, like order of magnitude.
And if you're having humans respond to those tickets, that can be even higher -- noticeably higher.
So -- and that's just like with half a day of trying to improve it.
I think there's a lot of gains and unlocks there, especially.
How would you interrogate what's going on if something goes wrong, especially with like communication in between multiple bots?
Communicate -- yeah, so one thing I didn't show in the demo is I set up --
evals and traces for every run, especially for the reply bot.
So this is pretty basic.
So all it is is you have like a Postgres database.
Tell it to like create a table for eval runs or for a set of evals.
So things you want to test every single time you like make a change.
And then another table for traces.
So every time reply runs, I ask it how long it took, what files it looked at, what files it ended up choosing to reply.
So usually it's like a filtered down list.
And then from there you can usually decipher where it went wrong or things like that.
And that's something you set up in the reply bot configuration?
Or is that like a meta, you know, bot that's looking at the whole system?
So I set it up just with a connector with Supabase.
So I didn't show it in the demo.
But I just set up a connector with -- to the build bot with Supabase.
Told that it has access to Postgres now.
Create traces and evals table.
Write to those tables every time I ask you to run an eval or create a new eval.
Or run a trace or answer a ticket even if it's internal, external, even if it's a dry run ticket.
So even if it's just leaving a note on the plain ticket, still writing a trace.
So then I can have like a log of how it's thinking about it and what it's looking at.
And then you can also have the -- once you have that, you can also have the like self-improvement bot look at those and try to improve the system.
I think that's a big unlock.
Awesome. Thank you.
Yeah.
Yeah, and I'm just -- I was thinking about customer support with like phone calls.
I'm curious if you've -- I've seen like someone has set up GrokBot with like a phone.
I'm curious if you've seen any interesting cases of that yet or if you've played with it at all.
I haven't done it too much.
I know Matt on the stream has set it up.
He has a good video on Twitter of like giving it -- giving his GrokBot a phone number.
And I think trying to make a reservation with that.
I think that's something that's like definitely will be the case and want to explore.
So if you do it, let me know for sure.
I'll play around with it for sure.
Yeah, cool.
How do you guys think about implementing this for non-technical folks in the enterprise?
Because I'm kind of concerned if a non-technical user is writing stuff to Postgres or without like guardrails on.
So the -- sorry, I might have misheard the first part of it.
You're asking about non-technical users and how they would plug into this and if there's any concerns.
Well, I guess like because it's relatively easy to spin up a bot to do whatever you need.
And how do you put the guardrails so that they don't like mess up like the production databases or anything like that, right?
Because it's relatively easy to be like, oh, refund all the customers that are, you know, that should be refunded.
But then they don't know the technicalities of some of the backend stuff.
Yeah, that's a great question.
I know there's a lot of sort of effort into making this more multiplayer shortly.
Right now, I'd say like whenever you first set it up to set the guard -- whoever's first setting it up maybe can be like slightly more technical or not even more technical,
but just aware of sort of like system architectures of like, okay, if someone is going to run this Glockbot, I'm going to give them a template.
And someone non-technical, I'll share a template with them that says, oh, you can't update the knowledge base by yourself.
One thing that I've tried that I like a lot is using -- I use Notion as the knowledge base sort of just as like an easier example.
But you can use GitHub or origin, and that's really powerful because the primitives of GitHub are like -- you get PRs, you get code owners, you get branches, all that stuff.
So instead of this knowledge base where there's only sort of one, you could give someone a template on their like self-improvement bot.
So if you create for them, you could say, oh, you have to create a PR, it has to get reviewed by bug bot, it has to ping me, I have to approve it.
And I can run the building blocks of like evals and traces.
I can tell it to run the evals against a specific PR branch instead of just main, so I can have the output of that, have some confidence that it's going to behave how I want it to behave.
And then make sure it gets approved by the code owner or the person that's most in charge or most technical.
And you'll have confidence then of -- they can still make updates, they can still be helpful, but they're not sort of -- you're not taking on a ton of additional risk.
Awesome, thank you.
Yeah.
One question for Max.
Is it more token efficient to queue and bulk ask requests?
Sorry, what was that?
Just bulking together.
Yeah, so it can be.
So instead of -- I guess if you saw how I was talking to it of just like tell it to reply to Alex, that is pretty unclear.
So I could have been more clear by like giving it a set of ticket IDs.
Whenever I tell it like that, it has to be like go look, go find, maybe read, call the plain MCP, get all the open tickets, look through, do a string search on Alex, try to find them.
That is a lot less token efficient than, you know, giving it more hard details they can look up easier.
I guess one last question for Max.
As Roshan, Matt, and Lauren have been creating their company online, do you have any recommendations on what to set up first for a customer support team using GrockBot?
Yeah, that's a great question.
I know maybe their sort of business has changed a little bit, but I'd say usually there's about like, there's usually like an 80/20 of 20% of use cases that create 80% of the ticket volume.
I would try to identify those and have something in place and make sure those are in the knowledge base first and have GrockBot have really good knowledge and SOPs there and run evals and test and make sure everything it can handle it is.
And then, yeah, put GrockBot in front of it and try to answer.
Cool, amazing.
I think I am out of time and I'm going to send it back to the studio.
Thank you.
Awesome.
Welcome back, everyone.
Hope everyone enjoyed that last talk.
We're winding up our day pretty soon here and I think it's been a pretty fun one.
We got a bunch of stuff done, we have an app running and we're really excited about some of the progress we've made today.
We thought we'd kind of wrap up just kind of showing you some of the things that we were working on in the background during that last segment.
A few things that we kicked off before we got started, if you want to bring my screen up here on the menu.
We kicked off a few bots that were working on a number of tasks.
Again, for those who are just joining, we're building a gaming company and a gaming business as part of our 72 hour live stream here where we ship a product by Thursday.
And what's been really fun about this is actually we're starting to get a little more creative with it.
And so one of the things I did before we went off on to the last segment was spin up a bot here.
That's our audio engineer who's been working on a bunch of cool audio.
And, you know, unfortunately, can we get a mic for GrokBot?
I think that'd be really helpful.
So we can kind of go through some of these.
Oh, love it. Okay.
I'm showing this up as loud as I can.
Thank you so much.
So our bot here has been dumping some audio into an ocean doc.
We thought it'd be fun to go through these live and see what we came up with.
So we have some tones that we didn't like, but let's take a look at some of these lobby songs for our game.
A little quiet.
It sounds very, it sounds very calm.
It does sound very calm.
Very soothing.
But this is kind of wild.
The bot just kind of came up with these.
And if you haven't seen it before, this is using Strudel, which is really cool.
So I just told the bot to learn how to make Strudel apps.
And you can just go in here and hit play and just kind of make some pretty cool music.
Maybe not the exact vibe for our game, since I think we want something a little less chiptune-y maybe, or a little less pixel art.
So what I also did was ask my bot here to give me some prompts for Suno and just generated some tracks on Suno.
So we'll see how some of these sound.
That's a little too sad.
It's a kind of somber, yeah.
Let's see what else we've got.
I don't like it.
That feels more on brand.
It's also a little like...
Whimsical.
Very whimsical, yes.
I feel like I'm a wizard about to go on a quest.
Okay, those are pretty similar.
Alright, we're not a rom-com.
And then right before we came on stream, I tried to generate a few more.
I haven't actually heard these before.
Let's see if they work.
Ooh.
Whoa.
Damn.
That's some good battle music.
I kind of like that.
Okay.
A few more.
Oh, this is good.
For the draft room while we're kind of waiting and you're building your team.
Draft room energy.
Okay.
I kind of like these.
I feel like we've got something here that we might be able to play with.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Grock pot microphone.
Thank you, production.
Awesome.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
I feel like we have some pretty good art direction happening, right?
We have some UI that we've built.
But maybe to kind of share where we're ending up, Lauren, you want to show how the app is looking?
Can we switch to Lauren's screen on the screen?
Yeah.
Can we switch to my screen?
A lot of things don't work yet, but we've hooked up the backend.
So I've logged into my real X account and there's a leaderboard with nobody in it yet.
I can start a new match.
I don't have any bots yet.
And I just realized there's a bug.
So I can't actually add any bots yet.
But what we're going to do is we have some UI that we've built, right?
We have some UI that we've built.
Maybe to kind of share where we're ending up, Lauren, you want to show how the app is looking?
Yeah.
Can we switch to Lauren's screen on the screen?
Can we switch to my screen?
A lot of things don't work yet, but we've hooked up the backend.
So I've logged into my real X account and there's a leaderboard with nobody in it yet.
I can start a new match.
I don't have any bots yet.
And I just realized there's a bug, so I can't actually add any bots yet.
But when this works, I will be able to import any bot with a link.
I'll probably have to think a little bit about how to like...
I feel like this UI is not very user-friendly, but we'll iterate.
But yeah, for now, you'll just like, you know, paste a Dr. Egg bot link in here.
You'll create it.
Then it shows up and you can actually start playing a game.
But right now, yeah.
This is really cool.
While you're doing that, I just logged in as well on my end.
And I can log in with X.
Oh, okay, cool.
So we have logging in with X working.
Oh, did you log in already?
Yeah, I just did.
So we have @Roshan_X.
I see.
Well, yeah, I think I need to fix the leaderboard.
Okay.
I would expect the two of us to show up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So there's a bug I need to fix.
Yeah.
We're both gold at 1,000.
But hey, we both have accounts.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We didn't have accounts a long ago.
And very soon, maybe tomorrow, we'll come back with...
I think we're gonna go and get this deployed.
Maybe think of an actual good name for this game and start playing tomorrow with chat.
Yeah.
So if you're excited to tune in tomorrow, we're gonna get everyone into this game.
We've got to make it go viral.
We have one day to grow our business.
Yeah, we're gonna iterate.
We're gonna make it really, really fun.
And we'll get feedback.
We'll have a little factory going.
Yeah.
And we'll try to make this game real.
PRs are being merged.
Like our bots, we had some bots earlier that are kind of listening for all the PRs.
And it's a constant stream.
I don't know, Lauren, if you want to show us what you're...
Well, I mean, my bots are just chugging on.
I have so many bots now.
Like since we last talked, I have...
Well, we have Whisk, our game designer.
We have Crum, a new bot that I just made, who's our play tester.
It was actually just going in to the application and just like clicking around, making sure it works.
So my idea here is that I want to have a play tester bot that's just gonna keep playing the game.
Checking for bugs.
But I haven't taught it how to like, you know, give feedback on the game itself.
That would be really interesting to set up.
And then I also obviously have...
Oh, another thing I kicked off, which I recommend doing.
Since we're kind of like close to the end of the stream very soon.
Is I often like talk to Dr. Eggbot.
You know, as I create new bots, just think about like...
Like here's what I told it.
You know, zoom out from a high level.
Consider my goals.
Review all our bots.
Like where are our bottlenecks?
How can we speed up and tighten my workflow?
And then Dr. Eggbot will actually look at all the transcripts, the chats of all the bots that you've created and analyze it and try to figure out like, where can you improve your workflow?
So, it's got a few things like bottlenecks.
You know, the serial factory, human merge.
Yeah, that's, you know, that's a bottleneck, right?
And merge still waits on me.
Lauren as the interrupt bus.
So, you know, I'm still kind of like playing a lot of...
I'm still very in the loop right now.
Which I sort of want at least for the... while we're prototyping.
But as we start to actually, you know, get feedback and I'm going to try and make this more autopilot.
But yeah.
The autopilot part is super cool because then it's just like, you know, we get to just basically be directors of features, right?
We get to say we want to do X and then like the whole engine behind this will just like go and build features for us.
Make sure it's play tested.
Do our QA.
Make sure there's no regressions.
I'm really excited when we get to that.
I'm hoping like tomorrow we can just rip a bunch of features in and I think this will be really cool.
Yeah.
Matt, any updates on your end?
So we've been working on the ads side.
Just cranking along there.
And then I also was just testing out the app.
So I'm going to have the ads marketplace up hopefully tomorrow.
I think we're going to crank there.
This is my writing bot template that is currently open.
But if we pop on over to I think the ads MVP.
I haven't tested this out just yet.
We're going to need to take a look at what we're doing in the database and probably like run through some of this.
I also haven't refactored like basically rebased onto all the changes that Lauren made.
So a little bit behind here.
But that will be a sprint for tomorrow.
Nice.
Cool.
I think we had a pretty good day, right?
I think we ended up making a lot of progress.
We went from no app to an app.
And not just an app, but like an app with an engine and a bunch of bots that have basically done all the work for us today.
We got to spend some time looking at Cursor, which I think was great.
And getting to use some agents and show off things like multitask mode and design mode.
We got to make some music.
It's pretty fun.
We talked to a bunch of fun guests.
So yeah, overall, I think it's been a really great day and pretty excited to come back tomorrow.
I have a bug.
Oh.
I'm fixing that.
No, you're already on it.
I want to do this.
Great job then.
Yeah, very soon.
Like tonight, I think we'll have like a few games.
Okay.
Maybe we can see how fun it is.
Nice.
Kind of get some cool ideas for tomorrow.
Love it.
Before we wrap, wanted to switch back to my screen to remind you all that you can win some free GrokBot.
So if you want to build what we've been building, build the way we've been building, install Pstack, install DrEggBot, become acquainted with all these bots that we've created today.
You can follow these steps to get a free month of GrokBot, which is $200 in value.
So a free month of GrokBot at a really great tier as well.
You just need to duplicate and create a bot with DrEggBot and use this QR code to do so.
You will get a free month of GrokBot.
This is only available to our first 1,000 users who claim the offer and exclusively for folks who are watching on stream.
So if you want some free GrokBot, get in there.
Definitely get yourself set up.
We'll be back tomorrow to share even more of how we continue to build this app.
And I'm excited to finish strong.
Sounds good.
Thanks, y'all, for watching.
Thanks, chat.
See you tomorrow.
Bye.